IN SESSION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF
A QUORUM THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS
WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER. AND
BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRO
BURKE CALDERON RIO CERVANTES
CHAO JUNE DAVID CHIU CHOI
KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY THE-
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN SU CHI
THIS AREA OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON DOORS QUIRK QUIRK
SILVA RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE
REEBOKS ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
STONE TEAM VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER
WICKS WORD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR WE HAVE A BUSY DAY AHEAD
OF US PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR. AS SOON AS PRACTICABLE.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER. IN
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ELOISE REYES
ASSEMBLY MEMORIES. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN FOR. AS A BODY I PRAY
THAT WE ARE READY TO FACE THE
ISSUES THAT PLAGUE OUR
COMMUNITIES SO WE CAN CHANGE
THEM. I PRAY THAT WE BE THE
CHANGE WE CLAIMED AND PROMISED
OUR COMMUNITIES WOULD BE. I
PRAY THAT JUST AS THE EVIL HAS
DEEP ROOTS. THAT WE PREPARE
OURSELVES FOR THE VERY HARD
WORK NEEDED TO GET TO THOSE
DEEP ROOTS. LORD HELP US TO
HEAR THE RIGHTEOUS DEMANDS FROM
OUR COMMUNITY. HELP US TO ROUTE
OUT OF THE EVIL OF RACISM
DISCRIMINATION MARGINALIZATION
AND HUMILIATION. LET US PRAY
THAT THE EVIL OF SOME NOT BE
IMPUTED ON ALL. HELP US TO
RECOGNIZE THAT ALL OF YOUR
CHILDREN ARE IMPORTANT TO YOU
AND ALL OF THEIR LIVES MATTER
TO YOU. BUT HELP WAS ALSO TO
UNDERSTAND THE PARABLE OF THE
SHEPHERD WE HAD ONE HUNDRED
SHEEP. AND FOUND THAT ONE WAS
IN NEED HE LEFT JUST NINETY
NINE TO HELP THE ONE. THE
NINETY NINE WE'RE STILL
IMPORTANT TO HIM. BUT THE ONE
NEEDED HELP AT THAT MOMENT. HE
DIRECTED ALL OF HIS ATTENTION
TO THE ONE. REMIND US LORD WHY
WE FOUGHT TO BE HERE IT WAS TO
CARE FOR THOSE WHO NEEDED
REPRESENTATION. WE ARE AT A
CROSSROADS AND WE SEEK WISDOM.
THE COMMUNITY IS NO LONGER
ASKING THE COMMUNITY IS
RIGHTEOUSLY DEMANDING. HELP US
TO HEAR THEM. WHEN THOSE
UNAFFECTED HERE THE LAST WORDS
OF A MAN BEGGING FOR WATER FOR
ERROR FOR LIFE. I PRAY THAT OUR
REACTION BE OUTRAGE. OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE BURDENED.
THEY'RE TIRED YET THEY ARE
UNIFIED. HELP US LORD TO
ADDRESS THE DEEP ROOTED
INEQUITIES IN RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE WRONG AND IN HUMANE.
WE HAVE NOT ALWAYS RESPONDED
APPROPRIATELY. HELP US TO BE
OUTRAGED THAT ANY HUMAN BEING
LIVES UNDER THESE CONDITIONS.
ALLOW US TO NEVER FORGET THE
PHRASE. I CAN'T BREATHE. AND
LET IT FOREVER BE A REMINDER TO
OUR DUTY TO DISMANTLE
STRUCTURES OF HATE AND
IGNORANCE LET THIS BE OUR CRY
AS WE MARCH FORWARD TO CREATE A
BETTER CALIFORNIA AND A BETTER
UNITED STATES. AND MAY WE ALL
SEE THAT WE WERE BORN FOR SUCH
A TIME AS THIS. AND MAY WE
CONTINUE THE WORK WE WERE SENT
HERE TO DO. A MAN. THANK YOU MS
RACE WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DALY AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER DAVID. PLEASE
JOIN ME. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA. AND TO THE REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY MARCH
SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
RECENTLY MET AT ONE PM YOUNG
WILL COVER MULLIN SPEAKER PRO
TEMPORE THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING
TWO CLERKS REPORTER PROTESTS
READING FOR KATHLEEN IN THOSE
READING THE ROLES CALLED SOME
REMEMBER BROKEN TO QUORUM CALL
THE SIMPLY MOTION CARRY TIME
ONE O'CLOCK PM THIS ORDER OR
CALDERON. MOVES MR LACKEY
SECONDS. THAT THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY. FOR MEDICAL LEAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK. AND
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
SHINS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE ITEM TO- FOR A. B.
THIRTY THREE THIRTY O'DONNELL
TO THE INACTIVE FILE. THE CLERK
WILL NOTE. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. ON RECONSIDERATION FILE
ITEMS ONE THROUGH FOUR ARE TO
BE CONTINUED. MISTER CALDERON
YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZE PROMOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
ADOPT THE FOLLOWING LIST OF
FLOOR MOMENTS BY VOICE VOTE.
FILE I'M FIFTY SEVEN AB TWENTY
NINETHIRTY TWO O'DONNELL FILE
ITEM SIXTY EIGHT A. B. THIRTY
TWO SEVENTY ONE KILEY NUMBER
SEVENTY ONE AB NINETEEN FIFTY
KAMLAGER. NUMBER SEVENTY TWO A.
B. NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
CRISTINA GARCIA NINETY TWO AB
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE RUBIO
NINETY SIX AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEPARATE US NUMBER ONE ELEVEN
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
STONE. NUMBER ONE FORTY TWO A.
B. THIRTY FIFTY SIX GONZALEZ
FOR FORTY FOUR A. B. THIRTY
SEVENTY FIVE AND SALAS NUMBER
ONE SIXTY SIX AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE. ROBERT RIVAS ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT AB TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO
MCCARTY ONE EIGHTY ONE AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY GRAYSON. ONE
EIGHTY THREE AB TWENTY FIVE A
ONE WOMAN. WITHOUT OBJECTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF ADOPTING
THE AMENDMENT SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO. THE AYES
HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
OUT TO PRINCE IN BACK ON FILE.
MOVING TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE FILE ITEMS FIVE.
THROUGH. FORTY FOUR. PASS AND
RETAIN.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY FIVE. FILE ITEM
FORTY FIVE IS AB. NINETEEN
TWENTY SEVEN. CORKERY BUT SOME
PEOPLE NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
ACCOLADE IN A CRIMINAL PROCESS
MISS BOERNER HORVATH YES MISTER
SPEAKER IS A MEMBERS I'M PROUD
TO PRESENT TODAY A LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL AB
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN WHICH
WOULD ESTABLISH A NARROW
AMNESTY CLAUSE TO ENCOURAGE
VICTIMS AND WITNESSES OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OR SEXUAL ASSAULT.
TO TESTIFY IN COURT HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
NATIONWIDE INCLUDING THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
ALREADY IMPLEMENTED AMNESTY
CLUB IS THE PROVIDE IMMUNITY
FROM THE CONSEQUENCES OF DRUG
AND ALCOHOL USE. REPORTING OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT CRIMES AB
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN SIX TO
EXTEND THE AMNESTY CLAUSE TO
ALL SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES IN CALIFORNIA THIS
BILL ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU IS
BOERNER HORVATH SEEING IT
THOUGH YES MS LEVEL. MS LEMOND
I THINK YES MISS THEM THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AS VICE CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN TWENTY
SEVEN ONE EVER CAUCUS PRIORITY
BILLS EVIDENCE HAS SHOWN THAT
THE RATE OF SEXUAL MILEY
INCREASES DURING STATES OF
EMERGENCY INCLUDING NATURAL
DISASTERS AND HEALTH CRISIS
ACCORDING TO A SURVEY BY THE
NATIONAL LINE TO AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT 30% EVERY PRICES
CENTERS. HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE
IN DEMAND FOR SERVICES SINCE
THE SHELTER PLACE ORDER TAKE A
FAX BEING SEXUALLY ASSAULTED IS
ONE OF THE MACHINE IN DO SEEN
FROM IS THAT A PERSON CAN
EXPERIENCE FOR THIS REASON THE
MAJORITY OF THE SEXUAL ASSAULTS
GO UNREPORTED IN SOME SEXUAL
ASSAULT CASES OUT ADDRESS WERE
CONSUMED ALL THE MORE REASON
FOR VICTIMS TO FEEL
APPREHENSIVE ABOUT COMING
FORWARD BELIEVING THAT SOMEHOW.
THEY BROUGHT ON THE CELL THIS.
THANK. IS SERVER. THAT THERE
ARE OR CONTROLLED SUB OF DURING
THE TIME OF CRIME COULD EXPOSE
THEM TOOK LIABILITY FOR THESE
THREE I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
VERY IMPORTANT MATTER. THANK
YOU MISS AMOUNT MS POWER QUE
HAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN- I JOIN
MISS LOW MOAN IN EXPRESSING MY
DEEP. APPRECIATION TO THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
AND FOR ENSURING THE WOMEN WHO
COME FORWARD WHEN THEY ARE
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT ARE
PROTECTED THIS IS NOT TO NINE
THE RIGHT OF ANY DEFENDANT IN
THEIR PRECEDING IT NEARLY
PROTECT THE VICTIM FROM A
FUTURE CRIMINAL ACTION AGAINST
THEM FOR THAT DRUG AND ALCOHOL
ABUSE AND IT IS CRITICAL THAT
WE KNOW VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT. ARE HESITANT TO SPEAK
OUT FOR FEAR OF MANY THINGS BUT
THEY SHOULD NOT BE ONE OF THEM
AND WE CAN TAKE A STEP TODAY TO
PROTECT THESE VICTIMS ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE NOT PROSECUTED
FOR THEIR SIMPLE DRUG USE AND
THAT WE REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
ACTUAL SALT ESPECIALLY ON OUR
COLLEGE CAMPUSES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS BARRICADE HAD.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM THIS
BOERNER HORVATH CHEMICALS YES
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. LOCAL OF THE
ROLE OF ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEMS FORTY SIX
THROUGH FORTY NINE PASS AND
RETAIN. FILE ITEM FIFTY. AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE BY MISTER
NAZARIAN COOKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS AREA IN THE BACK
RELATING TO THE BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT. MISTER NAZARIAN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET FOR
JANUARY FOR UP FROM JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY SIX
FOR THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO UTILIZE A
BEST VALUE BID EVALUATION AND
SELECTION PROCESS FOR PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS IN EXCESS OF ONE
MILLION THIS PROCESS HAS
ALLOWED LA U. S. THE TO LOOK AT
BIDDERS BASED ON SAFETY
FINANCIAL CONDITION INSURANCE
COVERAGE CRIMES AND MISCONDUCT
BONDING SETTLEMENTS AND
JUDGMENTS. AND FORCING THE
SELECTION OF A BITTER BE SOLELY
ON PRICE MAY RESULT UP PROJECT
DELAYS AND COST OVERRUNS THIS
BILL ALLOWS FOR MORE OBJECTIVE
CRITERIA FOR SELECTING BIDDERS
WHICH HAS SHOWN TO YIELD
POSITIVE BENEFITS IN SELECTING
QUALIFIED CONTRACTORS AND
COMPETITIVE PRICES. THIS BILL
IS AN OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER NAZARIAN. SEEING EMBER
SEEKING RECOGNITION. QUIRK
LIBERAL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. I. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO HELP.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I THREE FIVE KNOWS FOR THAT
MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTY ONE A. B. THIRTY
TWELVE BY DOCTOR WOULD COVERAGE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWELVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULDN'T OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE TO INSURANCE DOCTOR
WOULD THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ONE OF THE MANY CHANGES
BROUGHT ON BY THE 200-017-2000
EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES IS A
SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTION IN
CALIFORNIA'S HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE MARKET SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN NON
RENEWED BY THEIR INSURANCE
PROVIDERS AND FORCED INTO VERY
EXPENSIVE FAIR PLAN. WITH THE
PAST FOR YEARS WE HAVE WORKED
ON THIS IS THE CORRECT THIS
DESTRUCTION AB THIRTY TWELVE IS
NOT A SILVER BULLET BULLET BUT
I THINK IT'S A SERIES OF
BALANCE STEPS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RECEIVE NO
NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WITH MR DAILY URANUS. AUTHOR
THE BILL HI ROY TO SEE IT THE
BILL WILL HELP RETURN HOME WHO
WERE IN THE PLAN TO THE REGULAR
INSURANCE MARKETS IT WILL
CREATE A BETTER WAY FOR
HOMEOWNERS TO GET PAYMENT FOR
THEIR LOST POSSESSIONS AFTER
MAJOR WILDFIRE INVENT. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND THANK YOU MISTER WOULD.
THANK YOU QUESTION DALY. SEEING
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAKE
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE A-
CLERK WILL THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. IS THERE A VOTE.
THE CLERK WELL. CULTURAL TIED
ABOUT AYE SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEMS
FIFTY TWO AND FIFTY THREE PASS
RETAIN THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY FOUR AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY NINE BY MISS GONZALES
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY RULE
TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AN
ACCOLADE IN THE BUSINESS. MS
GONZALEZ YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER- ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE FORTY NINE IS
KNOWN AS A FAIR FOOD DELIVERY
ACT AND IT'S SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW- PEOPLE BEEN USING APPS TO
GET DELIVERY OF FOOD AND NOW
THESE RESTAURANTS ARE OPENING
UP WHAT THEY FOUND AND WHAT WAS
HAPPENING EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC IS OFTEN. WITHOUT
THEIR PERMISSION WITHOUT ANY
KIND OF AGREEMENT SOME OF THESE
APPS WERE POSTING- THEIR MENU
ONLINE THEY WERE DOING
DELIVERIES BUT THE RESTAURANT
SOUTH HAD NO CONTROL OVER THAT
SO SOMETIMES A MENU WOULD BE
WRONG IT HAD BEEN UPDATED OR
SOMETIMES THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
WAS BEING DELIVERED IN THE FOOD
WOULD BE DELIVER COLD OR
INAPPROPRIATELY. AND THE
RESTAURANT HAD NO RECOURSE
ALTHOUGH THEY'RE GETTING
NEGATIVE YELP REVIEWS AND
THEIR- THEIR BEING BLAMED
THEY'RE GETTING PHONE CALLS
BLAMED FOR THESE DISCREPANCIES.
SO ALL THIS BILL DOES IS SAY
THERE HAS TO BE AN AGREEMENT
PLACE BETWEEN THE APT COMPANY
AND THE FRONT FOR THE AB
COMPANYTO DISPLAY THEIR MANUAL
TO TAKE THEIR ORDERS AND TO
DELIVER ON BEHALF OF THESE
RESTAURANTS THE SIMPLE BILL IT
SUPPORT BY THE- RED. TO WHILE
POINT FEDERAL CAN I ASK. RISK
FIVE SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY I
FOR NAPA. THANK YOU MS COMPOSED
SEEN NOTED. OR DEBATE ON THE I.
CLERK WILL THE ROLE DESIRE VOTE
ON VOTED ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THAT OF A. ONE
FIFTY THREE. AT THE. QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
KNOWS FIVE. THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS FIFTY FIVE AND FIFTY
SIX. PASS A RETAIN WE'VE
DISPENSED TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
SEVEN THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM. FIFTY EIGHT THAT CITY THE-
THIRTY THREE TWELVE WE WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY. BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE. AB TWENTY
FOUR TEN MISTER CUNNINGHAM. THE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR TEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM
ANOTHER'S AN ACT RELATING TO
ATHLETIC TRAINERS AND CLEARING
THE URGENCY THERE OUGHT TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY MISTER
CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO AN ESTIMATED THIRTY ONE
HUNDRED CERTIFIED ATHLETIC
TRAINERS MANY OF THESE
PROFESSIONALS WORK IN THE
SPORTS SETTING AT OUR HIGH
SCHOOLS WITH YOU SPORTS BUT
SOME OF THEM ALSO WORK IN AREAS
OUTSIDE OF SPORTS. TO BECOME A
CERTIFIED ATHLETIC TRAINER AN
INDIVIDUAL HAS TO PASS A
COMPREHENSIVE FEDERAL TEST
ADMINISTERED BY A BOARD.
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY
STATE IN THE IN THE NATION THE
ONLY STATE THAT HAS NO TITLE
PROTECTION FOR ATHLETIC
TRAINERS AB TWENTY FOUR TEN
WOULD RECTIFY THIS. AND WOULD
MAKE IT SO THAT IF YOU'RE GONNA
HOLD YOURSELF OUT AS AN
ATHLETIC TRAINER YOU HAVE TO
HAVE THE REQUIRED CERTIFICATES
AND TO BE AN ATHLETIC TRAINER.
I THINK IT'S A POSITIVE THING
FOR OUR- FOR. I I'D IMAGINE
QUALITY ROLE IN THE INTO AN
THIS BILL PASS IN IN COMMITTEE
HAS OP IRIS ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CUNNINGHAM.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLICK LIBERAL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WERE
DESIRABLE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY EIGHT
NOTES HERE ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE. THAT BILL PASSES PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEM SIXTY FILE
ITEM SIXTY ONE IS AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH EIGHT. BY MS CERVANTES.
WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY. FILE
ITEM SIXTY TWO IS AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY BY MR LOW CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX NINETY
BY SOME REMEMBER LOW AN
ACCOLADE IN THE MOBILE HOMES
THE SHALLOW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
THIS IS AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
WHICH WOULD HELP PROVIDE RENT
STABILIZATION AND LOCAL CONTROL
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS LO. SI NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CORPORAL.
OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR LOW WAS A
CALL.
WE WILL PASS RETAIN ABOUT
WHEN I'M SIXTY THREE. WHERE
FILE I'M SIXTY FOUR AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY FIVE QUIRK SILVA
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER QUIRK SILVA AN
ACCOLADE IN THE MOBILE HOMES
THIS QUIRK SILVA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE BUILDS UPON
THE IMPORTANT POLICY DISCUSSION
THAT TOOK. RACE LAST YEAR
RELATED TO AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. AS WE KNOW WE HAD AN ISSUE
WITH HOMELESSNESS WELL BEFORE
KOBE NINETEEN WE KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE AN ISSUE WITH
HOMELESSNESS. AFTER COVERT
NINETEEN AND THIS BILL SEEKS TO
LOOK AT MOBILE HOMES AS- AS
HOMES THAT HOUSE MANY TIMES OUR
SENIORS PEOPLE ON FIXED INCOMES
AND WE KNOW THAT THEY CANNOT
MOVE THEIR MOBILE HOME. THE
MORE JORDY OF MOBILE HOME
OWNERS RENT THE LAND THAT THE
HOME RESIDES ON JUST AS RENTS
HAVE DRAMATICALLY INCREASED
STATE WIDE MOBILE HOME OWNERS
ARE ALSO FACED WITH DRASTIC
RENT INCREASES FROM THE LAND
OWNERS. HOWEVER MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
RENT INCREASES. FIND THEMSELVES
NOT ABLE TO TAKE A 20% INCREASE
IN RENT AS HAPPENED IN MY
DISTRICT FULLER TEN IN ANAHEIM
WHERE A NEW PARK OWNER
INCREASED RENT BY TWENTY
PERCENT. FOR MANY OF THESE RED
RESIDENTS ARE HOME WAS IN THE
BEST AT THAT THEY MADE THINKING
THIS WAS FOREVER HOME. RECENT
RECENT AMENDMENTS CLARIFIED
LOCAL ORDINANCES ARE STILL
ALLOWED AND ENCOURAGES LONG AS
PROVIDE EQUAL OR MORE
PROTECTION TO THE MOBILE. HOME
OWNERS IN THEIR COMMUNITY AS WE
CONTINUE TO DEAL WITH COMO
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE NOT WANT
TO SEE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE HAVE
THOSE BECOME HOMELESS. THIS
TIME TO BE BOLD IT'S TIME BREAK
A TO SAY YES TO. RENTS IT WAS A
FOR MOBILE. RENTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA. SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLICK LIBERAL MEMBERS WELL.
ZARA VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. OKAY ALL MEMBERS OF
OUT OF OUT. YEAH. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS THIRTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE
AND SIXTY SIX. WHERE IT FILE
ITEM SIXTY SEVEN MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE BY SOME REMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN IMMACULATE INTO
CONTRACTS. THIS MAIENSCHEIN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ELDERLY CONSUMERS ARE A
GREAT FINANCIAL RISK WHEN THEY
ENTER CONTRACTS WHICH THEY MAY
NOT FULLY UNDERSTAND THESE
CONTRACTS CAN HAVE DIRE
CONSEQUENCES AS SENIORS
UNKNOWINGLY PLACE THEIR HOME.
AT RISK OF FORECLOSURE THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS HAS MADE
OUR SENIORS EVEN MORE
VULNERABLE TO FRAUD AND
DECEPTION AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE WOULD PROVIDE
PREVENTIVE PROTECTION TO
SENIORS BY EXTENDING THE RIGHT
TO CANCEL FROM THREE BUSINESS
DAYS TO FIVE BUSINESS DAYS FOR
CERTAIN CONTRACTS. BANKING I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK IMAGINATION SEEING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK
WILL OF NARAL. THERE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS FOR AND A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE DEVELOPED. WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A AYE AYES
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES WE HAVE
DISPENSER FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT
PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE ITEM
SIXTY NINE. BRINGS US FILE ITEM
SEVENTY AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE
BY. MISS WICKS THE CLERK READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ONE BY SOME MEMBER WORKS AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE ELAINE USE
MISS WICKS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ONE WILL ALLOW FOR THE
REDUCTION OF RESIDENTIAL
PARKING REQUIREMENTS ON
RELIGIOUS PROPERTIES. THIS BILL
THE NECESSARY STEPHENSON
LEADING THE HOUSING PRODUCTION
CALIFORNIA DESPERATELY NEEDS.
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
INCLUDING SUPPORT FROM LOCAL
COMMUNITIES OF FAITH NONPROFITS
DEVELOPERS AND HOUSING ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MS QUIRK SILVA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. YES MISTER
SPEAKER IN MEMBERS I RISE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AS WE KNOW
WITH HOUSING WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO USE EVERY TYPE OF
HOUSING AND EVEN HOUSING THAT
WE HAVE NOT THOUGHT OF LIKE
USING CHURCH LAND OR EVEN-
ELEMENTARY OR EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS TO BUILD TO CREATE
THAT PRODUCTION THAT WE NEED TO
HOUSE PEOPLE AND THAT IS A
RIGHT THAT WE NEED TO TAKE
SERIOUSLY I SUPPORT AB.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU
MISS QUIRK SILVA SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ON THE ADAM PURPLE OVER
THE ROLE. RESERVE AT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE. KIRK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
SIXTY FOUR. NO THREE THAT
MEASURE PASSES. DISPENSED WITH
FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE AND
SEVENTY TWO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
THREE IS AB TWENTY THREE
FOURTEEN BY MR ROMMEL'S COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL 23-14 BY SOME
REMEMBER RAMOS ANOTHER SNACK
LIVING A VOTERS. MISTER ROBERTS
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
TWENTY THREE FOURTEEN AIMS TO
INCREASE NATIVE AMERICAN VOTER
ACCESSIBILITY TO THE ELECTORAL
PROCESS BY ESTABLISHING A
NATIVE AMERICAN VOTING ASSESS
ABILITY ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO
BE FORMED BY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE. LIKE OTHER
DISENFRANCHISED ETHNIC GROUPS
IN THE UNITED STATES THE
HISTORY OF NATIVE AMERICAN
VOTERS AND RIGHTS AND
ACCESSIBILITY THOSE RIGHTS IS
SHAMEFUL ACCORDING TO THE
NATIVE AMERICAN VOTING RIGHTS
COALITION WHEN THE FOURTEENTH
AMENDMENT WAS PASSED IN
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SIX MAKING ALL
PERSONS BORN IN THE UNITED
STATES. AND INTENDS ON
RESERVATION WORST DIFFICULT
EXCLUDED I DO IN THE LONG
HISTORY OF EXCLUSION AND
STRUCTURE BARRIERS TO VOTING
WILL REQUIRE AN ONGOING
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS THIS BILL
ENCOURAGES THAT COLLABORATION
CREATING THIS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO WORK DIRECTLY WITH
THE NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
WILL ENSURE THAT SUCCESS
ABILITY CHALLENGES ARE OVERCOME.
AND LAW CURRENT CALL EIGHTEEN
THIS BILL IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN. KNOW ECONOMIC RECESS DUE
TO THE CURRENT PANDEMIC AND AS
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE ACROSS
OUR STATE NAVIGATE THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES FOLLOWING THIS
CRISIS LIFTING NATIVE AMERICAN
VOICES WILL BE VIRTUAL AND
VITAL TO ENSURING AN EQUITABLE
RECOVERY. THANK YOU MISS ROSS
SEEN NO DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
CLICK CALL THE ROLL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ADDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE DOUBLE.
ONE WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY FIVE NOWS ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL PASS
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
SEVENTY FOUR THREE SEVENTY SIX.
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN. AB. TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
FIVE. COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAKING DALLYING
ACT WITHIN THE FAMILY LAW. THIS
DALY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
FIVE AS A SIMPLE BILL THAT WILL
REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT THAT
PARENTAGE CASES INVOLVING AND
MARRIED OR SINGLE PARENTS BE
KEPT CONFIDENTIAL EXCEPT IN
CASES INVOLVING ASSISTED
REPRODUCTION THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED FULL SUPPORT IN THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS WITH NOT A
SINGLE NO VOTE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON. EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY
FIVE. HI MEMBERS WILL NOT LOCAL.
THANK YOU THIS DALY. THANK YOU.
SEE A NOTIFICATION TODAY. LEGAL.
CHINA'S IS YOUR RECORD THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER SOMEONE
DOLLY I THINK THIS IS YOUR
FIRST BILL IF YOU PRISON ON THE
FLOOR IS THAT CORRECT. WELL NO
DISRESPECT TO THE GOOD SENATOR
THAT YOUR HUSBAND BUT YOU
PERCENT SO MUCH BETTER THAN
HIM. SO WELCOME TO THE CHAMBER.
THE POINT IS VERY WELL TAKEN.
SEE EMAIL OTHER MEMBERS SEE
RECOGNITION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS IT IS OUR VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. RESIDE ABOUT.
THE CLERK WILL THOSE ARE ALL
TIED UP I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS SAY
QUICK. HOUSEKEEPING ITEM WE
HAVE ADDED AN ADDITIONAL KIOSK
AT THE FRONT DESK TO YOUR LEFT
IN THE FRONT. WHERE MISTER
GLORIA IS STANDING THAT CAN BE
UTILIZED FOR VOTE ADDS. THANK
YOU MISS GLORIA. YEAH. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO BY MR
STONE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARK STONE IMMACULATE IN LAND
USE MR STONE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE GOLD THE
MANUFACTURE HOMEOWNERS LEAGUE
FOR A WHILE ON DEALING WITH.
MOBILE HOME PARK CONVERSIONS
AND THIS IS A BILL THAT'S VERY
DIFFERENT FROM LAST YEAR'S BILL
AND JUST IT DOES THREE THINGS
ONE IS IT INCREASES THE TIME OF
NOTICE. TO THE MANUFACTURE HOME
OWNERS THAT THE CONVERSION IS
HAPPENING IT ABSOLUTELY
JURISDICTION TO MAKE A FINDING
ABOUT THE IMPACT ON THE CLOSURE
OF THAT PARK. ON THE-
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THAT
JURISDICTION. AND THEN THE
THIRD THING IT DOES IS ENSURE
THAT THE MANUFACTURED HOME
OWNER WILL GET MARKET VALUE.
FOR THEIR HOME WHEN THAT PART
IS CONVERTED THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IT'S IMPORTANT. AS A
MECHANISM OF FOR PESERVING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN OUR
JURISDICTIONS BECAUSE MOBILE
HOMES MANUFACTURED HOMES ARE
SOME OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT.
QUANTITY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN A LOT OF OUR JURISDICTIONS
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THEY GIVE US
DOWN SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. OR CALL THE ROLL
MEMBERS. DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE RESERVE OF. YEAH.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS TO VOTE. THE.
THE QUIRK WELL. CLOSE ARE ALL
TIED ABOUT ICE FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS THIRTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM SEVENTY NINE.
IS AB. TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR
BY MISTER BERMAN CORKERY SO
MIDDLE TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN AN
ACCOLADE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LOTTERY IN MAKING A PROBATIONER
FOR MISTER BERMAN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR
WOULD WITHOUT CREATING A
MANDATE ALLOW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT TO USE RESTRICTED
LOTTERY FUNDS TO PROVIDE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE TO STUDENTS. OVER
60% OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT UP SURPLUS OF THESE
RESTRICTED LOTTERY FUNDS
LEAVING OVER EIGHTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ON TOUCHED WITHOUT
REQUIRING ANY NEW REVENUE THIS
BILL WOULD FREE OF THE EXISTING
SURPLUS TO HELP BRIDGE GAPS FOR
THE STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE.
WHICH IS THE IN MORE NEEDED
DURING THIS CAR PRICES AS
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH
HUNGER HOUSING AND SECURITY AND
HOMELESSNESS. TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY IS NO IN IT HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY. BERMAN YES MISS
KILEY YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER MY OBJECTION TO THIS
BILL AS I THINK WE SHOULD
BECOMING LAST. ON THE WATERY AS
A SOURCE OF REVENUE AND NOT
MORE- WELL WE KNOW THAT WHILE
IT'S TRUE THAT THE LOTTERY WAS
PASSED MANY YEARS AGO BY VOTERS
IT WE ALSO KNOW THAT LOTTERIES
THAT TEND TO BE A VERY
REGRESSIVE SOURCE OF REVENUE
THERE'S A LOT OF EVIDENCE THEY
ACTUALLY TARGET- POORER
COMMUNITIES AND A LOT A LOT ON
A RELATIVE HANDFUL OF HEAVY
PLAY. I'M A I ALSO. USING AND
MILLIONS OF. IN ADVERTISING.
THROUGH ADVERTISING FIRMS THAT
THEN USE THE FULL PANOPLY OF
TOOLS LIKE SEX APPEAL AND
EVERYTHING ELSE TO DROP PEOPLE
INTO THE GAMES WHICH
CONTRIBUTES TO GAMBLING
ADDICTIONS SO. I'M I UNDERSTAND
THAT- THIS IS A SOURCE OF
REVENUE IN MANY STATES BUT I
THINK THAT. THERE WILL COME.
WHEN WE ARE REAL. THE SCHOOL OF
THELOTTERY FITS VERY
UNCOMFORTABLY WITHIN THE
GENERAL FUNCTIONS OF GOVERNMENT
ESPECIALLY WHEN- THE STATE
ITSELF SELLS LOTTERY TICKETS
WHILE PROHIBITING EVERYONE ELSE
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR FROM
DOING SO I THINK THIS BILL. I'M
IS THIS IN THE WRONG DIRECTION
AND WHEN OPPOSE. THANKS KILEY.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
MISTER. BERMAN YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS MY
CALLER FROM ROSE BILL THE
REALITY IS THAT WE HAVE ANY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS CURRENTLY NOT
BEING SPENT IN CALIFORNIA CAN
BE BETTER USE FOR BASIC NEEDS
FOR STUDENTS WHO DESPERATELY
NEEDED TODAY I ENCOURAGE AN AYE
VOTE. WITH THAT PURPLE OF THE
ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY FIVE
KNOWS ONE. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO. PASS AND RETAIN
A FILE ITEM EIGHTY.
WE'RE GOING
TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE AT
A MEETING ONE PASS AND RETAIN
FILE ITEMS. EIGHTY TWO THREE
FOUR. WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY. ON FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY FIVE. IN THE PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE TO. FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE. THIS IS AB THIRTY
THIRTY NINE. THE COOPERATE SO
MIDDLE THIRTY THIRTY NINE BY
SIMPLY MEMBER QUIRK AND
ACRYLATE HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES.
SO THIS IS GOING TO BE
PRESENTED BY MISTER MURATSUCHI
MISTER MURATSUCHIYOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I AM PRESENTING AB THIRTY
THIRTY NINE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK THIS
DEALS WITH AN EXTENSION A
SIMPLE EXTENSION OF THE A
PROGRAM RELATED TO PROVIDING
LOANS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES TO
COMPLY WITH STANDARDS RELATED
TO UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANKS
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION. NO
NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI SEEING THOUGH
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROOM. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE CZAR TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TODD ABOUT I
SEVENTY TWO DOES ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. BACK IN FILE
ORDER FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX PASS
AND RETAIN WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY
SEVEN. PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS
EIGHTY EIGHT THROUGH NINETY.
YES. YEAH WE DISPENSED WITH
FILE ITEM NINETY TWO THIS IS
FILE ITEM NINETY THREE. AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO BY MISTER
CUNNINGHAM CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM
ANOTHER'S AN ACT RELATING TO
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. MISTER
CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT A. B. NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO AB NIGHTS A TWO WILL GIVE
TEACHING CREDENTIAL CANDIDATES
AN ALTERNATE PATHWAY INTO THE
PROFESSION BY ALLOWING THEM TO
USE QUALIFIED COURSEWORK A
COLLEGE IN WHICH THEY EARNED AN
A OR B. OR BETTER TO SATISFY
THE BASIC SKILLS REQUIREMENT
AND ENTER THE TEACHING
PROFESSION THIS BILL WILL
SUNSET AND THREE YEARS GIVING
US A CHANCE TO STUDY WHETHER
THE- SEA BASS TESTS IS BEEN AN
EFFECTIVE. MEANS OF IDENTIFYING
TEACHER CANDIDATES IT WILL HELP
WITH THE IMPENDING TEACHER
SHORTAGE THAT WE MAY BE FACING
AS A STATE- I THINK IT'S A GOOD
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. AIMS CUNNINGHAM.
SEEING I'M SORRY MR FONG IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER MISTER FONG
IN THE REAR CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS I RISE A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO THIS BILL WILL HELP ADDRESS
THE CURRENT TEACHER SHORTAGE WE
ARE FACING IN CALIFORNIA I
REDUCING BARRIERS TO ENTER THE
PROFESSION. IN KERN COUNTY
ALONE WE NEED TO HIRE FIVE
HUNDRED SIXTY MORE TEACHERS TO
REACH PRE RECESSION LEVELS WE
NEED TO INCREASE ACCESSIBILITY
TO ENTER THIS PROFESSION.
TAKING THIS THE BEST OR OTHER
STANDARDIZED TESTS TO SATISFY
THE BASIC SKILLS REQUIREMENTS
COSTI JURORS HUNDREDS OF
TEACHER CANDIDATES HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS AND SERVES AS A BARRIER
FOR MATT. I. IT IS S. WE GIVING
CAN ADDITIONAL AT TO MEET
TEACHER REQUIREMENTS TO EASE
THE TEACHER SHORTAGE. IN EVERY
DISTRICT HE TEACHERS NOW MORE
THAN EVER. THIS BILL HELPS GET
QUALIFIED INTO WORK FORCE WITH
COMPROMISING THE OF CANDY TO
OUR CHILDREN I LIKE TO THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FOR THE CENTER
BECAUSE FOR INTRODUCING THE
IMPORTANT MEASURE THERE IS NO
ASK FOR I. THANK YOU MISTER
FONG DOCTOR. ERICA YES THE
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
IN CAUTION WITH WE TO THIS BILL
I WILL SUPPORT IT BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY I'M NOT NECESSARILY
IN FAVOR OF THE TESTS THAT THAT
THEY'RE TAKING IN TERMS OF IT
ACTUALLY CERTIFYING ANYTHING
WHAT I AM CONCERNED THAT WE
HAVE NOT DONE THE WORK OF
BASICALLY WORK ON WHAT IT TAKES
TO ACTUALLY CERTIFIED TEACHER
IN OUR CLASSROOMS. WE HAVE NOT
CHANGED OUR METHODS OR ANYTHING
ELIMINATING THE ONLY TEST THAT
PROBABLY THAT SOME PROFICIENCY
ATTACHED TO IT NOT THAT IT SAYS
A WHOLE LOT AND MOST OF THE
STATES IN SOME WONDERFUL IN
TERMS OF BAIT DEALING TEACHER.
EIGHT TO FIVE YEARS OF THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT REALLY
MATTER THAT HELP US TO FIGURE
OUT WHO'S A GOOD TEACHER WE'VE
HAD THIS CONVERSATION BEFORE OR
AND SO MY FEAR THAT WE REMOVE
AND WE NEED TO BUT WE HAVEN'T
OUT WHAT WITH US UP IT WITH AND
AS A RESULT WE DON'T HAVE TO
COME IN OTHER THAN COURSES
TAKEN AT. BIRTH THESE THE
GRADES THEY GET AND HAVING BEEN
AT THE UNIVERSITY I NEED ALL
THE CAN VARY WIDELY WITH
REGARDS TO WHO'S TEACHING AND
HOW THEY'RE BE TEST RESULT IS
THAT THEY USE TO HELP. AS WE-
BUT WITH. ONE THE TEACHER AT
SINGLE PRESERVE. EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT IS A THE OF WHAT
WE'RE GETTING A CLASS TO MAKE
THEY CAN ENJOY THE ISSUE THAT
ARE CHIU A FACE AND THE WE CAN
IMPOSE ENOUGH THE IN OF FOR
TEACHER A PROCESS THAT GETS THE
IN A PROCESS THAT CERTIFY THEM
AND THEY COULDN'T TO SUPPORT
THEM AS THEY MOVE FORWARD SO-
AS YOU DO THIS I HOPE THAT IT
IS IN THE BACK OF YOUR MIND
THAT THIS IS NOT THE BE ALL END
ALL. THAT WE HAVE A BIGGER
PROBLEM AND THAT IS BASICALLY A
SYSTEM THAT CERTIFIES OUR
TEACHERS AND THAT WE HAVE SOME
CONFIDENCE THAT WHEN THEY GO IN
A CLASSROOM THEY WILL GET THE
SUPPORT YOU TO BE SUCCESSUL. I
THINK THAT WHATEVER. SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. MISS
CUNNINGHAM YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY CONCUR WITH- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO'S
COMMENTS- THIS IS NOT THE BE
ALL END ALL- SHE'S ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT WE DON'T HAVE ANY SORT OF
SYSTEMATIC STUDY OF WHAT A GOOD
USEFUL TEST WOULD BE TO
IDENTIFY. YOUR CANDIDATE IT'S
GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN THE
CLASSROOM- WE NEED TO DO THAT
IS THE STATE- THAT'S A POLICY
IN THAT DIRECTION NEED TO.
ACTION WITH. EXCEPTION OF IS
WHAT I VIEW AS A VERY FIRST
STEP. WHICH IS TO TEMPORARILY
SUSPENDED TESTS THAT HAS MET
NEVER BEEN STUDIED IN THIRTY
SOMETHING YEARS HAS BEEN ON THE
BOOKS IT'S THERE THEY'VE NEVER
DONE ONE STUDY TO YOU THAT THE
SEA BASS. IS A USEFUL TOOL TO
PREDICT WHETHER YOU. ON A CLASS.
GOT SOMEONE THAT WANTS TO TEACH
FIRST CAN. POTENTIALLY SOME OUT.
ALGEBRA WHICH IS SOMETHING.
THAT THEY- THE NET NEED TO
TEACH A IT IT IT IT DOESN'T
MAKE A WHOLE LOT OF SENSE TO ME
PARTICULARLY IN THIS TIME AND
THIS YEAR BECAUSE A CO OF IT-
PEOPLE CAN EVEN TAKE THIS TEST
IT WASN'T EVEN A MINISTER. SO
YOU KNOW IF IT WERE IT NOT FOR
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER BY THE
GOVERNOR YOU THAT PEOPLE HAVING
TO WAIT AN ENTIRE YEAR TO GET
IN THE PROFESSION JUST BECAUSE
THEY COULDN'T TAKE THIS TEST
ARE REQUIRED TO TAKE. WHICH IS.
AND FOR. SO I'M I ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. AS THAT AS A SIGN THE-
WORKING. AS ALLEGE. TO SOLVE
THIS ISSUE IN STUDYING THE
ISSUE CORRECTLY. AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FROM SAN DIEGO
POINTS OUT. AND I THINK WE CAN
GET THERE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. VIGOROUS CUNNINGHAM
AND WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS SARAH VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS
IS FILE ITEM NINETY FOUR AB.
TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN. FIVE
MISTER LOWE CORKERY CYNICAL
TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW ANOTHER SNACK
RELATED PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS MR LOW YOU MAIL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR SUBJECT
REMEMBERS THIS IS A BILL WITH
RENDON RESPECT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
TO HELP EXPEDITE LIKE A CAT IS
FOR THOSE ARE. REFUGEES SIMILAR
KOMMENTAR TO THAT VETERANS AND
OUR ASK PRIVATE. THANK YOU MISS
LOVAGE KILEY YOU'RE RECOGNIZE I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT I THINK THAT THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT BILL- WHEN IT
COMES TO ASSIMILATION FEW
THINGS ARE MORE IMPORTANT THAN
BEING ABLE TO PRACTICE YOUR
PROFESSION. AND EARN A
LIVELIHOOD AND WE HAVE A
LICENSE OR PROCESS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT CAN BE QUITE
BURDENSOME. I WOULD HOPE
ULTIMATELY THAT WE CAN
UNDERTAKE BROADER ISSUE
REFORMING OUR LICENSURE PROCESS
WHICH IS ROUTINELY RATED AS THE
MOST ONEROUS OF ANY STATE IN
THE COUNTRY AND ESPECIALLY NOW
AT A TIME WHEN IT'S MORE OPEN
THAN EVER THAT WE GET FOLKS
BACK TO THE WORK FORCE I HOPE
THAT WE CAN. I'M IN THE WELL
TIED THE BROADER OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING REFORM BUT I THINK
THIS IS A GOOD START. THINGS
KILEY SEEING NO OTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE MISTER LOW
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE CLUB CLUB IN THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT
ABOUT. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
TYLER. AS FIFTY NINE KNOWS TO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. WHERE TO
PASS AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM
NINETY FIVE WE DISPENSED WITH
NINETY SIX THIS BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM. NINETY SEVEN. AB
TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT OPERATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO OH
EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER IRWIN
AND ACTUALLY TO CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS MR WENT. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO AWAY A
BILL THAT WILL MODERNIZE OUR
STATE LAWS REGARDING ONLINE
CHARITABLE GIVING. THIS BILL IS
COMING AT A CRITICAL MOMENT IN
OUR HISTORY AS A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY AND ECONOMIC CRISIS
AT SOCIAL MOVEMENTS ARE MAKING
CHARITABLE DONATIONS ALL THE
MORE CRITICAL TO STRENGTHENING
THE FABRIC OF OUR SOCIETY. AB
TWENTY TWO AWAY WILL PROVIDE A
LONG SOUGHT PASSED BY ONLINE
PLATFORMS TO MINIMIZE EXPOSURE
TO LIABILITY WHILE PROVIDING
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THE TOOLS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT ONLINE
DONATIONS- REACHING RECIPIENT
VERITIES. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND IS THE PRODUCT OF
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS LARGE
STATE THEIR GROUP. RESPECT
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER WINCING
NOW TO SEE. OR DEBATE ON THE ON.
CLARK LOCAL THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE. ALL
MY VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. KIRK
WELL CLOSER ALL TIED UP AYE
AYES FIFTY THREE KNOWS TEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NINETY EIGHT. AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN BY MISTER
MONTGOMERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TWO THIRTEEN BY SOME MEMORABLY
MON AN ACT RELATING TO
EMERGENCY SERVICES MISS LAMANYA
MAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN ANSWERS
WE ARE ABLE TO MOBILIZE OUR
NONPROFIT SECTOR TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY DURING
DISASTERS SEVEN MONTHS AGO THE
ASSEMBLY GEO COMMITTEE IN THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR HELD A
HEARING TO EXAMINE THE ROLE. OF
NONPROFIT EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY AS THE COURT IN ANY
ENTITY TASKED WITH DEALING WITH
DISASTER STATEWIDE THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES IS UNIQUELY POSITIONED
TO PROVIDE MODEL GUIDELINES TO
LEVERAGE NONPROFIT RESOURCES
AND VOLUNTEERS DURING A
DISASTER AB TWENTY TWO THE TEAM
WILL ENSURE THAT THESE MALL IS
ARE DEVELOPED ABLE. SO THAT
LOCAL CAN PARTY TO DO. OF
VOLUNTEER DONATE AND RESOURCES
I RESPECTFULLY I FOR AND I.
THANK YOU MISTER. SEE NOW
DISCUSSION OR ON THE I CLERK
WILL OF THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
OUT OF THEM ALL MEMBERS VOTED
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIX NINE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM NINETY NINE.
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TO SEVENTY SIX BYE SO MY MEMORY
IS ANOTHER PERSON THAT RELATING
AMERICA. MS RACE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AT TWENTY TO SEVENTY
SIX WHICH HELPS CALIFORNIA TO
FINALLY ENSURE THAT RELEVANT
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS MEET THEIR
STATE AND FEDERAL MANDATES FOR
BLOOD LEAD TESTING. THIS BILL
PUT IN PLACE SERIES BILL TO
MECHANISM. THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT CHILDREN
RECEIVE THE REQUIRED BLOOD LEAD
TEST. THIS IS A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORTED THE BILL AND WILL
LOOK TO INCREASE THE EFFICIENCY
OF MEANT AN INCREASE TO MEDIC
OF A GROWING PUBLIC HEALTH THIS
A FULLY AT THREE. THANK YOU MAY.
SEEING PRESSURE DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLARK LEVEL ROLE ALL
MEMBERS UNDESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER OUT OF A- ALL MY VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSER ALL
TIED UP. I SEVENTY NO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO RETURN TO. FILE ITEM
NINETY ONE THIS IS FILE ITEM
NINETY ONE. AB NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN MISTER KALRA OPERATE
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
ANOTHER'S AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT MISTER KALRA MAY
OPEN THANK BIGGER MEMBERS AB
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN EXTENDS
THE FILING DEADLINE FOR
RETALIATION CLUBS WITH THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STATE AND
FORSMAN FROM SIX MONTHS TO ONE
YEAR WE'VE GOT IT FROM THE
YEARS LAST YEAR'S BILL TO US
THE GOVERNOR HAS BEEN. REGION
ARE NOW IN AGREEMENT. OF THE
SIX. IT ALL RECOVERY ATTORNEY
BE WERE BILL EMPLOYEES AND
APPLIES MITCHELL BLOOR
RETALIATION. WOULD TELL YOU IS
NOT ONLY PER. IN ALSO GROW
PROBLEM THE LOCAL. SURROUNDING
AND- IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS
AVAILABLE DATA FROM TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. IMMIGRATION
RELATED RETALIATION CLAIMS
FILED WITH THE DEAL AS SEE
INCREASED BY NEARLY TWO
THOUSAND PERCENT. THE MS THE
PANDEMIC ADVOCATES UPPORT AN
INCREASE IN CALLS REGARDING
HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES AND
WAGE THEFT I MISS. I MISS
CLASSIFICATION. IT IS OUR
APARTMENT PORT NOW AS EVER THAT
WE INSURE ALL LEGAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE AVENUES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR WORKERS TO COME
FORWARD. THE TWO MAIN BARRIERS
WORKERS BASEBALL CLAMOR DRESSED
IN THIS BILL WORKERS WERE BASED
DELEGATION ESPECIALLY THE
EXTREME FORMS TERMINATION. OR
VIOLENCE NEED MORE TIME TO
GATHER RESOURCES AND SEEK
ASSISTANCE A SIMPLE SIX MONTH
EXTENSION OF FILING A WORKER
TELEVISION CLAIM WILL GIVE
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
FEDERAL HOOD AND THEN THEIR
NEXT STEPS FOR RECOURSE IN THE
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN ALSO
BUILDS UPON EXISTING ABILITIES
RECORDS AWARD REASONABLE
ATTORNEY'S FEES TO ATTORNEY TO
TAKE HIS CASE ON BEHALF OF
WORKERS. THIS IS NOT A BILL
THAT IS INTENDED TO INCREASE
THE GEISHA OPPOSITION ARGUES
RATHER PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL
SENSIBLE REASONABLE WAY FOR THE
WORLD PAGE WORKERS PURSUE
RECOURSE WITH A BIT UNFAIR. IT
AGAIN FOR A BOGEY THERE
UNDERSTOOD LAW ALSO HAVING THE-
EXTENSION OF ALLOWS FOR MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO RESOLVE IT
THROUGH. DEVELOPER PROCESS. WE
ARE ABOUT. TAKING HIS CAR.
EMAIL DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE
ON A RESERVE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON VOTE ARE VOTE. ALL MY
VOTERS OUT OF A. YEAH. ALL
MEMBERS OF. WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS
EIGHTEEN. THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN REGULAR FILE
ORDER THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
HUNDRED. AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TO SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
MEDICO. MISTER CELIS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS
IS A COMPANION BILL THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE INLAND
EMPIRE JUST SPOKE ABOUT THIS
DEALS WITH A- CHILDREN ROLLED
IN MEDI CAL SHALL RECEIVE THE
REQUIRED BLOOD LEAD TESTING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MISTER CELIS. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. THE CLUB
LARA ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS AT ABOUT.
QUIRK WELL. CLOSER ALL TELL
ABOUT AYE SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE ONE AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY BY MR CHILD COOKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO AN
ACCOLADE OF PRIVACY MR CHECKOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
WOULD BRING HEALTH INFORMATION
COLLECTED BY FDA APPROVED APPS.
USED ADDED THIS QUESTION OF A
POSITION TO BE UNDER THE
PROTECTION OF CALIFORNIA'S
MEDICAL PRIVACY LAW. THE FDA
HAS RECENTLY STREAMLINED THE
PROCESS BY WHICH DIGITAL HEALTH
PRODUCTS OR APPROVED. GIVING
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS NEW WAYS
TO GET USEFUL PATIENT
INFORMATION. FOR EXAMPLE
SEVERAL FORMS OF DIGITAL PILLS
ARE ALREADY IN USE. THESE PILLS
COMBINE INJECTABLE MICROCHIP
SENSORS WITH PHARMACEUTICALS.
AND COMMUNICATE WITH THE PATCH
THAT COLLECTS INFORMATION AND
SINCE IT TO AN APP. THEY CAN
RECORD THE TIME IN QUANTITY A
DRUG BEING TAKEN BY PERSON AS
WELL AS- HIS BODY TEMPERATURE
AND HEART RATE. FOR DATA TO BE
CONSIDERED MEDICAL INFORMATION
AND HE NEEDS TO BE GENERATED BY
CARE PROVIDED. BUT IN CASE IT
DIDN'T MAKE IS CHEN BY HELP OUT.
AND COLLECTED I'LL OF THE MEDI
FACILITY. AND AT THE PACE A
LITTLE IT WOULD NOT BE. SURE UP
THE EXISTING. THIS IS. IN THE
COLD NINETEENTH AND THEN SO.
HEALTH CARE FOR. ARE LOOKING
EXPLORE TO DRAW THIS. INCLUDING
USE A DIGITAL PRODUCTS. TO GET
USEFUL INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
PATIENTS RACING SIGNIFICANT
PATIENT PRIVACY CONCERNS.
FOLLOWING THIS CRISIS THERE'S
ALSO THE LIKELIHOOD AND DEMAND
FOR DIGITAL HEALTH. INFORMATION
FOR RETROSPECTIVE ANALYSIS AND
RESEARCH FOR EXAMPLE A HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANY COULD USE
DIGITAL HEALTH INFORMATION
PURCHASE FROM ADDITIONAL
FEEDBACK SYSTEM TO IN FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO CONTRACTED
COVERT NINETEEN AND THIS SET
RATES FOR PREMIUMS BASED ON
THAT INFORMATION. AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY WILL BRING THESE
TECHNOLOGIES IN THE INFORMATION
THEY COLLECT UNDER CMI EIGHT BY
PROVIDING THAT ANY BUSINESS
THAT OFFERS SUCH AN OUT. OR
DEVICE TO A CONSUMER SHALL BE
DEEMED A HEALTHCARE PROVIDER
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT
SENSITIVE. HEALTH DATE DATA
GENERATED BY THESE DIGITAL
BILLS IS TREATED THE SAME WITH
THE SAME CARE AS DATA THAT IS
GENERATED IN THE TRADITIONAL
MEDICAL SETTING AND THAT
INFORMATION WILL BE SURE
WITHOUT PATIENTS WRITTEN
CONSENT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
ABOUT. THINGS CHAO. C. NOTICED
DEBATE LOCAL OF THE ROLE
REVERSAL. RESERVE ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A. YEAH. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE A. CLICK
WELL CULTURAL TELL ABOUT AYE
AYES FORTY NINE. KNOWS FIVE
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ASCERTAINABLE ITEM ONE OR TWO.
WANT TO TAKE A FILE ITEM ONE OF
THREE AB TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX
CARPOOL READ. SOME LEGAL TWENTY
TWO NINETY SIX BY SOME REMEMBER
QUIRK INOCULATING THE DRINKING
WATER. IS PARA QUE HAN ON
BEHALF OF DOCTOR QUIRK. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
REPRESENTING AB. TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX ON BEHALF OF DOCTOR
QUIRK AB TWENTY TWO NINE SIX
PROVIDE CRITICAL STABILIZATION
FOR SMALL DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS WITH LOCAL OVERSIGHT.
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS REGULATE
SMALL DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS IN
THIRTY COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA
ACCOUNTING FOR OVER HALF OF THE
PUBLIC DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS
IN THE STATE. SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS GENERATE LAST FEW
REVENUE TO SUPPORT OVERSIGHT
BUT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE AT
THE STATE WHAT BE VITAL. ACCESS
TO SAFELY UP FOR WATER NEVER
MORE COULD. HOWEVER PUBLIC
CRISIS IS PRETTY MORE OF A-
STRAIN ON LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES WITHOUT THE
FUNDING STABILIZATION AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY SIX PROVIDES. MORE
SMALL SYSTEMS WILL BE AT RISK
OF HAVING TO SURRENDER
OVERSIGHT BACK TO THE STATE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU IS
VERY QUE SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CLICK LIBERAL. MEMBERS
RESERVE AND ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
IS TO THOSE. KIRK WELL. THE.
CLOSE ARE ALL TIDE OF A HIGHS
FIFTY SIX NOW ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM. ONE OH FOUR.
FIVE A MODEL FOR IS AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY TWO KALRA CROCKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA OTHERS AN ACCOLADE A
FUNERAL LAW MISTER KALRA THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY TWO WOULD CLARA BY
THE PARTY RESPONSIBLE FOR
REPORTING ABANDONED FUNERAL
TRUST ACCOUNTS OUTLINED
DORMANCY SUGARS PRESUME THE
DEATH OF THE BENEFICIARY AND
JOBLESS REQUIREMENTS FOR
KENTUCKY OWNERS A PRE NEED
FUNERAL TRUST ACCOUNTS AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY TWO IS
SPONSORED BY STATE CONTROLLER
BUT HE- HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
AND YOUR- SUPPORT AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK BUT THE
CEMETERY. AND WE'RE TRULY
ASSOCIATION. ADDRESSING THIS
LONG STANDING IS AB THREE TO
TWO PROTECT US. AND THEIR
SURVIVING LOVED BUT A YOU CAN
WAY. TO LOCATE AND CLAIM.
UNUSED PRE NEED TRUST FUNDS ARE
STRICTLY ASPEN I'VE A- THANK
YOU MISTER KALRA SEEING NO
DISCUSSION. CARCLUB RURAL. IT
IS OUR LITTLE MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE OF. CLICK WELL LOW'S
ROLLTIDE BUT I SEVENTY NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE OH FIVE AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE I MISS GONZALEZ.
COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE HOUSING. MS
GONZALEZ THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE WOULD BOOST
THE NUMBER OF PORTABLE UNITS
BUILDING CALIFORNIA BY
INCREASING THE DENSITY BONUS
AND THE NUMBER OF INCENTIVES
AVAILABLE FOR QUALIFIES
QUALIFYING HOUSING PROJECTS.
CALIFORNIA SEVERE HOUSING
CRISIS HAS BEEN WELL DOCUMENTED
IN ONE OF THE MANY TOOLS AT OUR
DISPOSAL TO INCREASE HOUSING
ACROSS ALL INCOME LEVELS IS
DENSITY BONUS LAW. IN RESPONSE
TO SLOW ADOPTION OF THE PROGRAM
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO ENHANCE
THE STATE PROGRAM INCREASING
THE MAXIMUM DENSITY AND MAXIMUM
NUMBER ALLOWED INCENTIVES THE
CITY HAS SEEN A FOUR HUNDRED
AND 90% INCREASE ANNUALLY IN
PROJECT. ASIANS TO USE IT
GRAHAM SINCE THESE CHANGE WERE
PUT PLACE AB TWO THREE FORTY
FIVE PROPOSES TO EXPAND HEALTH
DENSITY LAW IN PROVIDE THOSE
ENHANCE. ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
JUST MAXIMUM PARKING RECALL FOR
NINE DAYS PROJECTS RESPECTFULLY
ASK AN. OR CALL THE ROLL ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO THEM. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE. DAMAGE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
OF SIX AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
CORKERY. SOME OF BILL TWENTY
THREE SIXTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND ACKLEY THE
MENTAL HEALTH. MR MAIENSCHEIN
IS MAKING HIS WAY TO THE WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ONE IN FIVE WOMEN WILL
BE AFFECTED BY A MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER DURING PREGNANCY OR
WITHIN THE FIRST YEAR OF GIVING
BIRTH. AND THE PREVALENCE OF
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS IN
CHILDREN HAS BEEN RISING EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC THERE ARE
GAPS IN DIAGNOSING AND TREATING
THESE DISORDERS AND A SHORT OF
A SHORTAGE OF PROVIDERS WITH
THE APPROPRIATE KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERIENCE. THE MENTAL HEALTH
IMPACTS ON CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
PULLED OUT OF THE NORMAL
ROUTINES WILL LIKELY MANIFEST-
FOR MANY YEARS AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY WOULD ADDRESS A SHORTAGE
OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN INCREASING
PREVALENCE OF MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS BY REQUIRING HEALTH
PLANS TO DEVELOP A DOCTOR TO
DOCTOR TELEHEALTH. CONSULTATION
LINE TO SUPPORT PROVIDERS AND
BUILDING OUR CAPACITY TO
DIAGNOSE AND TREAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. DAVIS MATIA SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CAR CLUB THE
ROLE. I'M NUMBERS OF. THERE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. PARK WELL. CLOSER ALL.
TELL YOU ABOUT I FIFTY NO SEVEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE OF SEVEN. AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO
MURATSUCHI CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SEARCHING ACCOLADE OF FIREARMS
MISS RUSSIA G. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO IS A BILL THAT WOULD-GIVE THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE
CIVIL FINES ON GUN DEALERS WHO
DO NOT COMPLY WITH OUR GUN
SAFETY LAWS. DURING THIS
ANDEMIC WE HAVE SEEN A
DRAMATIC SPIKE IN GUN SALES
WITH CROWDS LINING UP TO
PURCHASE GUNS FROM GUN DEALERS
ACCORDING TO THE BUREAU OF
ALCOHOL TOBACCO AND FIREARMS
GUN DEALERS ARE A LEADING
SOURCE OF GUNS ON THE BLACK
MARKET RESPONSIBLE FOR NEARLY
HALF OF THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
TRAFFICKED. I OUR ARMS AND
COVERED AT THE END CATIONS MANY
OF THESE TRAFFIC GUNS ARE USED
IN CRIMES WITH THE
DISPROPORTION NUMBER OF GUN
HOMICIDE VICTIMS BEING A YOUNG
BLACK MEN. THIS BILL WILL GIVE
THE STATE DOJ BUREAU FIREARMS
IMPORTANT TOOL TO IMPOSE
PROGRESSIVE DISCIPLINE BUT THE
PRIMARY GOAL TO SEE COMPLIANCE
THE GUN SAFETY LAWS THIS BILL
BILL SUPPORTED. IT'S GENERAL
AND CAL THE JUSTICE BOUNCE BY
THE BRADY DAM. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE. THANK YOU MISTER
MERCY. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CLARK LIBERAL. DESERVE
IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ADDED
VOTE. YEAH. CLARK WELL. CLOSER
ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY
SEVEN KNOWS EIGHTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. SO MEMBERS WERE
TO GO BACK IN THE FILE TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN AB THREE
THOUSAND FIVE BY MR RIVAS
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THOUSAND FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO THE LEROY ANDERSON
DAM AND RESERVOIR AND CLEAR IN
THE YEARS YOU SEE THERE OUGHT.
TO EXPECT MEDIALLY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
ZERO ZERO FIVE THE EXPEDITED
DAM SAFETY FOR SILICON VALLEY
ACT. THIS IS A BILL THAT SEEKS
TO ENACT CHANGES IN STATE LAW
CHANGES THAT ARE NEEDED THIS
YEAR THAT WILL HELP AND
FACILITATE THE EXPEDITED
REHABILITATION OR SEISMIC
RETROFITS. TO THE LARGEST
RESERVOIR IN THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA THE ANDERSON DAM.
THIS DâN HAS SOME SERIOUS
STRUCTURAL INTEGRITY ISSUES AND
IN FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR THE
FEDERAL ENERGY REGULATORY
COMMISSION BURKE. ISSUED A DAM
SAFETY DIRECTIVE REQUIRING. THE
SANTA CLARA THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER. DISTRICT TO FULLY
DRAW DOWN ANDERSON DAM STARTING
OCTOBER FIRST OF THIS YEAR.
ACCORDING TO THE COMMISSION
RISK AT THIS DAM IS CONSIDERED
EXTREME. EXTREME TO LIFE TO
PROPERTY AND POTENTIALLY
AFFECTING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE IN THE SILICON VALLEY
REGION. IN ADDITION TO THIS
PUBLIC SAFETY RISK IF WE DRAIN
THE IT WILL- CERTAINLY IMPACTED
REDUCE WATER RESERVES.
GROUNDWATER BASINS IN THE
COUNTY WILL BE IMPACTED AND FOR
THE STATE FOR A STATE PRONE TO
DROUGHT THIS IS A PROBLEM
ADDITIONALLY WIND. YOU CONSIDER
THAT THE CONSISTENT FLOWING IN
THE DOWNSTREAM THE COYOTE CREEK
IS CRITICAL FOR SENSITIVE
NATIVE HABITATS THE DRAINAGE
WILL ALSO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT TO OUR REGIONAL VITAMINS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION TO THE
REGION I REPRESENT AND WITH
THAT I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THEY GIVE US RIVAS MR GALLAGHER
OUR- RESIDENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS- I RISE IS A CO
AUTHOR IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AB THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE
AS YOU ALL KNOW DAMS ARE AN
IMPORTANT AND SENSITIVE
SUBJECT- TO ME GOING THROUGH
YOUR BILL DAM CRISIS- BACK IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN- IT IS. SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THE WORK
OF ENSURING THAT WE UPGRADE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE TAKE
CARE OF DAMS ANOTHER FLOOD
CONTROL- WATER RESOURCE
INFRASTRUCTURE- THAT THAT HAS
BECOME- IT. IT IS THAT NEEDS
MAINTENANCE THAT NEEDS
IMPROVEMENTS THAT NEEDS TO BE
BROUGHT UP TO THE MODERN ERA SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE SITUATIONS
LIKE THE OROVILLE DAM CRISIS-
WHERE SEVENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN MY DISTRICT HAD TO BE
EVACUATED ON A MOMENT'S NOTICE.
ON A SUNDAY AFTERNOON WE NEED
TO BE PAYING ATTENTION TO OUR
LEVEES AS WAS MENTIONED ON A
BILL YESTERDAY ARE LEFT TO
PROTECT SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM FLOODWATERS.
THESE THESE LET THESE FLOOD
CONTROL AND DAN AND WATER IN
FOR. THANKS BY THEIR THEIR GET
OLDER AND GETTING OLDER AND
OLDER EVERY DAY AND THEY
REQUIRE ATTENTION SO I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AS THE
ANDERSON DAM IS A- IS A KEY
COMPONENT. OF A KEY WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. PROJECT IN OUR
STATE AND ASK THE SUPPORT THIS
MEASURED AND LET'S CONTINUE
THIS WORK LET'S NOT LET THIS BE
THE ONLY ONE BUT LET'S CONTINUE
THIS WORK OF UPDATING. OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU. THERE
WAS GALLAGHER SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEMS RIVAS YOU MAKE CLOTHES IF
YOU WISH RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. IS THERE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ADDED VOTE.
QUIRK WELL YOU COULD. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY
FIVE KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
MEASURE THAT BILL PASSES BACK
IN REGULAR FILE ORDER WE ARE AT
FILE ITEM ONE OH EIGHT. IT IS
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
BY MISTER DAVID CHIU
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU AN
ACCOLADE HEALTH AND CARE
FACILITIES. MISTER CHAIR YOU
MAY OPEN GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY THREE
SEVEN SEVEN WILL REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS FOR RESIDENTS OF
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES.
ERA SERVE OUR STATE'S MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS
INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESSES AND OTHER CHRONIC
CONDITIONS NO LONGER ABLE TO
LIVE INDEPENDENTLY. IN RECENT
YEARS THESE FACILITIES HAVE
CLOSED AT AN ALARMING RATE IT'S
RESIDENTS AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. SINCE ERROR OF
CLOSE REQUIREMENTS ARE LESS
PROTECTIVE AND FOR OTHER BOARDS
AND CARES THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH STRONGER CLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS GIVING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE TOOLS THEY NEED
TO ENSURE. THAT THESE CRUCIAL
FACILITIES STAY OPEN AND THEIR
COMMUNITY. THE TAKES THE
NECESSARY STEPS TO ENSURE THAT
THESE RESIDENTS CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THE CARE THEY NEED.
WITH THE THREAT OF PHARMACIST
THERE HAVEN'T BEEN ANY NOTEBOOK
STERN IS PROP I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I DON'T. THANK YOU
MISTER CHIU. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL.
CALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR-
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I CITY THREE
KNOWS TO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
OUT OF FILE ORDER TO FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY NINE TO TAKE UP THE
SPEAKER PRO TEM. MEASURE AC
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE. OKAY MR ON
HIS PASSING TEMPORARILY WILL GO
BACK UP IN FILE ORDER TO FILE
ITEM ONE OH NINE AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FOUR
THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TAKE
ANOTHER. INOCULATED PUBLIC SO
SERVICES MISTER KING YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTEEN
STREAMLINES THE APPLICATION AND
RETENTION PROCESS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM WITH OVER
WITH ALMOST FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS UNEMPLOYED DURING
THIS COVERT TIME NEED TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE COULD GET ACCESS TO
FOOD. WITHOUT HAVING TO JUMP
THROUGH A NUMBER OF
BUREAUCRATIC HOOPS BUT WITHOUT
A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER TANG SEEING NO
MEMBER SEEKING RECOGNITION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE AYE SIXTY ONE
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING BACK DOWN THE FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY NINE SO WE CAN TAKE
UP THE SPEAKER PRO TEM. MEASURE
AC AGE TWENTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT TWENTY
FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER MULLIN
ANOTHER'S AN ACT RELATING TO
THE LEGISLATURE. MR MAILING YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS PRESENTING A
SEE A TWENTY FIVE PICTURE FOR
JUST A MOMENT A DIRTY BOMB
DETONATES IN DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTAL. EALING HUNDREDS
AND RENDERING THIS CAPITOL
BUILDING ALL SURROUNDING AREAS
UNINHABITABLE. OR THE LARGEST
EARTHQUAKE EVER RECORDED IN
CALIFORNIA STRIKES IN SECTIONS
OF HIGHWAY EIGHTY AND FIVE
AIRPORT RUNWAYS HAVE BUCKLED OR
HEAVEN FORBID ANOTHER MORE
DEADLY WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC
UNLIKELY SCENARIOS PERHAPS
IMPOSSIBLE TO IMAGINE. NO
CALIFORNIA THE STATE OF FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE HAS ABSOLUTELY
NO CONTINUITY OF GOVERNMENT
PROVISION IN OUR CONSTITUTION.
SO WHEN WE ARE UNABLE TO SAFELY
PHYSICALLY BE IN THE CAPITAL
THE GOVERNOR OF THE STATE HAS
SEEMINGLY UNLIMITED POWER TO
ISSUE EXECUTIVE ORDERS WITH
ZERO WARNING TO THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH WHERE BY THE ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE PEOPLE.
HAVE VERY LITTLE OVERSIGHT.
WHILE WE WERE ON A HASTY KOBE
DRIVEN EXTEND A RECESS THE
GOVERNOR ISSUE THIRTY EXECUTIVE
ORDERS. MOST OF WHICH I AGREE
WITH AND I APPLAUD BUT VERY FEW
OF THOSE ORDERS WITH WIDE
RANGING POLICY IMPLICATIONS HAD
ANY MEANINGFUL IMPACT. FROM
THIS LAW MAKING BODY. AS WE'VE
ALL LEARNED DURING THIS
PANDEMIC PEOPLE ARE CHANGING
THE WAY THEY WORK USING
TECHNOLOGY IN A REMOTE FASHION
TO KEEP BUSINESS MOVING. TWENTY
STATES CURRENTLY RED AND BLUE
STATES SO CALLED RED AND BLUE.
ARE USING REMOTE VOTING THEY
HAVE TAKEN THE EXTRAORDINARY
STEP OF LEGISLATING REMOTELY
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. ACA
TWENTY FIVE STATES THAT IN AN
EXTREMELY RARE CASE. WHERE A
STATE OF EMERGENCY IS DECLARED
BY THE GOVERNOR AND OR
PRESIDENT. AND LEGISLATORS ARE
PHYSICALLY UNABLE TO BE SAFELY
PRESENT IN THIS BUILDING. THIS
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE LEGISLATING A REMOTE
WAY. IF AND ONLY IF. THE VOTE
OF CALIFORNIA AUTHORIZED US TO
DO SO. IF ALLOWED BY THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT EACH HOUSE
WAS FURTHER ADOPT RULES BY A
TWO THIRDS SUPERMAJORITY VOTE.
DETAILING THE PRECISE MEANS BY
WHICH REMOTE OR PROXY
LEGISLATING WOULD HAPPEN. WITH
PUBLIC ACCESS AND PARTICIPATION
BY THE PUBLIC AS A PARAMOUNT
CONCERN. THERE'S BEEN DATED AND
AN ACCURATE INFORMATION PUT
FORTH BY OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL
REGARDING PUBLIC ACCESS AND
TRANSPARENCY. LET ME BE
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THERE IS NO
RESTRICTION. ON PUBLIC ACCESS
TO OUR PROCEEDINGS IN
EVERYTHING WE DO EVERYTHING WE
WOULD DO AND STATE OF EMERGENCY
THROUGH REMOTE MEANS. WOULD BE
ALIGNED WITH ANY COMPLIANCE
WITH PROPOSITION FIFTY FOUR.
THE P. AND GOT MAD MEASURE THAT
PASSED WITH 65% OF THE VOTE.
THE VOTERS OF THIS WONDERFUL
TRANS SEN ABILITY OF THE- THIS.
MEMBER I AM GRATEFUL. I
PARTISAN SUPPORT FOR ANYONE
PRESS TWO TO MY JOIN OFF TO
GLARE AT THE MINORITY. WHO UP
OF WAS LEAD ARE BY. EFFORTS IN
ROUNDING UP SUPPORT FROM THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE.
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS LONG
OVERDUE MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN MISTER
KING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'M A PROUD
JOIN AUTHOR OF A CA TWENTY FIVE
I THINK WE KNEW WHAT WOULD
OCCUR WHEN WE WENT ON RECESS
DUE TO THIS COVERT PANDEMIC.
WHEN WE ENDED UP GOING HOME
WORKING WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS
WHAT I WITNESSED WAS ALL THE
LOCAL AGENCIES WHO WERE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE TO LIBERATE
THE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THOSE
ON BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ARE
COMMUNICATORS BOARDS ARE SCHOOL
BOARDS ARE WATER DISTRICTS. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAD NO
PROVISION TO BE ABLE TO USE THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS AVAILABLE TO
US TODAY TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION BUT ALSO
CONTINUE TO DO THE BUSINESS OF
THE PEOPLE. THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO OPERATE
WE CAN CONTINUE TO MOVE THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE AND MOVE THE
PEOPLE'S BUSINESS. I WOULD
ARGUE THAT BYMOVING FOR
LEAVING YOU ACTUALLY SAW IT
INCREASING DISAPPEAR YORKSHIRE
SOME MORE PEOPLE WILLING TO OF
BE TO GIVE THEIR OPINION. IS NO
LONGER YOU HAVE TO TAKE OFF
WORK TO GO DOWN TO CITY HALL
WELCOME TO THE CAPITAL AND- SIT
FOR A FEW HOURS TO JUST GIVE A
ONE OR TWO MINUTES COMMENT YOU
COULD DO THAT LINE. YOU COULD.
BEING GAY. STILL DO AT DOING
AWAY AT HOME WERE STILL NOT BE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF YOUR
FAMILY HOME SO THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO OPERATE AND DO OUR
BUSINESS- DURING A PANDEMIC OR
DURING ANY PARTICULAR EMERGENCY
WHERE WE ARE UNABLE TO BE IN
THIS BUILDING WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MISTER TANG MISTER COOLEY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES
ARE VERY PLEASED TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. IT WAS
PRESENTED LAST WEEK IN THE
ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE THAT'S
WHERE THE MAN WAS TAKEN TO
REMOVE ANY CONFLICT WHATSOEVER
PROPOSITION FIFTY FOUR. AND I
THINK THERE WAS A CONFUSION BY
SOME FOLKS. RAISING QUESTIONS
THINKING THAT BY THIS ACTION WE
WOULD RE WRITE THE RULES
WITHOUT PUBLIC INVOLVEMENT. SO
COURSE THIS IS A PROPOSED
CONSTITUTION MEMBER WILL GO ON
THE BALLOT. AND THE PUBLIC WILL
BE PERMITTED TO WAY AND
ACTUALLY IT IS THEIR VIEW WHICH
WILL BE DISPOSITIVE. OF THIS
POSSIBLE CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT. I DO WANT TO NOTE
THAT I ACTUALLY THINK TWENTY
TWENTY. IS EXCEPTIONAL TIME TO
PUT A QUESTION LIKE THIS BEFORE
CALIFORNIANS. I THINK THERE ARE
THREE VERY LARGE FACTORS OF THE
WAY INTO THEIR CONSIDERATION.
THAT TWENTY TWENTY ACQUAINT
SOME WITH AN EXCEPTIONAL WAY WE
ALL KNOW THE CHANGE IN
TECHNOLOGY. THAT EVERYONE IS
USING TO A GREATER EXTENT
BECAUSE OF COVERT. SO HAVE
PERSONAL FAMILIARITY WITH HOW
TECHNOLOGY EXTENDS YOUR REACH.
EVEN IN TRYING CIRCUMSTANCES.
THEY HAVE PERSONAL KNOWLEDGE OF
THOSE DISRUPTIONS ASSOCIATE
COVE IN. NINETEEN WHICH WILL
GIVE THEM AN IMMEDIATE FRAME OF
REFERENCE ON THIS QUESTION.
THAT TOO WILL BE A GREAT
ADVANTAGES A COMES BEFORE THE
VOTERS. AND THEN THE THIRD
ELEMENT HONESTLY IS THE ELEMENT
OF PROTEST CURRENTLY COURSE
INTO AMERICAN LIFE. CALIFORNIA
LIFE IT IS A REMINDER THAT
PEOPLE DO WANT ACCOUNTABLE
GOVERNMENT. SO I THINK THESE
THREE ELEMENTS THE FAMILIARITY
WITH TECHNOLOGY THE REALITY OF
DISRUPTION IN THE PRECIOUSNESS
OF OUR AMERICAN HERITAGE OF. OF
SPEAKING TO THE GREAT ISSUES OF
THE DAY WILL BE INTERTWINED IN
THE VOTERS MINDS IS A REVIEW
THIS THIS FALL I REGION I WILL.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY MISTER
KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT TO
ESTABLISH REMOTE AND PROXY
VOTING FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT NEEDS TO BE
CONSIDERED AGAINST THE BACKDROP
OF THE CURRENT STATUS OF
REPRESENTATION GEN IN OUR
STATE. BECAUSE BY ANY MEASURE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LEAST
REPRESENTATIVE LEGISLATURE IN
THE COUNTRY EACH OF US IN THIS
CHAMBER REPRESENTS CLOSE TO A
HALF MILLION PEOPLE ALL
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE
REPRESENT CLOSE TO A MILLION
PEOPLE THAT SEVERAL TIMES MORE
THAN ANY OTHER STATE. IN THE
COUNTRY NOT ONLY THAT BUT EVERY
YEAR THIS ASSEMBLY TAKES CONTRA
STEPS TO LIMIT PUBLIC ACCESS
AND TO BECOME LESS TRANSPARENT
BY LEGISLATING POLICY MORE THE
BUDGET PROCESS BY CRAMMING MORE
BILLS INTO A SHORTER WINDOW FOR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS BY IGNORING
PROP FIFTY FOUR TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS AND PERHAPS MOST
EGREGIOUSLY AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE CURRENT TERM. GETTING RID
OF CHOIR THE BILL EVEN UP TO BE
HURT VOTED ON IT DID YOU CAN
COMMITTEE CHAIRS THE POWER TO
SPIKE LEGISLATION WITHOUT A
HEARING WITHOUT ABOUT WITHOUT
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION. NOW IN
SPITE OF ALL OF THAT. THE WHAT
THERE'S ONE THING THAT KEEPS
THIS A REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY
IN MORE THAN JUST A NAME AND
THAT IS THE SINGLE
UNASSAILABLE. YOU WOULD THINK
IN ALL FOR A BALL FACT OF US AS
REPRESENTATIVES WALKING INTO
THIS ROOM SITTING AT THESE
DESKSPUTTING ALL OUR FINGERS
ON THE BUTTON AND PUTTING OUR
VOTES ON THAT BOARD FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THE WHOLE
WORLD. SEE AND IF YOU WANT TO
CREATE A STATUTE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IT HAS TO COME
THROUGH THIS ROOM AND RECEIVE
THE AFFIRMATION OF THE PUBLIC'S
DELEGATES OF THE PUBLIC
DELEGATES THAT IS THE BASIC
ARCHITECTURE OF DEMOCRACY. AND
THIS LEGISLATION PUTS A CRACK
IN. NOW I'M NOT SAYING THAT
REMOTE VOTING. WOULD NEVER BE
WARRANTED UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES. WHAT I'M SAYING
IS IF WE'RE GONNA PUT A CRACK
IN THE INSTITUTION OF
REPRESENTATION WE BETTER HAVE
SAFEGUARDS AND REINFORCEMENT
THAT IS IRON CLAD SO IT DOESN'T
DESTABILIZE THE INSTITUTION
ITSELF OR EVEN BECAUSE THE
WHOLE EDIFICE TO CRUMBLE BUT
THE WAY THIS IS WRITTEN RIGHT
NOW EVEN WITH THE AMENDMENTS.
CREATES THOSE VERY RISKS THE
DEFINITION OF EMERGENCY IS TOO
BROAD IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
OFFICIALS IN OFFICIAL STATEWIDE
EMERGENCY DECLARED BY THE
GOVERNOR IS LEFT TO THE
DISCRETION OF THE ASSEMBLY IT
ALLOWS FOR NOT JUST REMOTE
VOTING BUT PROXY VOTING WHERE
YOU CAN JUST HAND YOUR VOTER
VOTING BUTTON OFF TO SOMEONE
ELSE AND- SEVERS THE TIED TO
THE ACTUAL REPRESENTATIVE- IN
THE MOBILE DEVELOPING. AND DIED
AT ANY OTHER PREVENT WE ATE
SWAYED BROAD OF A MAN I TO
INVOKE THIS THEN I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE INDEED THERE'S EVEN ONE
PROVISION THAT FOR THE FIRST
TIME WOULD ALLOW THE MEMBERS OF
THE AND TO UP ITS MEMBER UNDER.
BILL SERVE WHICH I THINK IS A
TROUBLING PRECEDENT THIS IS
GOING TO GET A STATE WHERE I
COULD SUPPORT IT IT WOULD NEED
TO BE NOT MUCH NARROWER AND WE
NEED MEAN TO ME THREE
REQUIREMENTS. OF ALL THE STATE
OF THE WITH BE TO BE THE FIVE
TWO COULD ONLY THOSE RIBBONS
THE LEAD. SIMPLY ME. EXACTLY
THERE WERE TO BE A AYE A BETTER
PROCESS. FOR GETTING. ACTUALLY
HOW'RE VOTING WOULD WORK SAID
THE WE'RE GONNA NOT HAVE PROXY
VOTING FOR EXAMPLE WHEN SHOULD
ONLY BE LIMITED TO REMOTE
VOTING. AND THERE WOULD BE A
MUCH CLEARER PROCESS ABOUT HOW
EXACTLY YOU GO ABOUT BRINGING
THESE CONDITIONS I TO A- AND
BRINGING THEM TO AN END AND
THEN FINALLY THERE NEEDS TO BE
A PROCESS WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
RECONVENES. TO EITHER RATIFIED
OR REVERSE WHAT HAPPENED- WELL
THE REMOTE VOTING OCCURRED.
I'LL MAKE ONE FINAL POINT. AND
THAT'S THAT I COULD NOT AGREE
MORE WITH WHAT THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL SAID REGARDING THE
EXPERIENCE THAT WE'VE JUST HAD.
DURING THE STATE OF EMERGENCY.
WHILE WE WERE AWAY OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT COLLAPSE INTO ONE
PERSON RULE WITH THE GOVERNOR
ISSUING AT THIS POINT FORTY ONE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS. CHANGING OVER
TWO HUNDRED CALIFORNIA LAWS
WITH THE STROKE OF A PEN AND
THE ARGUMENT AS WELL IF WE HAD
REMOTE VOTING THEN MAYBE WE
COULD HAVE BEEN MORE ACTIVELY
IN THE EIGHTIES WE COULD HAVE
BEEN AN EQUAL PARTNER. IN
GETTING OUR STATE THROUGH THIS
CRISIS. WHAT IS THE ISSUE.
WE'RE BACK NOW. WE'RE HERE
WE'RE IN SESSION. AND YET THE
GUY IS STILL ADDED. ISSUING
EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT YOU SERVE
OUR LARGEST. ONE SECOND. REMOTE
VOTING. IS NOT A SUBSTITUTE FOR
POLITICAL WILL IT'S NOT A
SUBSTITUTE. FOR LEADERSHIP. SO
REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THIS PARTICULAR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I WOULD CALL ON ALL
OF US. TO LEAD THE WAY IN
BRINGING THE LEGISLATURE BACK
TO BEING A CO EQUAL BRANCH OF
MR STONE TO DISAPPOINT ORDER
I'M SORRY. OKAY I NAY A POINT
OF ORDER THIS HOUSE HAS A FIVE
MINUTE SPEECH LIMIT THAT SPEECH
IS GONNA QUITE A BIT LONGER I
WAS. HOPING TO ASK. THE
PRESIDING OFFICER TO ASK MR
KILEY TO WRAP UP. THANK YOU
MISTER S. DOWN HOWEVER HE DID
HAVE FIFTEEN MORE SECONDS. ON
THE CLOCK WE DO HAVE A TIMER
APPEAR- SO I JUST JAN THIRTY
SECONDS WERE YOU DONE MR KIND
OF CHECK. OKAY THANK YOU. AN MR
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER WANTED
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS SURE
A FEW THOUGHTS FIRST WANT TO
THANK OUR COLLEAGUE- FOR BRING
FOR THIS THOUGHTFUL MEASURE
HE'S BEEN A REAL LEADER ON
THESE TYPES OF ISSUES AND A
REAL ASSET IN CREDIT TO OUR
BODIES SO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR OF YOUR LEADERSHIP HERE
AND- RISES A PROUD POST SPONSOR
OF THIS MEASURE. I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE A FEW POINTS ONE I
THINK IS A POINT TO MAKE FOR
THE RECORD WHICH IS THAT- I
IT'S MY OPINION I THINK OPINION
OF A LOT OF FOLKS OF LOOK AT
THE ISSUE THAT REMOTE
LEGISLATING IS CURRENTLY
CONSTITUTIONAL I THINK THAT'S
CLEAR FROM THE LANGUAGE OF
ARTICLES THREE AND FOUR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION. IT'S
CLEAR FROM THE OPINION OF A LOT
OF OUTSIDE EXPERTS INCLUDING
THE CONSTITUTION CENTER UC
BERKELEY THAT IS LOOKED AT THIS
ISSUE A LOT OF THE LAWYERS IN
OUR HOUSE TO LOOK AT THIS THE
CHAIR OF OUR JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THE CHAIR THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE THE ASSISTANT
MAJORITY LEADER OUR SYSTEM TOM
OTHERS HAVE EXAMINE THIS ISSUE
AND I THINK I'VE TAKEN THE
OPINION I THINK RIGHTFULLY SO
IT'S CONSISTENT ABOUT A HUNDRED
YEARS OF CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT PRECEDENT. THAT WE WANT
TO TOMORROW TO WE FROM NOW ON
NOW MEET REMOTELY AND REMOTE
THE TOP PERMISSIBLE OUR
CONSTITUTION NOT IS SAID I
THINK IT'S EXTREMELY PER TAKE
MEASURE TO CLARIFY WHAT THE
SHOULD PROVIDE SOME GABRIELLE'S
IN CYBER. EYES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS AND I THINK IT'S A MUCH
INAPPROPRIATE. I ALSO WANT
REALLY A STATE MY CELL WITH THE
COMMENTS OF OUR CALL. FROM SAN.
I THINK THAT THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT WE HAVE ADOPTED RECENTLY.
HAS REALLY EXPANDED
TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. I THINK IT'S
BROUGHT MORE PEOPLE INTO THE
PROCESS AND I THINK IT'S-
SOMEWHAT TELLING WITH WITH AND
I SAY THIS RESPECTFULLY. BUT
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS ARE THE PAID. PROFESSIONAL
LOBBYISTS IN SACRAMENTO.
BECAUSE WHAT THEY ENJOY UNDER
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES IS A NEAR
MONPOLY ON THE ABILITY TO COME
TESTIFYING COMMITTEE. AND OURS
ARE CALLING FROM SAN FRANCISCO
NOTED. IT' PRETTY HARD FOR
YOUR- CAL. THEY DON'T LIVE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA TO MAKE IT
UP HERE AT ELEVEN A. I'M ON A
WEDNESDAY TO COME TESTIFY ON AN
ISSUE OF BROAD PUBLIC
IMPORTANCE. BUT WHAT ALL OF US
HAVE SEEN OVER THE PAST COUPLE
WEEKS IS THAT BY USING
TECHNOLOGY. PEOPLE ACROSS THE
STATE CAN CALL IN AND HAVE
THEIR OPINIONS HEARD AND CAN BE
PART OF THE PROCESS SO I THINK
THAT THERE'S A REALLY STRONG
ARGUMENT. AS OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO MADE VERY
CLEARLY. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY IT'S GOING TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY IT'S
GOING TO START TO PUT YOUR
AVERAGE CITIZEN ON EQUAL
FOOTING WITH PAID LOBBYISTS UP
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. I THINK
IT'S A REALLY WISE AND PRUDENT
AND MEASURE I DON'T REALLY
ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
SUPPORT IT. YOU MISTER GABRIEL
MISTER GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE CULMINATING CRISIS
HAS SHOWN US THAT OUR
GOVERNMENT MUST BE ABLE TO
RAPIDLY ADJUST TO EVER EVOLVING
CONDITIONS IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE WELL BEING OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. HOWEVER OUR
ABILITY TO TAKE IMMEDIATE STEPS
FOR IMMEDIATE RESPONSES FOR THE
MITIGATION OF THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS WAS LIMITED
BECAUSE IT WAS UNSAFE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONVENE. I
BELIEVE THAT THE INTENT OF A CA
TWENTY FIVE IS TO ALLOW FOR US
AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY TO
CONTINUE OUR WORK IN REAL TIME
DURING A DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCY. I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE GOOD WORK THAT
YOU AVE DONE AND- THIS I
BELIEVE IS AN APPROPRIATE
MATTER AND I AM PREPARED TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE TODAY
HOWEVER. IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE STRIKE THE BALANCE OF
SAFEGUARDING THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS AND THE RIGHTS OF
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION WHILE WE
DO OUR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
GRAYSON MISTER LIVING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT. ASSERTING
BRANCHES CO EQUAL BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT BUT THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT IS
TRULY ABOUT CONTINUITY OF
GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE'S
GOVERNANCE. WE HAVE A DEADLINE
STARING DOWN BEFORE US- THAT
WERE RACING TOWARD WHICH IS
PASSING THE STATE BUDGET. AND
WITHOUT THE LEGISLATURE WE
CANNOT PASS THE STATE BUDGET WE
CANNOT FIND CRITICAL HEALTH
CARE SOCIAL SERVICES PUBLIC
EDUCATION WITH OUT. THE
LEGISLATURE MEETING AND PASSING
THAT BUDGET AND THIS MEASURE
HELPS MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN DO
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER LEVIN MISTER BERMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MIL
I'M NOT A SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE- IN SUPPORT
OF A CA. TWENTY FIVE TO A
MEMBER- EVERY WOMAN AND MAN IN
THIS ROOM I THINK WAS
INCREDIBLY FRUSTRATED BY THE
EXPERIENCE THAT WE FELT. WHEN
WE WEREN'T ABLE TO COME TO
SACRAMENTO AND DO OUR JOBS AND
A LOT OF US TALK TO EACH OTHER
WE TAXES EACH OTHER WE CALLED
EACH OTHER WE DISCUSSED IN
CAUCUS SOME OF US TWEETED OUR
ANGER AT THE GOVERNOR AND
CONTINUE TO TWEET OUR ANGER AT
THE GOVERNOR. ON A DAILY BASIS-
AND I THINK THERE'S UNANIMOUS
AGREEMENT AT THE FRUSTRATION
AND WHAT WE CAN ROMANTICIZE.
ABOUT WALKING INTO A PHYSICAL
LOCATION AND DOING OUR JOB IN
THAT FIELD PHYSICAL LOCATION.
SOMETIMES OUR ROMANTIC IDEALS
RUN INTO THE HARSH REALITIES OF
TODAY- AND TODAY. THAT WE HAD A
GLOBAL HEALTH PANDEMICS. IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE EARTHQUAKES-
THERE ON TOLD- UNANTICIPATED
EMERGENCIES THAT COULD CREATE A
SITUATION WHERE WE CAN'T
PHYSICALLY WALK ONTO A GREEN
CARPET AND PUSH A PHYSICAL
BUTTON TO REPRESENT OUR
CONSTITUENTS BUT IT'S DURING
THOSE TIMES THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO OUR JOB.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO BE THE CO EQUAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT THAT WE
ARE- AND THAT IS WHAT A CA
TWENTY FIVE IS TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN MATTEO. FOR WORKING SO
DILIGENTLY ON THIS ISSUE FOR
WORKING ACROSS THE AISLE
GETTING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR
THIS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
MEASURE- WE CAN TWEETS WE CAN
RAGE WE CAN YELL BUT AT SOME.
TIME WE HAVE TO DO THE
RESPONSIBLE THING AND
SUPPORTING A CA TWENTY FIVE IS
NOT RESPONSIBLE THING ON CAR
DRIVER. THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN
MISS RIVAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF A CA TWENTY FIVE
I THINK GOING THROUGH THIS
PROCESS OF AMENDING OUR
CONSTITUTION IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO OTHER STATES HAVE DONE
THIS AND WE LEARNED DURING THIS
PANDEMIC THAT IT'S TIME THAT
CALIFORNIA DOES THE SAME. ALSO
BY GOING THROUGH- A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT IT
MAKE SURE THAT THE DEBATE OF
WHETHER REMOTE LEGISLATING IS
ALREADY IN THE CONSTITUTION OR
NOT- IT WILL DEFINITELY CLEAR
THAT UP AND I THINK ALL OF US
WILL FEEL CONFIDENT. THAT WE
THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO
AND I'M CONFIDENT TO THAT THE
AUTHOR AND ALL OF US WILL MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE CAN
PARTICIPATE. AND SO I AM PROUD
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS RIVAS
MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS- I A PRE I DO
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT INTO THIS BILL.
THAT I THINK. MADE THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT-
BETTER BUT I THINK FOR ME THE
REAL ISSUE HERE IS IF THE ISSUE
IS REMOTE VOTING. AND ALLOWING
US TO REMOTE VOTE IN EMERGENCY
CIRCUMSTANCES THEN THAT IS ALL
THIS CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
SHOULD BE ABOUT. IT SHOULDN'T
HAVE THESE OTHER THINGS IN
THERE LIKE ORIGINALLY. OUT
PUTTING AN OBSTACLE IN THE WAY
OF THE PUBLIC BEING ABLE TO
REDRESS AND PETITION THEIR
GOVERNMENT. IT SHOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN THERE AS IT DOES NOW AS IT
STILL DOES- PROVISIONS THAT
ALLOW FOR- SOME OTHER BODY TO
FILL. SEATS US IF THERE WERE
SOME SORT OF DESTRUCTIVE THING
TO HAPPEN AND WE LOST MANY
MEMBERS OF THIS CHAMBER. I
DON'T THINK THAT ANYBODY ELSE
SHOULD FILL THAT SEAT OTHER
THAN THE PEOPLE THAT THE DOT
SEAT REPRESENTS. THE PEOPLE
THAT WE REPRESENT. AND MAYBE
MOST IMPORTANTLY THAT THIS BILL
THERE'S THIS CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT ALLOWS FOR PROXY
VOTING AND I'M SORRY BUT EACH
AND EVRY PERSON IN THIS ROOM
IS IMPORTANT FOR THIS ONE
REASON YOU AND ONLY YOU. CAN
REPRESENT. YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
YOU AND ONLY YOU. HAVE BEEN
ENTRUSTED WITH THAT VOTE TO
VOTE ON BEHALF OF THEM AND IF
WE ALLOW PROXY VOTING WEIRS WE
ARE TAKING AWAY FROM THAT
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE AND
ALLOWING SOMEONE ELSE TO VOTE
IN THAT SEE WHICH IS NOT WHAT
OUR CONSTITUENTS INTENDED SO IF
THE ISSUE IS ABOUT REMOTE
VOTING THEN LET'S JUST MAKE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT SIMPLY
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I AGREE WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MEET.
DURING THIS EMERGENCY WE SHOULD
HAVE HAD THE ABILITY TO REMOTE
IN WE HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO DO
IT I AGREE WITH THE MEMBER FROM
FROM THE GREAT SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY- THAT ALREADY
CONSTITUTIONALLY WE PROBABLY
HAVE THAT ABILITY. TO DO THAT-
AND IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN
LET'S JUST DO THAT. RIGHT BUT
ADDING IN THESE OTHER THINGS
ALLOWING SEATS TO BE FILLED BY
SOMEONE WHO'S NOT. THE PEOPLE.
WHO THAT SEAT IS SUPPOSED TO
REPRESENT. AND STILL LEAVING IN
THEIR PROXY VOTING WHICH ALLOW
SOMEONE ELSE TO VOTE ON BEHALF
OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT THEY DID
NOT ELECT REPRESENT THAT'S A
PROBLEM FOR ME AND IF WE CHANGE
THAT IN THEIR HOUSE TO ME
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF GOOD
DISCUSSION AMONGST MANY PEOPLE.
BUT WE HAVEN'T HAD A FULL
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY HAVE THE
PUBLIC WEIGH IN ON THIS AND
HAVE DELIBERATION AND I THINK
YOU NEED TO DO THAT ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU'RE MAKING SIGNIFICANT.
CHANGES SO. THAT IS WHY I CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. AS IT
SITS HERE TODAY AND I THINK WE
SHOULD ALL BE THINKING ABOUT
THOSE. FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES.
AND I WILL AGREE WITH MY
REPRESENTATIVE FROM ROCKLAND.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ROCKLAND THEY
IT ONLY MATTERS OF THIS CHAMBER
ACTUALLY STEPS UP AND
CHALLENGES THE GOVERNOR WHEN HE
TAKES OVER OUR LEGISLATIVE ROLE
AND HE HAS DONE THAT MANY TIMES
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND WE'VE
DONE VIRTUALLY NOTHING. WE
DON'T LITTLE BIT COMPLAINED
ABOUT IT. WE DONE VIRTUALLY
NOTHING TO TAKE BACK
LEGISLATIVE POWER THAT HE IS A
SERB FROM US WITH EXECUTIVE
ORDERS. WHETHER YOU'RE DOING IT
REMOTELY. OR WHETHER YOU'RE
DOING IN THIS CHAMBER AT SOME
POINT THIS BODIES GOT A STEP UP
AND SAY THIS IS THE LEGISLATIVE
HOUSE THE LEGISLATIVE POWERS
ARE OURS ALONE. AND NOT THE
GOVERNOR'S AND UNLESS SOMEONE
IS WILLING TO DO THAT IT
DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE-
VOTING REMOTELY ARE NOT. IT'S
THE WILL OF US TO PROTECT THAT
SO DON'T. PUT THIS IS THIS IS
THE ONLY WAY THAT WE CAN.
ASSERT OUR POWER WE HAVE THE
POWER TO DO THAT RIGHT NOW
TODAY. AND I HOPE THAT WE WILL.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER GALLAGHER MISS WALDRON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I
RISE AS JOIN AUTHOR OF A CA
TWENTY FIVE WHICH WOULD ENSURE
CONTINUITY OF GOVERNMENT DURING
TIMES OF DISASTER. AS THE COLD
WITH NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS MADE
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR OUR
LEGISLATIVE WORK DOES NOT STOP
SIMPLY BECAUSE CIRCUMSTANCES
PREVENT US FROM BEING
PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN THE
CAPITAL IN FACT IN TIMES OF
DISASTER OUR CONSTITUENTS NEED
REPRESENTATION MORE THAN EVER
AND WE SAW THAT SIMPLY HANDING
CONTROL OUR STATE OVER TO THE
GOVERNOR IS NOT THE ONLY
SOLUTION THAT WE CAN HAVE
AVAILABLE TO US. AND IT'S
GLARING FAILURE THAT IS A STATE
THAT LEADS THE WORLD IN
TECHNOLOGY AND INNOVATION WE IN
STATE GOVERNMENT HAVE FALLEN SO
WOEFULLY BEHIND THE TIMES ACA
TWENTY FIVE WOULD HELP BRING US
INTO THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
WHAT THE WORK CONTINUES
REGARDLESS OF OUTSIDE
CIRCUMSTANCES. I WANT TO MAKE
IT CLEARER THE INTENT OF THE
MEASURE WILL PRESERVE
TRANSPARENCY PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THIS IS A
CA DOES NOT PREVENT. OR PLACE
ANY RESTRICTIONS ON THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AND TRANSPARENCY
PROVISIONS GRANTED TO
CALIFORNIANS BY PROP FIFTY FOUR
IN ANY WAY. NOTHING IN THIS ACA
PREVENTS ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC FROM CONTACTING THEIR
LEGISLATORS OR FOR FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS JUST AS
THEY ARE CURRENTLY DOING IN
FACT IT WOULD BE EVEN BETTER.
NOTHING IN THIS A CA ALLOWS
LEGISLATORS TO VOTE OR
GOVERNMENT IN SECRET. IN FACT
THE AUTHOR OF PROPOSITION FIFTY
FOUR SAID THAT RECENT
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS. FURTHER THE ABILITY
TO VOTE REMOTELY IS GRANTED
ONLY TO THOSE LEGISLATORS WHO
CANNOT SAFELY GET TO THE
CAPITAL DUE TO A STATE OF
EMERGENCY A DROUGHT FOR EXAMPLE
IS NOT BECAUSE TO ALLOW REMOTE
VOTING UNDER A CA TWENTY FIVE.
FINALLY AND MOST IMPORTANTLY.
THIS MEASURE WILL GO TO THE
VOTERS VOTERS WILL HAVE THE
FINAL SAY BOTH HOUSES MUST THEN
ADOPT IMPLEMENTING RULES TO
SPECIFICALLY DEFINE THE RARE
INSTANCES WHEN THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS MEASURE MAY BE INVOKED.
TO ENSURE CALIFORNIANS NEVER
LOSE THEIR RIGHT TO
REPRESENTATION EVEN IN TIMES OF
EMERGENCY OR DISASTER I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
WALDRON MISTER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. YOU KNOW I
THINK WE ALL HAVE MANY CONCERNS.
OVER THIS CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT. AND I KNOW THE
AUTHOR OF THIS HAS BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY. I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE WHAT HAS HAPPENED. WITH
THE GOVERNOR ROLLING VIA
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND US FINDING
OUT WHAT HE'S DOING. ON THE
NEWS OR HIS FACEBOOK OR HOWEVER
YOU ALL COTTAGE. IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE. I FEEL THAT THERE
ARE STILL SOME PROVISIONS IN
THIS. THAT NEED WORK. I FEEL
THAT THE PROXY SITUATION IS AN
ISSUE. AND IT IS MY HOPE THAT
AS THIS MOVES THROUGH THE
SENATE THE AUTHOR WILL ADDRESS
THESE THINGS AND TAKE SOME MORE
AMENDMENTS. TO CLEAN THIS UP TO
REALLY TRULY INSURER. THAT THE
VOTERS ARE GETTING THE VOICE
THAT THEY VOTED FOR. AND THAT
THAT POWER REMAINS WITH THEM. I
WOULD APPRECIATE IT IF THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL WOULD
ADDRESS THOSE- POSSIBLE
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE AND
HIS CLOSE. I THINK THAT-
REMOVING THE PROXIES WOULD MAKE
THIS MUCH MORE PALATABLE- X.
SPECIALLY FOR THE VOTERS AS
THIS GOES FORWARD BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY. GOES
THROUGH THE ELECTION PROCESS.
TO SAY OH YEAH SOMETHING
HAPPENED WERE IN ANOTHER
PANDEMIC OR AN EARTHQUAKE OR
WHATEVER. TO HAVE THE PERSON
THEY VOTED FOR NO LONGER BE
ABLE TO BE THERE AND THEN THAT
PERSON BE APPOINTED BY SOMEBODY
ELSE I THINK THAT EEDS
CLARIFICATION. AND HONEST TO
GOD HOPE THAT THAT CHANGES SO
WHEN THIS BILL DOES COME BACK
ON CONCURRENCE FROM THE SENATE.
WE WILL SEE THOSE CHANGES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
MATHIS NETWORKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN MATTEO FOR
PUTTING FORTH THIS IMPORTANT
ACA. I AM STANDING HERE THE
LEGISLATURE BUT ALSO AS A
PREGNANT LADY WITH A HIGH RISK
PREGNANCY. WHO IS HERE TODAY IN
THIS ROOM WITH ALL THE
BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE HOPEFULLY NONE
OF YOU HAVE CURRENT VIRUS. AND
TAKING THE RISK TO BE HERE
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE I NEED TO
BE ENFRANCHISED IN MY
CONSTITUENCY BE A FRANCHISE.
AND I NEED TO VOTE ON THESE
BILLS. BUT THAT IS A TOUGH
CHOICE TO MAKE. WE ARE WHEN
YOUR HEALTH. OR YOUR JOB WHICH
WE ALL TAKE VERY VERY SERIOUSLY.
AND IF WE HAD TO SAY CA PASSED
RIGHT NOW ON OF THE VOTERS
APPROVE IT. WE WOULD HAVE TO
MAKE THOSE CHOICES. AND SO IT
ASKS THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS
TODAY SO WE CAN GO TO THE
BALLOT SO OUR- OUR LECTURED.
CAN HELP MAKE THIS DECISION FOR
US. BECAUSE OF THESE RARE
MOMENTS OF TIME WE HAVE A STATE
OF EMERGENCY. WE NEED ANOTHER
TOOL AND ART AND ART IN THE
TOOLBOX. TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CONTINUITY OF GOVERNMENT WHICH
IS VERY VERY CRITICAL. TO
ENSURE EVEN MORE TRANSPARENCY
IN THE GOVERNMENTAL PROCESS AND
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. AND TO
ENSURE FUNDAMENTALLY THAT OUR
PEOPLE IN FRANCHISE BECAUSE
THAT IS THE AND THE ESSENCE OF
OUR DEMOCRACY. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WICKS%
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION
MISTER MIND YOU MAKE US. THE
BEST FIGURE AND MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION JUST A COUPLE OF
QUICK POINTS ON. THAT PROVISION
ABOUT APPOINTMENT METHOD. ON
VACANCY THAT WOULD BE
ESTABLISHED BY STATUTE- IF
REMOTE. LET ME JUST I WANNA
CLARIFY ON THE REMOTE METHODS
HERE THEY ARE ONLY AUTHORIZED
IF MEMBERS CANNOT SAFELY
ATTEND. IN PERSON AND THAT'S A
VERY VERY IMPORTANT. THE
STATION IN THIS A CA IF YOU
PREFER TECHNOLOGY VERSUS PROXY
VOTING WE CAN HAVE THAT DEBATE
ON THIS FLOOR. WE ARE SIMPLY
ASKING THE VOTERS FOR THE
AUTHORIZATION FOR THESE REMOTE
METHODS WE THIS BODY BY
SUPERMAJORITY VOTE. AND BOTH-HOUSES- OPINING. BY S.
SUPERMAJORITY WE WOULD DECIDE
THE MECHANISMS BY WHICH WE
ACTUALLY DO THAT AND AGAIN
THESE ARE AND THE MOST EXTREME
OF CIRCUMSTANCES MY HOPE OF
COURSE. IS THAT THIS IS NEVER
ACTIONABLE BUT WE HAVE TO IF
YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR US NOT
TO HAVE THIS. IN OUR
CONSTITUTION GIVEN THAT WE
REPRESENT FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS A COUPLE OF QUICK
NOTES MIGHT MAKE GOOD CALLING
FROM YUBA CITY REFERENCE SOME
ITEMS THAT- FRANKLY I ALWAYS
KNEW WERE GOING TO BE AMENDED
OUT OF THE BILL THAT WAS THE
ORIGINAL DRAFT- WE PAIRED THIS
BACK IT'S VERY CLEAN- ACA VERY
NARROWLY CRAFTED- AC AND AGAIN.
THE ACTUAL METHODS AND HOW THIS
WOULD WORK IN THAT
UNFORESEEABLE EVENT- THAT WILL
BE DEBATED ON THIS FLOOR SO.
I'VE EVER JUST VERY BRIEFLY I
KNOW SAID A LONG DEBATE AND I
STAND IN THE WAY OF- A LUNCH
BREAK I BELIEVE LET ME BE BRIEF
AND JUST SIMPLY SAY THAT SOME
OF YOU MAY RECALL THAT- I WAS A
VOICE FOR KEEPING THE OLD THE
ORIGINAL CAL CHANNEL. ALIVE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CABLE HOUSEHOLDS
AND NOW WITH THIS FORTUNATE
DEMISE I PUSH FOR WORK AROUND
WHEREBY WE ARE MAKING OUR
PURSUIT IS AVAILABLE FOR
STREAMING- OR DOWNLOAD AND
AIRING ON LOCAL CABLE
TELEVISION SO ANIMAL A
SUBSTITUTE TO BE SURE IT'S JUST
IN ITS INCEPTION NOW BUT
HOPEFULLY SOMEDAY CALIFORNIA TO
DIGITAL. CAL ON TO POINT OUT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE A LEAD IN
MODERN IT SHUTTLE MOCK RECEIPT
POINT IT PUBLIC ACCESS. YOU UP.
WE ARE ALL. THE FLOOR SESSION
THIS. BRING A STATE EMERGENCY
ARE AVAILABLE THE PUBLIC IN
MULTIPLE SO THEY UNDER. WHAT WE
ARE IN THE BUILDING I THEIR
BEHALF. OF ALL PLACES
CALIFORNIA THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD MUST LEAD
ON UTILIZING TECHNOLOGY TO KEEP
THE CRUCIAL BUSINESS MOVING OUT
OF THE MOST EXTREME OF
CIRCUMSTANCES. IT IS FLAT OUT
YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
STATE TO NOT HAVE A CONTINUITY
OF GOVERNMENT PROVISION IN OUR
CONSTITUTION AND STATES OF
EMERGENCY. LET US SUBMIT TO OUR
VOTERS. AND THAT'S THE KEY HERE
THE VOTERS WILL DECIDE WHETHER
OR NOT WE HAVE THIS AUTHORITY
LET US MATURE VOTERS TO MANAGE
TO ENSURE THIS CO EQUAL BRANCH
OF GOVERNMENT. ALWAYS BE. A
VOICE FOR THE PEOPLE OF. EVEN
STATE OF EMERGENCY. FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I ASK FOR IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. QUIRK WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY FOUR NEWS
EIGHT THIS MEASURE PASSES WITH
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE. MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MEMBERS I
JUST WANT TO GIVE EVERYBODY AN
IDEA OF WHERE WE'RE AT BEFORE
WE BREAK FOR LUNCH. AS OF RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE DONE THIRTY BILLS
THIRTEEN SENSE OF AMENDMENTS WE
HAVE ONE BILL ON CALL. WE'RE
NOT MOVING FAST ENOUGH FOR NOT
DOING ENOUGH WORK. WE HAVE
SEVENTY MORE BILLS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE TO COME UP
TODAY THAT WE PLAN ON TAKING UP
TODAY. SO IF WE PLAN ON GETTING
OUT OF HERE TODAY TONIGHT AT A
REASONABLE HOUR AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE DONE TO MORROW AT A
REASONABLE HOUR WE HAVE TO KEEP
THIS IN MIND. AND A LITTLE BIT
FASTER. AND MORE EFFICIENTLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON
MEMBERS WE WILL BE TAKING
RECESS INTEL FOR FORTY FIVE
MINUTES UNTIL ONE O'CLOCK.
MEMBERS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS LUNCH WILL BE AVAILABLE
IN THE MEMBERS LINE FOR THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IT WILL BE
AVAILABLE IN THE WILLIE BROWN
ROOM- I AM LIFTING THE CALL YOU
MAY GO BACK TO YOUR OFFICE.
ENJOY YOUR LUNCH IN SOCIAL
DISTANCE. BUT IT'S- WE WILL BE
BACK HERE AT ONE PM.
MEMBERS IT
IS ONE O'CLOCK. WE ARE BACK IN
SESSION PLEASE JOIN US ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE
BACK TO WORK JOIN US ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR SO WE CAN
COMMENCE HEARING ADDITIONAL
BILLS.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN
FILE ORDER MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE TEN AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME MIDDLE
TWENTY FOUR SEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL ACCOLADE A POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. IT'S A
GAME YOU ARE RIGHT I THINK YOU
SPEAKER AND I HOPE ALL MEMBERS
IN OUR LISTENING WILL COME BACK
SO WE CAN RESIST MARLETTE
BUSINESS. THIS IS EXCELLENT
PIECE OF THIS LATE IN. THE
TESTIMONY ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS IN OUR STATE BUT ARE
GOING WITH A WATER THEY- HELPS
IN. IT'S. CHOIR COLLEGES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO CONSIDER
STERN HOMELESSNESS IS AN
EXTENUATING CIRCUMSTANCES WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST MY
COLLEAGUES PARTICIPATION ON THE
FLOOR AND REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THE THANK YOU MISTER A ROOM IS
FOR OF A YEAR RECOGNIZED IN
THIS MATTER. YES MEMBER I AGAIN
IN SOME. OF LEGISLATION THAT IS
GOING TO WORK TO ADDRESS OUR
HOMELESS SITUATION WHETHER BE
STUDENTS OR SENIORS WITH TO DO
EVERYTHING WE- TO WORK TOWARD
HOUSE PRODUCTION. AND MAKING
SURE WE DON'T ADD TO OUR CRISIS
OF HOMELESSNESS I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB. TWENTY FOUR
SIXTEEN. THANK YOU MS PARKER A
THING NO MEMBERS WORK MR
GABRIEL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
JUST WANT TO THANK MY CALL FOR
HER. FOR HER SUPPORT AND AN
IMPORT PERSPECTIVE ON THIS AND
WE RESPECT QUESTION I. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- ON. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED A. ALL MEMBERS THE IS
THERE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLE IN TALLY THE I
FORTY FIVE NEWS HEROES MEASURE
PASSES. WE TO VIOLATE ONE TWO
EIGHTY FOUR SO THE CLEAR WILL
READ SOME MIDDLE TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY BY SOME MEMBER DALY.
TIONS AND LOCATIONS MR DAILY
YOU ARE A OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. AND
WHO NEEDS THOSE MEMBER ANYWAY
RIGHT. THE OF A HOW GOODS MODE
KERRY OUT. AND BE ADJUSTED
THREE FOR THE DO SERVICE%
PROVIDE BY MY PUMP. THIS
MODERNIZE CAL STATE. BY
PROVIDING AT THE BETWEEN TWO
FULL SIR MOVE COME AND SO
MOVING SO MOVING SIR. PROVIDED
BY CARRIER. I'M REQUEST. I
THINK YOU MEANT THE DAILY
SEEING FOR MEMBERS THE WRECKING
CLEAR WILL. ALL MEMBERS ARE THE
DESERVE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE
TO GO. WHERE WILK THE INTO THE
VOTE EYES WERE SIX NEW HERE
THIS PASS. PASS THE RETAIN AND
FILE ITEM ONE THIRD. COLBERT
FILE ITEM ONE FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY FIVE THE CLERK READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR EIGHT
FIVE SIMPLY RECALL ACKLEY THE
TEACHER POTENTIAL IS TO COVER
YOU ARE AS ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU MADAM AB FORTY FIVE FOR THE
RECRUITMENT OF WILL PROVIDE A
FAX A FOR PERSON T. DEMO SUB
MATTER BECAUSE- STATE'S
RIGOROUS TEACHER. CASE
REQUIREMENTS THIS IS FOR THE
CUP. IN ON TEACHER COULD.
RECEIVE NO. VOTE YES FOR THE-
THANK YOU MISTER S. NO FOR
MEMBERS WRECK THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ON THEM VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
VOTER TO THEIR TO THE- ON
MEMBERS RESERVE A- WHERE WE-
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW VOTE I
FIFTY ONE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASS. WE WERE PASS TEMPORARILY
IN ITEM WE FIFTEEN FILE ITEM
ONE SIX AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
NINE OCCURRED WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOR FORTY
BY SALAS IN OTHERS AND I TO
PROFESSIONS OF OKAY OF MAKING
APPROPRIATE OF FOUR IT'S JUST
ALEX YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON
THE- THANK YOU VERY SPEAKER
MEMBER ARE PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE FORTY NINE
WHICH SIX. A LIFE YOUR PROGRAM
FOR SPOUSE OF. THE MEMBER. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED A. PALMER VOTED
AS I OF THE. MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY THREE BY
SIMPLY PRINTING AND OTHERS WILL
PERMIT. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THE MATTER THINKING THAT SB.
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY THREE AS PART
OF A PACKAGE OF BILLS THAT OUR
HOUSE IS PUTTING FORWARD TO
ADDRESS THE CRISIS OF
HOMELESSNESS. SEVEN THE BILL IT
BE NINE THIRTY TWO ESTABLISH A
PILOT PROGRAM TO GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. GREATER
FLEXIBILITY TO EXPEDITE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF SHELTERS. SINCE
THEN OAKLAND BERKELEY CENTERS
IN SAN FRANCISCO HAVE ALL USED.
AB NINE THIRTY TWO- I WAS PROUD
TO SEE MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY FULTON. LAST YEAR
EXPANDED THE ACTOR HER OWN
STICTION. THIS BILL EXPAND THE
PILOT PROGRAM ACROSS THE STATE
TO GET ALLOW JURISDICTIONS
POPPED INTO THIS PROGRAM IF
THEY WANT TO EXPEDITE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF HOMELESS
SHELTERS- WE THINK THIS IS A-
GREAT WAY TO GET MORE SHELTERS
BUILT. FASTER MANNER. FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY THREE. THANK YOU MISTER
TEEING SEEING AND HEARING NO
FOR THE DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS BOTH THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD OF A.
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE QUIRK WELCOME. CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE EYES SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES
BUT AT FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME REAL
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY BY SOME
MARK STONE ACT OF THE FULL.
EXAM RECOGNIZE THANK YOU SPEAK
MEMBER. WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IT TACK FRAUD TO THE FALSE
CLAIMS ACT OF FALSE CLAIMS ACT
AS IT IS A- GREAT TOOL FOR
IDENTIFYING. SCOFFLAWS AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY ARE
BROUGHT TO JUSTICE IN IN THIS
CASE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EXTRA
FLAWS. BUT LET ME BE CLEAR
ABOUT. POUNDS AROUND OR IS IT
IS THIS IS SOMEONE HAS
INTENTIONALLY. NOT A TAXES AND
TAXES IN THE AMOUNT OF TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
MORE NOW I KNOW THE OPPOSITION
IS RAISED SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS AND WE'RE TAKING SOME
INVENTS. OUR FIVE THIS IS NOT
AND THE TO BE A TWO. FOR
FISHING EXPEDITIONS OR
HARASSMENT IN FACT WE'VE TAKEN
OUT THE PROVISION THAT ALLOWS A
PRIVATE ATTORNEY. ACTING ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY TO. A CASE
FOR THIS BILL WILL. WAY
UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE WHO USE
OUTSIDE COUNSEL AND DON'T HAVE
INSIDE. BRING THESE WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO TAKE IT OF. TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS BILL SECONDLY
THEY CONCERNED THAT PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS ON BEHALF OF THE KEY
TO HAVE THE WHISTLE BLOWER THE
KEY TELL PLAINTIFF WOULD BE.
THE MAY COMPANY WHERE I'M GONNA
TAKE AN AMENDMENT IN THE SENATE
AGAIN THIS IS BASED ON
OPPOSITION. DEMANDS ARE OF THIS
REQUEST TO INSURE THAT IF AN
ATTORNEY DOES THAT. LETTER THAT
TOURNEY WOULD FROM BRINGING
THAT CASE SO THIS IS NOT COOL
TO FISHING OR GO HOME. THIS IS
BUT IT WE SHOULD TO GO OKAY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND UP FOR MORE IN
TAX. AND IT TENDS ONLY WILL.
NOT PAID THEM. THAT'S THE SCOPE
IT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN NEW
YORK NEW YORK AS PRIDE IN. FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. THE
LAST TEN YEARS IN UNPAID TAXES
WE HAVE A TAX CAP IN CALIFORNIA
OF TOOL HE BILL. MOYERS NOW
THIS. THAT OTHER. YEAH BRING IT
TO THE STATE AND LOCAL JR
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS OF AGAIN
INTENTIONALLY WITHHELD TAXES SO
THIS IS THIS IS A BILL THAT
GOES AFTER THOSE SCOFFLAWS THIS
GOES AFTER TAX EVADERS THIS TO
GO OUT FOLKS WHO HAVE THIS.
THING AGENCY THOSE ARE
PROHIBITED IT IS ONLY FEE OF
WILLFULLY AND INTO SELECT WITH
HELD THEIR AXES IS. BORN AT THE-
IS A BY THE GENERAL WHO. OF THE
U. THE THOUGHT. UNDER THE
WHISTLE BLOWERS THAT TO AFTER
TAX STUFF LAWS AND I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU MISS STONE
MISTER O'CONNOR TO YOU ARE IN
THE REAR CHAMBER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE AND I. TO
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY. I'M
SURE EVERYONE IN THIS CHAMBERS
BY. TO REDUCE TAX CAPITAL. THIS
BILL GOES ABOUT IT IN A WAY
THAT IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE BUT
ULTIMATELY VERY DESTRUCTIVE.
THIS BILL. GET PRIVATE. TO IN
CALIFORNIA REVENUE. LAW IT
CREATES A- OF FOR THESE
ATTORNEYS BRING NUISANCE
LAWSUITS AGAINST TAXPAYERS AND
YOU WANT TO GO TO. OF HOW THIS
PROCESS HAS RUN AMOK IN THE
PAST LOOK AT THE- PLEASE AT
WHICH IS A NOT EVERY DAY
SUPPORTS. DOES OF LAWSUITS AND
ALLOW SIXTY OF BILLS AND ALL
SIX YEAR A TO FOR TO BE WITHIN
THAT'S SYSTEM WHEN I WAS MAYOR
OF A CITY IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
THE SAME. ASSET AS A MORE.
WHERE SINGLE PAYER. BUSINESSES
IN. WHY OF THEM ALL UP. THAT
THE TOY. SEAT TO A ARE
HAPPENING TOO CLOSE TO THE WALL.
SO THAT'S THE KIND OF THE- THAT
THAT THIS OF BILL WOULD ENABLE
YEAH IF YOU DON'T GO. THAT THAT
WHAT HAPPENED HE AND CAL LOOK
NO FURTHER THAN OTHER STATES
THAT. MEDI ANGEL. BY JUST ONE
BERNIE FILED HUNDREDS OF
LAWSUITS IN WHICH HE WENT
ONLINE WHAT. THE PRODUCTS AND
THEN USE THAT AS JUSTIFICATION
TO FIRE. HOW TO STICK A. HELLO
IN VIOLATION AND STATE CODE I
WILL HAVE. IF WE PASS THIS
TODAY AYE URGENT VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER O'DONNELL TEAS
SEEING NO FURTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION MR SO YOU
MAKERS I THANK YOU I'M I'M
ACTUALLY GLAD THAT CALLING FROM
BIG BEAR BROUGHT UP THOSE
ISSUES. AS THAT SLOWLY. REMOTE
UNDER THE CLAIMS ACT WHICH
MEANS THERE NEEDS TO BE A
WHISTLEBLOWER AND THAT WAS A
BLOWER NEEDS TO COME FORWARD TO
A TAXING ENTITY OR TO. THE B.
S. THAT WILL HAVE TO THE TAX IS.
MAKE CLAIM THINK OF THE GENERAL
IN THIS CASE. WHERE PRINT
ATTORNEYS FROM UNDER THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN THE
SENATE WE JUST DIDN'T HAVE TIME
TO GET THOSE DONE UNDER A
SHORTENED ABBREVIATED SCHEDULE
WE'RE PROHIBITING IT IS SENDING
OUT THOSE LETTERS AS HAD HAVE
TO THE EIGHTY. BUT ROOM THERE'S
A BRUSH. HI DOLLARS WILL FULLY
TAP. SO THOSE FISHING UP BUT IF
WON'T HAPPEN BE WERE FOR THEM
WE HAVE TAKEN OUT THE SECTION
AND THIS WAS THE OTHER
OPPOSITION THAT BECAUSE WE HAD
ALLOWED CITIES WHO CAN'T AFFORD
TO HAVE A CITY TURNING ON STAFF
THEY YOU CONTRACT OUT BERNIE'S
IN RECOGNIZE THAT WE TOOK THAT
PROVIDE YOU NOW BECAUSE OF FEAR
THAT THAT WAS DRIVE IN PRIVATE
IS RAISING THE- GOING AT. THAT
WOULD TRUE. UNDERSTOOD THE CAN.
SO WE TOOK THAT PROVISION THAT
THE EIGHTY A LAWSUIT IN FACT WE
HAVE THAT PROVISION THAT BARS
ATTORNEYS FROM FILING THOSE
CLAIMS AGAINST BUSINESSES THAT
WORKS UNDER STATE LAW RIGHT THE
PROBLEM IS FEDERAL LAW DOES.
SAME OPPONENT BUT UNDERSTOOD.
THE EIGHTY. HOWEVER DROPPED OUT
OUR HAPPENING THERE IF THAT LAW
THAT WE HAVE THE PHONE
JURISDICTIONS THE SAME CHANGES
WE DID THEN THOSE WOULDN'T
HAPPEN THERE EITHER SO WE HAVE
AFFECTED WE SOLVE THAT PROBLEM
UNDER THE EIGHTY WHICH IS A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THANK IN
THAT MECHANISM SPARE. SO DON'T
GET THE FISHING EXPEDITIONS AT
GRASS BUSINESS. HOURS WILL. IN
TAX WITH CHEATING THEIR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ESPECIALLY IN A
TIME LIKE THIS WHEN WE NEED AT
THE STATE LEVEL AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL ALL THE REVENUE WE CAN
GET SO THE OPPOSITION ARE NOT.
ALI BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN TAKING
AMENDMENTS AND WORKING WITH
OPPOSITE. THOSE SPECIFIC ISSUES
AND MAKE SURE THAT THIS BILL
CAN BE PROPERLY MANAGED BY
ATTORNEY GENERAL. BY THE MAJOR
COUNTY SETS WITH COUNTY LOST SO
SUPPORT SYSTEM AND BY THE MAJOR
CITIES HAVE ON TOURNEY'S TO BE
TO DO THAT PROSECUTE. WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT GOING
TO BE A CIVIL FORCE. NOT SEEN
THOSE PROBLEMS AT ALL I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE THE- CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED A
VERITABLE. ALL MEMBERS GO TO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
IS THERE TO VOTE. MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD OF THE. YEAH.
ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD VOTE.
YEAH.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES AYE AYES FORTY ONE NO
SEVENTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE MOVING BACK UP IN FIVE.
TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTEEN AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY TWO CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FIVE TWO BY- SACRAMENTO FIRE.
MR ARE RECOGNIZED. HE MET HER.
TODAY I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY FIVE TWO THIS AUTHOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO ASSIST
LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH PETITIONS
WE ARE IN CIVIL COURT. THINGS
RATES OF DVR THE CROP
CALIFORNIA REMAIN LOW. CAN HELP
IN. AND REMOVE GUNS FROM DANE
SUCH. THAT NEED NOT AND WITH
GUNNAR. THE BILL WITH FIVE
SUPPORT IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT. HE
YOU MESS ONE BEING IN HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE THIRD OF THE. I MEMBERS
VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE-
WHERE. WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
TWO KNOWS ONE THIS MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING BACK DOWN FILE
ORDER FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY AB TWENTY SIX SEVEN.
SOME TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN RIVER
GATE ROAD OTHER ACCOLADE
FIREARMS SICK APRIL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
TERM PLACE TODAY TO PURSUE AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN KIDDING ON
THEME OF GOT RESTRAINING ORDERS
WITH HOW ARE A- IMPROVE TOOL
HELPING TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
DEATHS IN THE STATE
ACCOUNTABLE. AB SIX IT WILL
HAPPEN. ON FORCES. LAW DVR ROSE
THAT ARE IN A STATES SO THAT
THOSE WHO ARE IN IMMINENT RISK.
TO THEMSELVES OR OTHERS. CANNOT
CONTAIN THEIR ARMS THE BILL. BY
A BROUGHT. OF FIFTY GROUPS. IN
MARCH FOR THIS IS A BUILT ON.
ARE A CALLING FROM BROWN I.
LASTING AB ONE SIX SEVEN AT
WHICH WILL BE UNANIMOUSLY
PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE AS
WELL AS A VIOLENCE AGAINST
WOMEN ACT BY ATTENDING. SINCE
TO INTO SUB STATE HOW IMPORTANT
IS TO HELP SAVE LAW AND
RESPECTFULLY AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER GAVE US BEING IN NO.
MATTER CLERK WILL THE- ROMAN
VOTE TO THEIR- ON MEMBERS VOTED
AS TO VOTE. NUMBER THIRTY THIRD
OF THE- WORK WILL. CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THEY WROTE AYE
AYES SIXTY NO ZEROS MEASURE
PASSES. WE WILL PASS THIRTEEN
ON FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE
FILE AND ONE TWENTY TWO AB
TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL. ASSEMBLY BILL TO. THE
EIGHT SEPTEMBER. CREATION OF
SAFETY IN HEALTH IS BURKE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT LAST
YEAR START TO FALL APART WE SAW
ME COUNT ALARMING VIDEOS
DOMESTIC WORKERS RUNNING HOME
BACK TO WAITED. HOMES THAT WERE.
THE SIX FIFTY EIGHT WITH
ALLEVIATE THAT PAIR BY
EXPANDING EXISTING PROTECTIONS
AGAINST EMPLOYER RETALIATION.
THING TO WORK AND HAVE
CONDITIONS TO DOMESTIC WORKERS.
THIS IS THE ACTION ALREADY
ESTABLISHED IN LABOR CODE FOR
MANY THE FIRST. MEMBER THIS
WILL BE A RECURRING ISSUE AS
THE GROWING VERIFY WHILE. IN
OUR IN TEAM. DOMESTIC TURNING
TECH. ALLIES ARE THE- ACTIONS
WE HAVE. CALIFORNIA WORK
WORKERS WITH RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN IRA. MISS BEING IN
HERE THE DEBATE ON UNDER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE A VERY A- ALL.
DESERVE A- YEAH LONG MEMBERS
THIRTY TO THIRTY VOTE. WHERE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE KNOWS TO
THIS MEASURE PASSES. PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY THREE FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY FOUR AB TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL TWO SEVEN FORTY NINE
BY SOME REMARKS STONE ACCOLADE
CANNABIS MR STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBER THIS BILL SURE
IS THAT THE BUREAU CANNABIS
CONTROL SETS. COMPONENTS THE
STATE I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERTED. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
AREN'T THE. HOME VOTED IS THERE
TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLLING TALLY VOTE AYE AYES
SIXTY EIGHT NEWS HERE THE
MEASURE PASSES. IN A PILOT AND.
ONE TWENTY FIVE. FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE BY SOME ROLE DONALD
OTHERS IN THE PUBLIC WHAT.
MISTER DOT. GREAT SIXTY FIVE
PUBLIC WORKS TO INCLUDE CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITY PROJECTS THAT
RECEIVE FUNDING THROUGH CONDUIT
REVENUE BONDS. THIS WILL ENSURE
THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK ON
THESE PROJECTS RISKY PREVAILING
WAGE AND A LOT. FROM OF THE
PROGRAM'S. CONDUIT REP BOND IS
FINANCING COORDINATED BY A
PUBLIC ENTITY. THE STATE LOSES
REVENUE ON THESE BONDS AS
INVESTORS DO NOT PAY TAXES. IN
THE BAR. RECEIPT LOWER INTEREST
RATES. IN A LOT OF US WILL THAT
ARE FUN I SEE EDUCATION BONTA
REQUIRE. TO COMPLY WITH HER
FAILING IT WAGE AND HIGHER
CONSTRUCTION STATE AND THE
HIGHER CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS
UNDER THE FIELD ACT. PROJECTS
THAT ARE FUNDED WITH CONVERT
REVENUE BONDS DO NOT. A
REQUIREMENTS IT'LL DO IT
SCHOOLS DURING WE ARE TAKING
TODAY TO APPLY TO A CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT USE CONTRA BONDS
SO WE MUST ENSURE THAT THOSE
WERE ON OUR SCHOOL FACILITIES
ARE SKILLED AND QUALIFIED THIS
BILL SPONSORED BY THIS BUILDING
RUSSIAN TRADES QUE. FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THE YOU MAY. THE KING IN
HEARING NO FURTHER DELAY MISTER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I NUMBER MEMBERS
OF THIS ASSEMBLY MYSELF
INCLUDED HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERN
ABOUT THE CUTS TO EDUCATION
THAT WE FCE SO IT'S QUITE
SURPRISING TO SEE THIS. MOVING
FORWARD I THERE'S A GLASS BIG
INTEREST GROUPS THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT AND THAT WILL BENEFIT
BUT IT WILL RESULT IN LESS
MONEY GOING TO KICK. IN OUR
SCHOOL CLASS. IT IS STATE VOTE
FOR THIS BILL THE VOTE CAUGHT
EDUCATION. EVEN FOR. THANK YOU
MISS KILEY NOW SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER O'DONNELL YOU
MAY CLOSE. CLOSE I THANK YOU
AYE MADAM CHAIR OF VOTE FOR
THIS BILL IS A VOTE TO ENSURE
THAT OUR SCHOOL FACILITIES ARE
BUILT TO A QUALITY STANDARD ON
TIME UNDER BUDGET. AND THAT
HAVE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE SERVING OUR PUBLIC
WELL A CONDOM ONCE I ASKED FOR
AND I. CLERK WILL THE ROLE. ON
MEMBERS PRESERVER. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. NON
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRTY VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
THREE KNOWS TENNIS MEASURE
PASSES. PASS AND RETAIN
VIOLATED ONE TWENTY SEVEN FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY EIGHT.
AB
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BY SOME
REMEMBER THIS AREA THAT
ACCOLADE PUBLIC HEALTH
PFISTER'S HEARING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWENTY TWENTY ONE
STANDS A SUNSET DATE
CALIFORNIA'S PARKINSON'S
DISEASE REGS SO IT CAN CONTINUE
TO COLLECT THEM AND THAT WILL
HELP IDENTIFY HIGH RISK GROUPS
SUPPORT PATIENTS THAT HE'S-
SERVE AS A- WILL DATED. PROVIDE
OPTIMAL IT'S PART. IS HE'S I
RESPECT. FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. THIS VOTE THERE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. YEAH. WORK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE AYE
SIXTY FOUR NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES. HALF RETAIN
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE.
MOVING TO VIOLATE A ONE THIRTY
AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW AND ACT LIKE A PUBLIC
TRANSIT MR LET YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
TRANSFORMERS LEGAL TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY ALLOWS FOR A NEGOTIATION
WITH RESPECT TO. BEAR RIVER
TRANS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU MISTER LOS
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. HOME MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE AYE
AYES FORTY SEVEN KNOWS
FIFTEENTH MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY ONE AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME REAL TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY SIX BY SOME
REMEMBER WALDRON ACCOLADES
SINCE USE DISORDER. HIS FATHER
AND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY SIX
WOULD ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF
THE LACKING INFORMATION WITIN
CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL ASSISTED
TREATMENT PROGRAM MATT. BY
REQUIRING DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES REPORTS SPECIFIED
INFORMATION TO THE LETTER PETER
IN AN EFFORT TO ADDRESS THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC THROUGHOUT
EIGHT. OR MODIFY CARE SERVICES
A WOMAN IN THE CAL. I'M MATT.
CHECK THE MAP EXPANSION FOR. A
TO INCREASE ACESS TO MATT
REDUCE UNMET TREATMENT NEEDS
AND REDUCE OPIOID OVERDOSE
RELATED DEATHS THROUGH
PREVENTION TREATMENT. COVERAGE
ACTIVITIES PORTING WILL HELP
EVALUATE THE PROGRAM I REGION I
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WALDRON
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS. OF THE- HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE WILL LOW'S THE ROLE
IN TALLY THAT I SIXTY FOUR NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY TO THE CLERK WILL
READ TO MIDDLE TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU IS NOT RELATED
SCHOOL SITES MR CAN'T INSURE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB TWENTY TWO
TWELVE CHOIR THE POTENTIAL OKAY
IN FOR A NEW SCHOOL AND OTHERS
SCHOOL. PROBLEM THE EVALUE
BEFORE THE SCHOOL IS TO APPROVE
AND SPIN PROVIDENTIAL OUT OF
SCHOOL WE NEED TO THEN NEAR
PAYS FORCES ALL OF IT LUCIA.
FALL WITH YOUR LOW. RICK AND
MEET CERTAIN SEE REQUIREMENT
THE WILL ENSURE THAT THOSE
SCHOOL ARE NOW BUILT NEAR OR
HAZARDOUS. AB TWENTY EIGHTY TWO
WERE PROTECT THE WELL BEING OF
ALL STUDENTS AND SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER CHOOSE SEEING AND
HEARING FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THERE ARE. ALL ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE EYES
FORTY NINE NEWS TO THE MEASURE
PASSES. VIOLATE ONE THIRTY
THREE AB TWENTY EIGHTY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME OF
BILL TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY THREE
BY SOME REMEMBER QUIRK SILVA
AND OTHERS AND I BELIEVE THE
JOKER. IS FOR EXAMPLE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. GOOD AFTERNOON. AT
NEW SPEAKER A MEMBERS THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS HAS
HIGHLIGHTED THE INDISPENSABLE
NEED FOR CHILD CARE. IN TIS
STATE WE ALSO AS WE TALK ABOUT
RECOVERY CHILD CARE IS AT THE
CENTER OF THAT DISCUSSION.
PARENTS WORKING IN LOW WAGE
JOBS AND THE CENTRAL WORKFORCE
ARE IT ACTUALLY IN NEED OF A
CHILD CARE THE CURRENT PANDEMIC
NEWSOME'S EXECUTIVE ORDER AND
FORTY FIVE TWENTY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S MANAGEMENT BULLETIN
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
STIMULUS BUDGET HAD TO
SAFEGUARD OUR EARLY LEARNING
AND CHILD CARE PROVIDER AND
STRUCTURE BY ISSUE I'M POLICY
CHANGES INCLUDING
REIMBURSEMENT. THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC IS BROUGHT TO THE
FOREFRONT HOW THESE POLICIES
HAVE BEEN AT AND TOLD I DON'T.
NOW THESE NEEDED POLICY CHANGES
TO CONTINUE BEYOND THE PANDEMIC
CRISIS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY THREE MAKES
VARIOUS CHANGES TO THE
CHILDCARE AND DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES ACT RELATED TO
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAMS IN
ORDER TO IMPROVE. ACCESS TO AND-
OF CHILD CARE PROVIDERS WORKING
FAMILIES NEED ACCESS TO
CHILDCARE IF THIS IS A KANYE ME
IS TO RECOVER AND WE ARE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH OPENING OUR
BILL THIS IS IN GETTING PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK WE NEED PARENTS
BACK AT WORK HERE. HAVE STATE
WELL. AS FOR YOUR SUPPORT AB
TWO EIGHT EIGHT THREE. THANK
YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. HOME MEMBERS THOSE
WHO THEIR TO VOTE. OUR MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD OF A. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE NOTES
HERE THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SIX BY REMEMBER WICKS
INOCULATED CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS. THIS WORKS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SIX NO SIMPLE BILL THE
WILL CODIFY THE TERMS DONOR
ADVISED FUNDS AND SPONSORING
ORGANIZATIONS AND ALLOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO ESTABLISH A
CLASSIFICATION FOR SPONSORING
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT MAINTAIN
ONE OR MORE DEBT. DO NOT MY SON
OR DOUBTS LOW DONOR TO
ESTABLISH AN ACCOUNT TO WHICH
THE THAT INDIVIDUAL CAN MAKE A
TAX DEDUCTIBLE CONTRIBUTION TO
A CHARITABLE SPONSORING
ORGANIZATION. THE GENERAL AND
RECOMMEND BANDS FROM HIS OR HER
FUND OTHER CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
DIRECT. PUBLIC BENEFITS THROUGH
COMMUNITY SERVICE PROGRAMS OR
ADVOCACY. NATIONALLY DEATHS
ACCOUNT ACCOUNTS HOLD
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED AND
TEN BILLION DOLLARS A DONOR AND
DONATED TERRIBLE ASSETS OF
WHICH ESTIMATED SEVENTEEN
BILLION IS HELD BY DAFT
SPONSORING ORGANIZATIONS
HEADQUARTERED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THESE CHARITABLE
DEDUCTIONS COST THE STATE AN
ESTIMATED THREE HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. FOR
THE MONEY STOCK OR OTHER ASSETS
THE DONORS CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR
DEATHS HOWEVER THESE FUNDS CAN
SIT INDEFINITELY. WITHOUT
PROVIDING ANY PUBLIC TERRIBLE
BENEFIT AND NOTHING IS STATURE
REQUIRES THESE FUNDS TO
ACTUALLY BE DISPERSED. THIS
INCLUDES THE NUMBER OF A NIGHT
THE NUMBER OF THE CAR A COVER
NINETEEN RELIEF FUNDS THAT HAVE
BEEN SET UP AS STAFF DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES SPNSORING
ORGANIZATIONS TO REPORT GIVING.
THE AGGREGATE TOTALS. REPORTER
DO NOT TRANSLATE INTO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR EACH TAX
DEDUCTION THAT TAKES MONEY OUT
OF. CALIFORNIA'S GENERAL.
HOWEVER THE OVERALL EFFICACY OF
CALIFORNIA ORGANIZATION
ACCOUNTABLE ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM. IS A LARGER POLICY
QUESTION THAT AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SIX DOES NOT PRESUME TO
ANSWER. THIS BILL WILL SIMPLY
ADD BASIC INFORMATION ABOUT
DAFT TO THE GOVERNMENT CODE. TO
HELP ESTABLISH A BASELINE FROM
WHICH TO START ENGAGING IN A
BROADER POLICY CONVERSATION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WICKS
SEEING IT. FOR THE DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE.
LONG MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE A.
YEAH. OKAY. OUR MEMBERS THIRTY
THIRD BOTH.
THIS WITNESS THE
COP.
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON
AB FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FIVE
FILE ITEM ONE THREE SIX AB
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE SIXTY EIGHT BY
SIMILAR RODRIGUEZ AN ACCOLADE
TO EMERGENCY SERVICES AT TWENTY
NINE FIFTY EIGHT. YEAR MISTER
RODRIGUEZ THE VAST PART OF
SPEAKER MY AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
EIGHT. OR DIRECT HELLO YES
DEVELOP A PROCESS TO REVIEW A
LOCAL EMERGENCY PLAN. AT THE
COUNTERS REQUEST AN
ESTABLISHED. BEST PRACTICES.
FOR COUNTIES TO DEVELOP AN
UPDATE THEIR MERCY PLAN. NO
WHAT ARE FAR ONE FIVE ENOUGH
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA MUST TO
BETTER PREPARE FOR DISASTERS
AND EMERGENCIES. THAT BEGINS
REVIEWING LOCAL CURRENCY PLANS
TO ENSURE THEY ARE UPDATED WELL
THOUGHT OUT WELL BEST PRACTICES
AND ACCOMMODATE THE MOST
VULNERABLE OF US. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN HELPING FORGE PROTECT
ITSELF FROM THE NECK- OR MERCY
ARE STRICTLY OUT OF. THANK YOU
MISTER EVERY SEEING NO FURTHER
ON THE MY THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS BOTH OF
THE- ALL MEMBERS TO THEIR TO
VOTE. OUR OWN MEMBERS VOTED AS
ARE THE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE ANTI VOTE I FIFTY EIGHT
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME MIDDLE
TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER ANOTHER
SNACK LONG TO IMPLEMENT. MISS
WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THIS
WEBER DO LIKE JUST PASS
TEMPORARILY. A PASS TEMPORARILY
IN FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY SEVEN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
EIGHT AB TWENTY NINE NINETY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
MIDDLE TWENTY NINE NINETY NINE
BUT THIS MOVIE WHEN ACCOLADES A
POINT MR LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
VERY MUCH BACK REMEMBER THIS IS
A FAMILY FOR TWENTY NINE NINETY
NINE CAN YOU BELIEVE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A-
POLICY. PECTER LEAVE. TO
PLEASE TAKE TIME FOR ONCE FAN
THIS IS. WITH RESPECT TO LEE I
THIS IS ALSO BEEN A DEEMED A
JOB KILLER BILL- BY THE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND AS I MENTIONED
IT RECORD IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DOING THE JOB TO A GUY SHOULD
MADE IT AT HIS PAGER PAID FIVE
DAYS A STATE. IF FOR ONCE
FAMILY I THINK AND ASK FOR YOUR
ADULT IN SOME. A WORKERS IN
INDIVIDUALS AT A TIME WHEN THEY
NEED SUPPORT THE MOST I
RESPECTFULLY S. RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER MISTER VOEPEL YOU
RECOGNIZED. QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR. IN A LITTLE BIT OF A
SET UP FOR THIS IS. IN MY
CORPORATE WORLD WE WOULD GIVE
THREE DAYS BEREAVEMENT PAY
PAID. IN ANY EMPLOYEES THAT
WANTED TO GO TO A FUNERAL WE
GET THE DAY OFF PAY SO MY
QUESTION TO YOU. MISTER AUTHOR
IS WITH YOU WILLING TO IT
AMENDMENT AND HAVE THREE DAYS
BRAVE MEN PAY OR NOT PAY BUT
UNPAID. AS OKAY I CAN'T THANK
YOU VERY ADVENTURE MUCH FOR THE
A QUESTION AND ALSO SHARING
WHAT IS CURRENTLY IN THIS I TO
WHICH YOU'VE SHARED THE
RECOGNITION. BENEFACTOR YOU
HAVE THREE DAYS BUT IT IS PAID
THIS IS INDEED UNPAID. AND IT
SHOULD THIS FORD AND FORCE AND
I WON'T BE TAKING THOSE MINUTES
TODAY BUT I WOULD BE DEEPLY
COMMITTED AN ON THE RECORD TO
ADDRESS AND ACCOMMODATE AT OF
THREE DAYS I SHOULD THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD- IN RESPECT OF
HOUSE. ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT IS. THANK YOU
MISTER LOWE SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER LOVE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE WORK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THERE. ALL MEMBERS
WHO THIRD ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER THERE'D BE A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. YEAH. ON
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
IF YOU LOW MOVES A CALL. FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE A. B.
THIRTY SIXTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY ROOM THIRTY
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAKING DAILY AND OTHERS AND I
REALLY NAY HEALING ARTS. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THIRTY
SIXTEEN WILL CREATE A MORE
EFFICIENT PROCESS FOR LICENSE
VERIFICATION FOR CALIFORNIA
NURSES SEEKING EMPLOYMENT IN
MULTIPLE STATES BY REQUIRING
THEM INTO LET. VACATION SYSTEM.
OUR NUYS ATION IS MORE
NECESSARY THAN EVER GIVEN THE
PANDEMIC WE ARE FACING AND THE
MASSIVE HEALTH CARE FOR WORK
FOR SHORTAGE ACROSS THE NATION
MY OFFICE HAS HEARD FROM NURSES
FROM A CALIFORNIA LICENSE THE
HAVE MISSED OUT ON MANY JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AND HAD DIFFICULT
RESPONDING TO HOT SPOT AREAS OF
KOBE NINETEEN. FRIENDS LINK THE
LICENSE VERIFICATION PROCESS
WHICH IS BACKLOGGED IT CAN TAKE
UP TO TWELVE WEEKS. SO THESE
QUALIFIED NURSES MISS OUT ON
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AB
THIRTY SIXTEEN REQUIRES A B. R.
AND TO IMPLEMENT AN ONLINE
LICENSE VERIFICATION SYSTEM
CALLED NURSES .COM WHICH THEY
CURRENTLY CONTRACT WITH. IS
USED BY FORTY SEVEN OTHER
STATES TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
SECURE ONLINE LICENSE
VERIFICATION THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED FULL SUPPORT IN THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS WITHOUT A
SINGLE NO VOTE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON AB THIRTY
SIXTEEN TO HELP NURSES GET TO
WORK FASTER. THANK YOU MISTER
ALI SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A-
ALL MEMBERS AND WHO DESERVE IT.
CALL MEMBERS THIRTY VERY VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY SEVEN
NEWS HERE THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY AB THIRTY
FORTY THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
LEGAL THIRTY FORTY BY SOME
REMEMBER DAVID CHIU AN ACCOLADE
HOUSING MISTER DAVID CHIU YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB THIRTY FORTY WILL
GIVE CITIES THE CREDIT THEY
DESERVE AS A CONSIDER REZONING
DURING THIS HOUSING CRISIS IN
THE COMING YEARS CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE REQUIRED TO UPDATE
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENTS TO MEET
THEIR RENO OBLIGATIONS TO PLAN
FOR HOUSING NEEDS FOR EACH
REGION OF OUR STATE. THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SEE PROPER AND
PREDICTABLE CREDIT TOWARD THE
RENO NUMBERS IF THEY REZONE ON
SINGLE FAMILY HOUSING SINCE
SINCE POST VOLUNTARY FOR LOCAL.
THE MANDATE THE BILL SUPPORTED
BY I SIT IN COUNTY AS WELL AS
PRO HOUSING PRODUCTION
STAKEHOLDERS SINCE IT SUPPORTS
MORE HOUSING ON LOCAL TERMS I
APPRECIATE THEIR BEEN NO ZERO A
NO NO VOTES DURING THIS PROCESS
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I.
THANK YOU MAY CHOOSE HEARING NO
FOR DEBATE ON THE MATTER. WELL
OPEN ARE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR- ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. QUIRK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING TELLING
VOTE I FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS THREE
THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY ONE AB THIRTY FIVE
FORTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME MIDDLE THIRTY FORTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE TO PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS IN MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR. MISTER GRAY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THIRTY
FORTY FIVE REQUIRES MOST
LICENSING BOARDS UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
TO HONOR THE OUT OF STATE.
PROFESSIONAL LICENSES OF
VETERANS AND ACTIVE DUTY
MILITARY SPOUSES. THE BNP CODE
ALREADY CALLS FOR THE GAMING OR
THE GRANTING OF TEMPORARY
LICENSES TO MILITARY FAMILIES
IN MOST HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONS
AS WELL AS ENGINEERS LAND
SURVEYORS AND GEOLOGISTS. THIS
WOULD CREATE LICENSE
PORTABILITY FOR ALL OTHER
LICENSES FOR BOTH VETERANS AND
ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY SPOUSES
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE HOME. THANK YOU
MISTER GRAY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
LONG MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY SIX NEWS HERE THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE DISPENSE
WITH FILE ITEM ONE FORTY TWO
FILE AND ONE FORTY THREE AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN ACKLEY TO FIRE
PREVENTION. THREE MEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- THIS BILL
MANY OF YOU VOTED ON A VERY
SIMILAR BILL LAST YEAR- CREATES
A NEW FIVE FOOT ZERO FIVE
WHATEVER RESISTANCE- NEXT TO
HOUSES SO WHY IS THIS
IMPORTANT. AND THE LAST GROUP
WILD FIRES WE SAW EXAMPLE AFTER
EXAMPLE. OF HOUSES THAT WERE
BURNED WHEN NOTHING IN THEIR
YARD WAS BURNED SO A WALL OF
FIRE DIDN'T COME THROUGH IN IN
GOAL FOR THE HOUSE WHAT
HAPPENED WAS. EMBERS DRIFTED
SOMETIMES ONE MILE THROUGH THE
AIR LANDED ON SOMETHING THAT
WAS PLANTED RIGHT UP AGAINST
THE WALL OF THE HOUSE. CAUGHT
THE EMBERS ON FIRE IN THE
ENTIRE STRUCTURE WITH LOST THIS
BILL WILL CREATE A NEW ZERO TO
FIVE FOOT AMBER RESISTANCE OWN.
SEND A VERY STRONG SIGNAL TO
LANDSCAPE DESIGNERS AND
HOMEOWNERS ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF HAVING EVER EXISTED
MATERIALS RIGHT NEXT YOUR
HOUSE. IF YOU DON'T THINK THIS
IS NECESSARY LET ME JUST TELL
YOU MY HUSBAND'S OF TRAIN
LANDSCAPE DESIGNER THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE LANDSCAPE WHO
DOESN'T TELL LANDSCAPE DESIGN
THAT EVEN IN A HIGH FAIR
VERITIES OWN. SHOULDN'T WRAP
YOUR HOUSE AND PUSHES AND
PEOPLE. DESIGNING A WEBSITE
THAT PEOPLE ARE STILL IN THE
PLANTING WE HAVE TO HAVE A
SPECIFIC CODE THAT'S IN LAND.
IN OUR SCHOOL AS A CENTER TO
EIGHT WAYS AND IF AN APARTMENT
THE CAN FOR THERE. ABOUT THE
DANGER OF HAVING FOR WINTER
OVER TO THE SIDE HOUSE THIS
BILL HAS BEEN DEVELOPING
CONJUNCTION WITH- WITH- ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ON MEMBERS THIRTY THIRTY
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY FOUR. OKAY VIOLATE ONE
FORTY FIVE AB THIRTY NINETY TO
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
THIRTY NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS INOCULATED
CIVIL ACTIONS THIS WORKS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS UNDER CURRENT
LAW THE VAST MAJORITY OF CASES
CONNECTED TO DOCTOR HEAPS OF
PHYSICIAN EMPLOYED BY UCLA WHO
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED OVER TWO
HUNDRED WOMEN. IN THE COURSE OF
HIS THIRTY FIVE HER CAREER WILL
BE TIME BARRED BY THE STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS SB THIRTY NINETY TO
A TEMPORARY RELIEF CLAIMS THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE TIME BARRED
UNDER THE EXISTING STATUTE
LIMITATIONS FOR ONE YEAR. I'M
SUCH AS SUCH AS- SEXUAL ASSAULT
OR OTHER INAPPROPRIATE CONTACT.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OPPOSITION I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WHERE
X. SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE- ALL MEMBERS GO
TO DISCARD VOTE. QUIRK WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
FIFTY FIVE NOSE ONE THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE FORTY SIX
AB THIRTY NINETY SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME MIDDLE THIRTY
NINE SIX BY SOME REMEMBER DAVID
CHIU ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE TO
PUBLIC PUBLIC PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
MISTER DAVID CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES WE ALL AGREE
ON A WORKERS RIGHT TO ORGANIZE
UNFORTUNATELY DURING THE PAST
FEW YEARS THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS REPEATEDLY SENT
OUT INTO UNION COMMUNICATIONS
TO WORKERS ATTEMPTING TO
BARGAIN ON CAMPUSES ACROSS THE
STATE IN FLAGRANT VIOLATION OF
THE LAW. UNFORTUNATELY EVEN IF
A UNION A SUCCESSFUL IN
PETITIONING THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
MEANT RELATIONS BOARD PER. TO
GRANT AN UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE
THE DAMAGE HAS BEEN DONE AND
THERE IS NO MEANINGFUL
CONSEQUENCE TO YOU SEE. THIS
BILL WILL IMPOSE A FINANCIAL
PENALTY FOR SUCH ACTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT YOU SEEK CAREFULLY
CONSIDERS. BEFORE INTENTIONALLY
DISCOURAGING UNION ACTIVITY IN
THE PUBLIC SECTOR. WE ALL HAVE
A- TO PROTECT WORKERS IN OUR
STATE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER TO
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THE- LONG MEMBERS SO TWO TWO
THIRDS VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
AS ART OF THE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE EYES FORTY
SIX KNOWS TWELFTH THE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
SEVEN AB THIRTY NINETY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME MODELS
THIRTY NINETY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS AN ACCOLADE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE CERAMICS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
THIRTY NINE NINE STARTS TO MOVE
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO
ADDRESS A VERY REAL CONCERN IN
THE STATE WITH MISSING MURDER
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN.
JURISDICTIONAL CONFUSION AMONG
FEDERAL ALIFORNIA LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND TRIBAL
JUSTICE ENTITIES HAS A HISTORIC
PATTERN OF NEGLECT OF NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES. AND
HAVING CREATE A PERCEPTION THAT
CRIMES COMMITTED AGAINST NATIVE
AMERICANS ON TRIBAL
RESERVATIONS OCCUR IN A VAT
VIRTUAL VACUUM WHERE CRIMES
MANY TIMES ARE NOT EVEN
INVESTIGATED. NATIVE AMERICAN
WOMEN HAVE A RATE OF
VICTIMIZATION MORE THAN DOUBLE
OTHER RACIAL GROUPS IN ON THE
SAME TRAVEL RESERVATIONS.
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN ARE
MURDERED AT A RATE TEN TIMES
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE. AB THIRTY
NINETY NINE WOULD CREATE THREE
NEW POSITIONS WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO THE
TRIBAL POLICE COVERING
REPORTING STATISTICS AND
TRAINING MATERIALS. MATERIALS
THAT WILL START TO BRING
EDUCATIONAL PROCESS AROUND
PUBLIC LAW TWO EIGHTY. THESE
TYPES OF ISSUES HAVE COME UP IN
OUR COMMITTEE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS THESE
ARE VERY REAL ISSUES THAT ARE
AFFECTING THE NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND THIS BY NO MEANS. IS
A COMPLETE SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM HOWEVER THIS JUST
STARTS TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM
AS WE FURTHER START TO MOVE THE
STATE FORWARD AND RECOGNIZING
AND ADJUSTING PUBLIC SAFETY ON
INDIAN RESERVATIONS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I YOUR AYE
VOTE. HERE MISTER ROBERTS
SEEING HEARING NO FOR GREAT ON
THE MATTER CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. QUIRK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY THREE NOTES HERE
THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY EIGHT AB THIRTY ONE
OH SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FOR WHOM SEVEN BY
SOME REMEMBER WOMAN OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE ELAINE YEARS. MR BLOOM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU AB
THIRTY ONE OH SEVEN IS A
MEASURE THAT WILL HELP BUILD
HOUSING NEAR TRANSIT CENTERS
AND- WORD- AND NEAR JOBS WHERE
THE STATE DESPERATELY NEEDS IT.
THIS BILL WILL PERMIT HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT WITH AT LEAST 20%
OF UNITS DESIGNATED FOR LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS TO BE ALLOWED
ON ANY SITE DESIGNATED FOR
COMMERCIAL USE. RECORDERS ARE
IDEAL FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BECAUSE THEY'RE CLOSE TO
AMENITIES PUBLIC TRANSIT AND
JOB CENTERS HOWEVER MODERN
ZONING THAT SEPARATES
RESIDENTIAL AREAS FROM
COMMERCIAL AREAS UNDULY
RESTRICT THE NUMBER OF SITES
AVAILABLE FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. AND THIS BILL WILL
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
AVAILABLE SITES FOR HOUSING
ENCOURAGE MORE MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT WHILE MAINTAINING
THE CHARACTER OF THE COMMUNITY.
PROJECTS WILL BE LIMITED TO
INFILL SITES AND CITIES THAT
ZONE FOR THEIR SIX REINA CYCLE
WILL BE EXEMPT FROM THE BILL
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I'VE A- THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
HEARD OF IT. SMALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TOWN I DON'T ICE FORTY FIVE
NEWS TEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY NINE AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE. PASS
TEMPORARILY IN FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY NINE FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY FOUR THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME MIDDLE
THIRTY ONE SIXTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
ANOTHER'S MAC LATE FIRE
PREVENTION. THREE WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR DIRECTS CAL FIRE IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AND ADVISORY
WORKING GROUP TO DEVELOP A
PARCEL LEVEL WILDFIRE RISK
MODEL TO HELP COMMUNITIES
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE RISK FROM
WILD OR WHAT THEY CAN DO TO
REDUCE IT WELL CALIFORNIA'S
MAKING IMPORTANT INVEST RISK
REDUCTION THROUGH VARIOUS GRANT
PROGRAMS AND FUEL REDUCTION
ACTIVITIES THERE'S CURRENTLY NO
MODELER MAC. DEMONSTRATING HOW
MUCH RISK HAS BEEN REDUCED
THROUGH THESE ACTIVITIES HAZARD
MAPS DON'T SHOW REDUCTIONS IN A
SIGNIFICANT RISK XIN WORK HAS
BEEN COMPLETED DEVELOP. THEIR
TO FIT. EIGHT AND THAT THEY'RE
PUT OUT IN THE MONEY THAT THE
SPEND AFFECT OF THE PAUL AND
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WERE WORKED RISK
PRODUCTION WORK IS BEING DONE
REDUCING WILDFIRE RISK FIRE
PREVENTION DURING A PANDEMIC IS
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT BECAUSE
HYBRIDS SEVERITY WELL FIRE
SMOKE A LIKELY INCREASE
MORTALITY OF PEOPLE INFECTED
WITH THE NINETEEN IT DIDN'T
EVACUATION OF HOW FIRE
SUPPRESSION POSE TRANSMISSION
WRISTS WITHOUT URGENT AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. MESS FREE AND THING
HEARING. MATTER CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
AMERICA. ALL MEMBERS TO THIRDS
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
TWO NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY ONE.
THE BEST NUMBER EARLY ON FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY ONE. AT FEBRUARY
VIOLATE ONE FIFTY TWO. MR MATH
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY THREE AB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE THIRTY
TWO TWENTY BY THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TXIC
MATERIALS INOCULATED PESTICIDE
POISONING. THANK YOU MISTER
MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
PRESENT THIS MATTER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB THIRTY
TWO TWENTY IS A COMMITTEE BILL
THAT SIMPLY X. STANDS DE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL SUPERVISION
PROGRAM ENSURING WORKER SAFETY
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MAY I MATHIS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. VERY PAUL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE. ALL MEMBERS GO
TO THEIR TO VOTE. BUT THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY
THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY NINE IS
YOUR THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY FOUR AB THIRTY
TWO TWENTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME AGO THIRTY TWO
TWENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC ALL. MISTER RODRIGUEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. MATTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY FOUR CRATER PROCESS. TO
EXAMINE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE ISSUES
BY. REQUIRING CD PH A CONTRACT.
CONTRACT WITH A PROPER ENTITY
TO EVALUATE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ADEQUATE
STAFFING LEVELS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. THIS
WOULD ENSURE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS CAN SUCCESSFULLY
PERFORM DURING TIMES OF RUN
SHE'S. AND ADEQUATELY FLEX FLEX
TO MEET EMERGING COMMUNITY
NEEDS THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE. AH TO CONVENE AN
ADVISORY GROUP TO OVERSEE A
PROVIDE TECHNO ASSISTANCE TO
THE EVALUATION ENTITY. THIS
BILL IS CO SPONSORED BY THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXACT OF SOCIAL
ASIAN OF CALIFORNIA THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS . YEAH YOU. JOINT
TURN HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS ARE MET RESPECT ME US FOR
I WILL. THANK YOU MISTER
RODRIGUEZ SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR- ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELE VOTE I FIFTY NINE NEWS
HERE THE MEASURE PASSES. WE
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY FIVE MOVIE FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY SIX A. B. THIRTY
THREE OH SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME LEGAL THIRTY THREE OH
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
GARCIA ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR SIR GARCIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY THREE OH SEVEN THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTORY MARK.
BURNS ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
STRIDES TO ESTABLISH A DISASTER
LOAN AND LOAN GUARANTEE PROGRAM
AS WE'VE SEEN DURING THIS
PARTICULAR PANDEMIC- THE NEED
FOR A NUMBER OF EXECUTIVE
ORDERS AND RE DIRECT THE-
RESOURCES TO HELP OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE MANUFACTURING
COMPANIES HAS BEEN TAKING PLACE
FOR EXECUTIVE ORDER THIS
ACTUALLY QUALIFIES IT AND
ALLOWS THE- BANK. GOBIZ TO
ESTABLISH THE ACTUAL PROGRAM
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED OF
ART OF A- ALL MEMBERS VERY VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE THAT.
AND. WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY NINE
NEWS HERE THE MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY SEVEN AB
THIRTY THREE FIFTY TO THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
THREE FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
ACCOLADE THE BUILDINGS WHICH IS
FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. EVERY TENANT IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE CHILD OF
EVERY TEN IN CALIFORNIA
DESERVES A SAFE AND HABITABLE
PLACE TO LIVE. I READ A VERY
SHOCKING ARTICLE- A FEW MONTHS
AGO- THAT OUTLINED HOW SOME
CHILDREN HAD DIED BECAUSE OF AN
UNSAFE AND SUB STANDARD WIRING
IN THEIR APARTMENT. NOW THIS
YEAR HAVE BEEN REPORTED TO
AUTHORITIES BUT THEY REFUSE TO
INSPECT BECAUSE IN MANY
MUNICIPALITIES AROUND THE
STATE. THEY ACTUALLY PUT
DEMANDS ON TENANTS BEFORE THEY
WILL INSPECT FOR ON SAFE AND IT
ON AVAILABLE CONDITIONS IN
APARTMENTS. THEY WERE CAUGHT.
UP ON THEIR RENT THEY REQUIRE
THAT THEY FIRST NOTIFY THE
LANDLORD. AND TRY TO CORRECT TO
THE LANDLORD EVEN IF THOSE
TENANTS HAVE REASONS TO FEAR
EVICTION OR BEING REPORTED TO
ICE OR ANYTHING ELSE WHICH PUTS
A BUG AS YOU CAN TELL HUGE
BARRIER SOMETIMES TO REPORTING
THESE UNSAFE CONDITIONS. BUT
NONE OF THAT SHOULD MATTER TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AN APARTMENT
IS EITHER SEEK TO LIVE IN OR
IT'S NOT AND IT'S A
RESPONSIBILITY OF THOSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO INSPECT FOR
UNSAFE CONDITIONS AND MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE ARE REMEDY BY
PROPERTY OWNERS. AB THIRTY
THREE FIFTY TWO SIMPLY
PROHIBITS LOCAL COLD
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA FROM PLACING THOSE
KINDS OF RESTRICTIONS IN PRE
CONDITIONS BEFORE RESPONDING TO
PROBABILITY COMPLAINTS. THE
BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THAT
THE AGENCY PROVIDE COPIES OF
THE INSPECTION REPORT AND ANY
CITATIONS TO THE TECH ANOTHER
DOCUMENTS OF THE BUILDINGS WHO
MIGHT BE AFFECTED. SO THAT THEY
KNOW THE CORRECTIVE ACTION HAS
OR HAS NOT BEEN TAKEN. OUT I
PROVIDING A- WORK EIGHT THREE
WHO DOES NOT READ ANY NEW DO A
RESPONSE ON THE GOVERNMENTS I
DO NOT EXPECTED INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS MADE ONLY
HOPE. IT WILL GET THOSE COME IN
CALLED AND MORSE OUR CREATED.
MY OFFICES HAVE PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSION WITH REAL
REPRESENTATIVES OF CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND I'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THAT MAKES ANY ISSUE
OR DROP. ME THREE THREE IF TWO
BY THE WESTERN LAW ALREADY AND
CALIFORNIA ROLL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. AND I'M
OF TENANTS EVERYWHERE ARE
CORRECTLY. RESPECT AND I. YOU
MISTER. IT HEARING FURTHER
DEBATE ON MATTER BURKE WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
REGARDING THE- ALL MEMBERS GO
TO THEIR TO THE- ON MEMBERS
VOTE IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
HER WILL LOSE THEIR ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY FOUR
KNOWS FOURTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES HAS TEMPORARILY AND
VIOLATE ONE FIFTY EIGHT WE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY NINE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH
INOCULATED SCHOOL SAFETY. THIS
MAP YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN WOULD ESTABLISH THE SIX
THE STATE ASSISTANCE FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TEAM WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION UNDER THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE SS PI TO SUPPORT K.
TWELVE. SERVING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
FACING THE CHALLENGES OF
NATURAL DISASTERS PUBLIC HEALTH%
EPIDEMICS WIDE SCALE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISES AND OTHER
EMERGENCIES IMPACTING SCHOOLS.
THE SAFER TEAM WOULD BE CHARGED
WITH FOUR KEY RESPONSIBILITIES
ONE PROVIDING CLEAR AND TIMELY
DIRECTION AND COMMUNICATION
FROM THE S. S. P. I. AND THE CD
DIRECTLY TO SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS PARTICULARLY
AROUND CLOSURES AND RE OPENING
OF SCHOOLS. TO SHARING
KNOWLEDGE OF BEST PRACTICES
FROM SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
ACROSS THE RELEVANT BRANCH
DIVISIONS I'VE CD AND LEE EYES
LIAISING WITH LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL PARTNERS TO ADDRESS THE
RANGE OF SPECIFIC NEEDS IN AN
EMERGENCY. THREE EXPEDITING THE
EXISTING PROCESS HE IS FOR
REQUESTS FOR ALLOWANCE OF
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE DUE TO
EMERGENCY CONDITIONS THE J.
THIRTEEN A FORM AND PROVIDING
GUIDANCE THROUGH THIS PROCESS
AND FOR ESTABLISHING THE
COLLECTION OF DATATO ALLOW FOR
REAL TIME MONITORING AND
EVALUATION IN EMERGENCIES. THIS
SAFER TEAM WOULD INCLUDE
SUPPLEMENTARY COORDINATING
STAFF IN ADDITION TO
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
RELEVANT BRANCHES DIVISIONS TO
ENSURE THAT EMERGENCY RESPONSE
EFFORTS ARE BEING EVALUATED
BOTH FROM A GLOBAL PERSPECTIVE.
I'M THROUGH EACH OF THE FACETS
OF SIR IS THAT SCHOOLS PROVIDE
THIS BILL WAS ORIGINAL INTO
ADDRESS COOL CLOSURES RESULTING
FROM WILDFIRES PUBLIC SAFETY
POWERSHOT UP. UNTIL CRAZY. AND
THE SCHOOL BY. OVER THIS DEMI
DEMONSTRATED HOW MUCH. AND FOR
THE SIX SERVICES AND POINTS FOR
WELLNESS FOR IN THEIR ENTIRE
FAMILY. SO THESE ARE
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGING TIMES
BUT BY PRIORITIZING PLANNING
COMMUNICATION AND BEST
PRACTICES WE WILL BE READY TO
PROVIDE A QUALITY EDUCATION TO
ALL OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISS MATH SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO. SMALL MEMBERS KNOWN
AS ARE THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
AS ART OF THE. WORK WELL CLOSE
THE ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY FOUR NEWS ONE THE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE
AB EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME AGO
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US ANOTHER
CYNICAL IN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. THIS RIVAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ONE SECOND. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. FOR ALL PAINFULLY
AWARE THAT THE STATE WAS
STRUGGLING TO OVERCOME ITS
GROWING HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
WELL BEFORE COVERT NINETEEN.
HAPPENED THE PANDEMIC AND THIS
RECESSION RESULTING FROM IT
WILL LIKELY EXACERBATE AND THE
ALREADY CATASTROPHIC STATE OF
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA. DUE
TO THE PROLONGED IMPACTS OF
THIS VIRUS MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE FAMILIES WILL
LOSE THEIR JOBS LIVELIHOODS AND
THEIR HOME. COVER NINETEEN
COULD TURN OUR HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS INTO A FULL BLOWN HEALTH
AND SAFETY CATASTROPHE. AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE SIXTY
CREATE THE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
COMMUNICATION THAT IS REQUIRED.
NOW MORE THAN EVER BY
ESTABLISHING A CENTRALIZED
STATE OFFICE TO END
HOMELESSNESS THIS MEASURE ALSO
CREATES A SECRETARY ON HOUSING
AND SECURITY IN HOMELESSNESS TO
ENSURE GREATER COORDINATION
BETWEEN THE THIRTEEN DIFFERENT
STATE AGENCIES. AND DEPARTMENTS
IMPLEMENTING OVER THIRTY
DIFFERENT EXISTING PROGRAMS
RELATED TO HOMELESSNESS.
MEMBERS YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE
MY WORD. THAT THIS IS THE RIGHT
APPROACH THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND EVEN GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S COUNCIL OF REGIONAL
HOMELESS ADVISORS HAVE ALL
RECOMMENDED THAT WE ESTABLISH A
CENTRALIZED OFFICE ON
HOMELESSNESS. AND THERE'S GOOD
REASON TO DO SO THE LA-
RECENTLY STATED THAT A
FRAGMENTED RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS CREATES VARIOUS
CHALLENGES INCLUDING DIFFICULTY
TRACKING ALL HOMELESSNESS
RELATED EXPENDITURES ACROSS THE
STATE DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE
HOW PROGRAMS WORK COLLABORATE
TO FLEE. AND DIFFICULTY
ASSESSING WHAT PROGRAMS ARE
COLLECTIVELY ACCOMPLISHING. I
TRUE BUT TRULY BELIEVE WE HAVE
SOME OF THE MOST DEDICATED AND
BRIGHTEST INDIVIDUALS WORKING
ON HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE
HOWEVER THEY NEED HELP TO
ADDRESS AN INCREDIBLY
FRAGMENTED STATE SYSTEM. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR BIBLE BEING THANK YOU MISS
RIVAS. MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- I'VE SEEN THIS IN
MY OWN COMMUNITY WHERE YOU KNOW
THERE'S THERE ARE SO MANY
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS- DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS AND YOUR MANY OF
MY COUNTIES. HAVE TROUBLE
NAVIGATING ENSURING THEY COMPLY
SO HAVING THIS. YOU KNOW PERSON
THAT CAN HELP COORDINATE THOSE
AN OBVIOUSLY. AT A GIVEN. IN
THE IN THE FUTURE DOING MORE TO
HELP CONSOLIDATE THESE PROGRAMS
AND MAKE THEM MORE. NAVIGABLE
FIRE CAN TO BE A THINGS. REDUCE
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MYSTERY
GUEST WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SURE THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS AND- NO ONE. CAN DO IS
LOOK BACK AND SAY WE COULD OF
WE SHOULD HAVE RESPONDED MORE
AGGRESSIVELY TO THE TO COME
BACK HOMELESSNESS AND THE
IMPACTS OF THE NINETEEN- SO. WE
REALLY NEED TO DO SOMETHING
TODAY- AND I BELIEVE THAT
ESTABLISHING IN THIS OFFICE IS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. WELL OPEN.
MEMBERS ONLY DESERVE A- ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS LED HER DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE TWELVE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING VOTE I FIFTY
EIGHT NEWS HERE THE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO
A. B. NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY GOING
TO SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GREAT ACCOLADE
HORSE RACING A MAKING OF
OPERATION ARE FOR MR GRAY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS- AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR IS AN EFFORT
UNDERTAKEN BY BOTH HOUSES WE
HAVE AN ASSEMBLY BILL AS WELL
AS THE SENATE BILL- TO ADDRESS.
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S HORSE
RACING INDUSTRY AS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE THE GOLD STANDARD HORSE
RACING HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
WE'VE HAD. SOME INCREDIBLE
BREEDERS SOME INCREDIBLE RACES
WE HAVE SOME BEAUTIFUL TRACKS-
BUT THEY'VE BEEN UNDERGOING A
DIFFICULT TIME THERE'S BEEN
EQUINE FATALITIES- THAT ARE
UNACCEPTABLE AND BOTH THE
SENATE SAMIR WORKING TOGETHER
TO ADDRESS THAT WITH- STANDARDS.
I AM PROUD. WOULD CONTAIN THIS
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER GRAY
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. OF ALL
MEMBERS ROADSIDE OF IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THIRD VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY TWO THIRDS
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALENTED I SIXTY SIX NEWS
HERE THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY THREE AB TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME AGO TWENTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON ALCALINA PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES AND DECLARE
NEAR ZERO PACIFIC IMMEDIATELY.
YOUR GIFTS AND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWENTY. TO THINGS THAT
BRING OUT THIS SIX TO WAIVE
LICENSE FARMERS. TO CREATE SIX
YEARS A RESTORATIVE CARE PILOT
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO TREAT
HOMELESSNESS- MENTAL ILLNESS
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND CAR
INCARCERATION. SECOND POINT
REQUIRES A COUNTY DIRECTOR OF
MENTAL HEALTH TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE TWO YEARS ALL THE
PROGRAMS OUTCOME AND COST
EFFECTIVENESS MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WITH VOTE ON
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. YOU MISTER
GIBSON SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
AND MEMBERS VOTERS THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AREN'T VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
AYE SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. AND I SIXTY
YOUR NOTES HERE ON THE URGENCY
AS WELL. WE WILL PASS A ROUTINE
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FOUR
VIOLATED ONE SIXTY FIVE EIGHTY
TWENTY FORTY THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME LEGAL TWENTY FORTY BY
SOME REMEMBER BIGELOW ANOTHER
SNACK LEYVA TAXATION. MR
BIGELOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FORTY
ADDRESSES AN ERROR THAT
OCCURRED REGARDING ALLOCATION
OF IN LIEU LICENSE FEES- IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE FOUND THE
END THE INCORRET NUMBERS THIS
ACTION TODAY WILL REMEDY THE
SITUATION AND MAKE EVERYONE
RIGHT. I ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER BIGELOW SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
DESERTED. HOME MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ON VOTED OUT OF
A. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY
THREE NOTES HERE THE MEASURE
PASSES. DISPENSED WITH FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY SIX PASADENA
VIOLATE ONE SIXTY SEVEN FILE
ITEM IN SIXTY EIGHT AB TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME AGO TWENTY ONE HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE MEDICO. THROUGH A YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
IS IN RESPONSE TO A CHANGE IN
MEDI CAL PHARMACY REIMBURSEMENT
IN FEE FOR SERVICE IT TOOK FACT
AFFECT THE NIGHT TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
CHANGE THE PRESCRIPTION DRUG
BENEFIT FROM BENEFIT PROVIDED
BY MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS
TO INSTEAD BE PROVIDED THROUGH
FEE FOR SERVICE THE BIPARTISAN
BILL WITH NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I. D.
MISTER WITH SEEING HEARING
FURTHER DEBATE I'M OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS WHO. ON MEMBERS THIRTY
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS SAID HIS
ART OF THE- BURKE WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY
TWO NEWS HERE THE MEASURE
PASSES. BY LATE ONE SIXTY NINE
AB TWENTY ONE TWELVE THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME A BILL TWENTY
ONE TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS ANOTHER'S MACULATUS
SUICIDE PREVENTION SURROUND US
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS. AB
TWENTY ONE TWELVE ESTABLISHES A
STATEWIDE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
EVEN BEFORE THE CURRENT COVE IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC SUICIDE RATES
AMONG ALL GROUPS HAVE BEEN
INCREASING INCREASING
DRASTICALLY THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE
AFFECT PEOPLE FROM ALL WALKS OF
LIFE. BUT RISK OF SUICIDE IS
ESPECIALLY SIGNIFICANT AMONG
ADOLESCENTS OLDER ADULTS
VETERANS AND LGBT Q. YOUTH AND
ADULTS AS WELL AS OUR
FIREFIGHTERS. SUICIDE RISK IS
SIGNIFICANT IN THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES NATIVE
AMERICAN YOU FACE HIGHER RATES
OF SUICIDE THAN THEIR PEERS. IN
ADDRESSING THE CRISIS OF
SUICIDE WILL REQUIRE A FOCUS ON
THE NATIVE AMERICAN YOU. AS WE
LOOK FORWARD WE NEED TO PREPARE
FOR INCREASED PRESSURE ON THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM NOT
ONLY DURING THIS CRISIS BUT IN
THE LONG TERM. AB TWENTY TWELVE
TAKES THE FIRST STEP IN
ADDRESSING THE CURRENT CRISIS
OF SUICIDE BY CREATING A
STATEWIDE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS OFFICE WILL CENTRALIZE
STATE RESOURCES MARSHALL
EXPERTISE AND BUILD ON THE
VITAL WORK OF STAKEHOLDERS I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER RAMOS MISS WALDRON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE AS CO
AUTHOR OF AB TWENTY ONCE WHILE.
CREATING THE STATEWIDE OFFICE
OF SUICIDE PREVENTION WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
TO ADDRESS THE SUICIDE CRISIS
FACING OUR STATE THIS BILL
OFFERS A VITAL LIFELINE TO
THOSE WHO HAVE CONTEMPLATED OR
ATTEMPTED SUICIDE. OF THIS POOR.
REPRESENTS BUY USED ESPECIALLY
NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH AS THE
AUTHOR POINTED OUT I COMMEND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM HIGHLAND FOR
LEADING THIS CRITICAL EFFORT
AND CHEN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS WALDRON SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISS RAMOS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS VOTER
THEIR VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO STARTED THE- ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY ONE NEWS HERE THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY AB TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ. ONE
SEVENTY. TWENTY ONE FORTY TWO
WILL BE BUILT TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN BY SOME THE ROOM
RODRIGUEZ AN ACCOLADE HIGHER
EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS
MISTER RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS TO THEIR RIGHTS
PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN
THIS BILL WE PROVIDE THE
MINIMUM EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS TO
CERTAIN EMPLOYEES WHO WORK FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION IN. ORDER
EMPLOYEES IN A PART IN THIS
BILL WILL WORK IN HIGHER
EDUCATION ARE NOT AFFORDED
BASIC RIGHT INCLUDING DUE
PROCESS. REGARDING TERMINATION
OF EMPLOYMENT OR DISCIPLINE
THAT COULD. NEGATIVELY AFFECT.
THE FUTURE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE SOMETHING
MINOR. HAS HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH A LICENSE ACADEMIC OR
CLINICAL MATTER. BECAUSE OF THE
ONGOING CRISIS IN HEALTHCARE
TODAY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THE
MINOR THINGS DON'T GET IN THE
WAY OF OUR FUTURE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR THESE
WORKERS ARE SPENT YEARS
LEARNING THE PRACTICE OF
MEDICINE. ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY
ARE NEEDED SO MUCH TODAY
BECAUSE OF CORPORATE NINETEEN
RESPECT US FOR I WILL. THANK
YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ MISTER
MEDIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM POMONA.
FOR TAKING THE ADDITIONAL TIME-
TO TALK TO YOU SEE. AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
STATED. IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE COMPETENT
TEACHERS. AND IT IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
COMPETENT DOCTORS- I. VERY MUCH
THINK THAT THIS IS A NEEDED
BILL ONE THAT WILL PROTECT
RESIDENTS AND INTERNS IN THE
MEDICAL FIELD. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MEDINA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER RODRIGUEZ
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
HERTZBERG RESTAURANT. BURKE
WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS GO TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS
THIRTY TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY TO THIRTY VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THOSE GUYS FORTY FOUR
NEWS FOURTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
ONE AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME MIDDLE
TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORY ANOTHER
SNACK LIKE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DISTRICT ARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY TWO BELL AS APPLE FOR THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO INCREASE
ADOPTIONS OF RESCUE ANIMALS AND
PROTECT ANIMAL WELFARE BY
PROHIBITING THE RETAIL SALE OF
DOGS CATS AND RABBITS FROM
PUPPY MILLS. THE INTENT OF THIS
LAWS TO SUPPORT GREATER ACCESS
TO RESCUED ANIMALS BUT BECAUSE
SALES OF PUPPIES KITTENS AND
RABBITS REMAIN LEGAL SOME PET
SHOP OWNERS HAVE FOUND CREATIVE
WORK AROUNDS TO MAINTAIN THEIR
COMPLIANCE WITH CURRENT STATE
LAW. FOR EXAMPLE PRIOR TO THE
RECENT PASSAGE OF LEGISLATION
PARTNERING ORGANIZATIONS
QUICKLY OBTAIN NONPROFIT STATUS
JUST PRIOR TO THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE STATE LAW IN ORDER TO WE
CAN DO WE HAVE TO CAN YOU TO
SELL- ANIMALS OFTEN SOURCE FROM
PUPPY MILLS- THIS BILL
EXPLICITLY PROHIBITS THE SALE
OF THESE KINDS OF ANIMALS WHILE
ALLOWING RETAIL ESTABLISHMENTS
SOME FLEXIBILITY TO PARTNER.
WITH RESCUES AND SHELTERS FOR
THE ADOPTION EVENTS THIS BILL
WILL RESTRICT HIS STRICKEN
SAFEGUARDS TO PREVENT THE
EXPLOITATION OF ANIMALS BRED IN
HORRIBLE CONDITIONS AND
IMPORTANT FOR SALE ALEX PRESS
MY CATION TO MY COLLEAGUEFROM
LONG BEACH FOR HIS PARTNERSHIP
ON THIS MEASURE. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BOB BROAD BI PARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IBM. THANK YOU MISTER
GLORIA MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM IS.
I AS PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL WHICH CLOSES A
LOOPHOLE IN CALIFORNIA'S FIRST.
IN THE NATION BAN ON SALE
COMMERCIALLY BRED- PETS IN
RETAIL STORES. THE EXPLOITATION
OF ANIMALS HAS LED TO COUNTLESS
TRAGIC CASES INCLUDING THAT OF
BELLA THE SAN DIEGO CORGI FROM
HOME THIS BILL IS NAME. IT HAS
BEEN SAID IF ANIMALS COULD
SPEAK YOU MANAGE THE WOULD CRY.
I URGE AND I BOTH. THANK YOU
MISS WALDRON SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER COREY WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. FAST RELIABLE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS GO
THROUGH THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO BALANCE LAW
PASSES. MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY TWO. AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
FROM THE BILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUN
REPORTER RIVAS ANOTHER WAS NOT
RELATED HEALTHCARE SERVICE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. CHAIR I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO ONE SIX FOUR. THIS
BILL WOULD MAKE. PERMANENT THE
TEMPORARY REGULATORY CHANGES
GIVEN TO FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CARE CENTERS AND RURAL
HEALTH CLINICS THAT HAVE
INCREASED ACCESS TO THE TELL
HEALTH CARE AMID OUR CURRENT CO
THE NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. IN PARTICULAR THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW THESE IMPORTANT
HEALTH CENTERS TO ESTABLISH
NEW- NEW CLIENTS SOME NEW
PATIENTS REMOTELY VIA THE
TELEHEALTH SERVICES. AND
CLEARLY THESE VIRTUAL OR THESE.
TECHNOLOGICALLY POSSIBLE
CHANGES. HAVE TAKEN ON A
SPECIAL- YOU KNOW HAVE THEIR IN
YOUNG PROBABLY MORE IMPORTANT
THIS IS THE WAKE OF OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. AND WILL BE NO
LESS IMPORTANT AS THIS CRISIS
COMES TO AN END AND BEGINS TO
WANE IN THE RULE PARTS OF OUR
STATE OUR HEALTH CLINICS ARE
HEALTH CENTERS THEY SERVE THE
MOST MEDICALLY VULNERABLE
PEOPLE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
FOR TOO LONG RURAL- YOU KNOW
OUR CONSTITUENCIES IN THE ROLE
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA HAVE LACKED
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO QUALITY
HEALTHCARE YEARS OF RESEARCH
HAVE SHOWN THE POTENTIAL FOR
THE TELL HOW TO IMPROVE ACCESS
TO CARE. TO LOWER COSTS AND
INCREASED FLEXIBILITY FOR
PATIENTS AND FOR OUR PROVIDERS.
THIS BILL- CAN CERTAINLY PAVE
THE WAY FOR A MORE INNOVATIVE
ADAPTABLE AND ADVANCED
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IN OUR STATE.
THAT CAN YOU OF THE SYSTEM THAT
CAN MORE EFFICIENTLY MEET THE
NEEDS FOR OUR RURAL PARTS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND FOR OUR- ARE-
CONSTITUENCIES ARE COMMUNITIES
OF THOSE THAT ARE AT RISK AND
MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR STATE-
AND CERTAINLY WILL WILL WILL
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO HELP OUR
HEALTH CARE. PROVIDERS IN IN
THESE AREAS SO I CERTAINLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITH THAT THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MISTER IS
MISTER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AS A CO AUTHOR
ON THIS BILL I CANNOT STRESS
THE IMPORTANCE OF TELEHEALTH.
ESPECIALLY FOR- OUR COMMUNITIES
IN RURAL AREAS PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS ISSUES. ON THIS GOES
MUCH MUCH FARTHER BEYOND COVE
IT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THIS
BODY HAS BEEN PUSHING FOR
YEARS- AND I ENCOURAGE ALL OF
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS WE HAVE-
FAMILIES IN DESPERATE NEED OF
THESE THINGS PEOPLE THAT FACE
ISSUES. WITH BEING ABLE TO GET
INTO TOWN TO SEE DOCTORS IN
THIS GIVES THEM THE ABILITY TO
DO IT FROM THE COMFORT OF THEIR
HOMES MEMBERS ASK YOU FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER MATHIS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISS RIVAS WULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE- CERTAINLY. WANT
TO THANK EVERYBODY IN ASK FOR
HAVE A- TECH WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED A. ALL
MEMBERS THAT YOU DESERVE A. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE A. WHERE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY TWO NEW ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES BY LIGHT AND ONE
SEVENTY THREE AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME AGO TWENTY ONE EIGHTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER AROUND THE
LINE ACCOLADE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS. MISTER. DR
EMILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY NINE WHICH HELPS SMALL
TELEPHONE COMPANIES PROVIDE
SERVICE TO THEIR CUSTOMERS BY
RESTORING THE ADVICE LETTER
PROCESS AT THE P. YOU SEE. FOR
DECADES THE P. YOU SEE HANDLE
RATE CASES FOR SMALL TELEPHONE
COMPANIES THROUGH THE INFORMAL
ADVICE LETTER PROCESS WHICH
TYPICALLY TAKES LESS THAN A
YEAR TO COMPLETE. IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE CPUC BEGAN
REQUIRING THE SMALL TELEPHONE
COMPANIES TO GO THROUGH THE
FORMAL APPLICATION PROCESS
WHICH IS A PROCESS USUALLY
RESERVED FOR COMPLEX THREE
CASES OF LARGE UTILITIES THE
FORMAL PROCESSES BURDENSOME
TIME CONSUMING AND EXPENSIVE
FOR EVERYONE INVOLVED IT IS
ALSO OUT OF PROPORTION RELATIVE
TO THE SIZE OF THE SMALL
TELEPHONE COMPANIES. AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY NINE ESTABLISHES A
REASONABLE STANDARD FOR WHEN
THE P. YOU SEE CAN REJECT AN
ADVICE LETTER AND REQUIRE A
SMALL TELEPHONE COMPANY TO FILE
A FORMAL APPLICATION AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY NINE WILL ENCOURAGE
THE P. YOU SEE TO COMPLETE
THESE RAPE CASES A MORE
EFFICIENT COST EFFECTIVE AND
TIMELY MANNER THAT IS MORE IN
LINE WITH THE SMALL SIZE OF THE
RIVER BURL TELEPHONE COMPANIES.
THAT HELP TO ENSURE THE
CONTINUITY OF SERVICE TO THE
CUSTOMERS WHO RELY ON THEM
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR LIVE. THANK YOU MISTER
SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YEAH PETER THANK YOU AS WE GO-
WHAT I COULD HAVE PUT IT BETTER
THAN THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL I
DO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IT IS A REASONABLE BILL THAT
HELPS SMALL RULE- TELEPHONE
COMPANIES GET A WINDFALL IN
VACATION BEFORE THE PC AND IT
ADDS TENS PERRY MAKES MORE
EFFICIENT AND IT REALLY IT
REALLY WILL HELP- CONDUCTIVITY
WITHIN RULE COMMUNITIES ARE
SPECIALLY ASK FOR NINE THE-
THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO
MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THURMOND SPEAKER
MEMBERS ALSO RISE- IN STRONG
SUPPORT WITH- MUCH APPRECIATION
FOR MISTER SAN DIEGO MR RABBIT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS. FOR
SOMETIME THIS IS A REAL
SOLUTION FOR REAL SET OF
PROBLEMS AND I KNOW THE SMALL
TELEPHONE COMPANIES
PARTICULARLY IN OUR NECK OF THE
WOODS. ARE VERY GRATEFUL AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE ON THIS
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
HARRIS AND SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THERE TO
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS SAID HE
DESERVED IT. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
TO THEIR TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTER
AYE SIXTY ONE NEWS HERE THE
MEASURE PASSES IRELAND ONCE IT.
MISTER CALDERON FOR A REASON
YOU ICE YEAH MEMBERS WANT TO
REMIND YOU THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING EACH OTHER. DON'T BE
DRESSED EACH OTHER BY THEIR
NAMES. BY WHETHER FROM THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON
FOR THE REMINDER. WE ARE ON
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY FOUR AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME OF YOUR TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO ANOTHER SNUGGLING
ACCESS TO HEALTH SERVICES.
MISTER SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MAN
SPEAKER I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN WHICH TO
PROVIDE MEDICAL AND DIRECT
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR THE- D. G.
I. COMMUNITY. WE'LL KNOW
THERE'S BEEN ALARMING
DISPARITIES FOR HEALTH CARE FOR
TRANS GENDER FOR CHANGE OF THE
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE IS ONLY
BEEN EXASPERATED BY COVE IN
NINETEEN. THIS IS A VITAL IT'S
VITAL WE PROVIDE RECENTLY THE
TGI COMMUNITY TO ACCESS
APPROPRIATE HEALTH CARE I
RESPECTFULLY OFF HIS BODY FOR
NINE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
SANTIAGO SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIRD VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE A.
CLERK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE AYE AYES FORTY FIVE
KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE PASSES WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY FIVE. I MEAN
IF I LEARNED ONE SEVENTY SIX AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE BY SOME
REMEMBER MASON ACCOLADE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. MR MAYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AS COPD IS A
SERIOUS LUNG CONDITION THAT
LEAVES INDIVIDUALS PARTICULARLY
SUSCEPTIBLE TO COVERT NINETEEN.
AT LEAST ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE COPD COPD
DON'T KNOW THAT THEY HAVE IT.
THIS POPULATION HAS BEEN THE
LOWER END OF THE SOCIO ECONOMIC
LADDER. TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO
THIS LEDGE RESERVE CODE SECTION
FOR COPD RECOGNIZE IT AS A
CHRONIC DISEASE. BUT AS REMAIN
ENTIRELY BLANK SINCE THEN. THIS
BILL WOULD INCREASE AWARENESS
FOR COPD SO THOSE AFFECTED CAN
SEE THE APPROPRIATE TREATMENT
AND LOWER THERE IS FROM KOBE
NINETEEN. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MAYES SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIRD OF A-
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES WILL PASS A RETAINER
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY SEVEN WE
DISPENSE WITH FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT FILE AND ONE
SEVENTY NINE AB TWENTY FOUR OH
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR FIVE
BY SOME REMEMBER BURKE
ANOTHER'S NAPOLI TO HOUSING
MISS BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE
ESTABLISHES THE RIGHT TO
HOUSING FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES EFFECTIVE IN TWENTY
TWENTY SIX YOU TWENTY FOUR OH
FIVE EMPHASIZES THE PERMANENT
HOUSING WAS THE ONLY WAY WE CAN
TRULY AND HOMELESSNESS AND
PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK OUTLINING
THE AS PRACTICES FOR COMBATING
HOMELESSNESS WHICH INCLUDE.
PREVENTING FAMILIES FOR LOSING
THEIR HOME IN THE FIRST PLACE
PROVIDING EMERGENCY
ACCOMMODATIONS WITH SUPPORT
SERVICES SHOULD A FAMILY LOSE
THEIR HOME INTERESTED
TRANSITIONING THE FAMILY TO
PERMANENT HOUSING ALL FOSTERING
A CULTURE OF DIGNITY AND
RESPECT. THE BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES GRADE COORDINATION
ACROSS STATE DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES TO STREAMLINE AND
INTEGRATE POLICIES AND SERVICES
TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS AND THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS ARE SUBJECT
TO A BUDGET APPROPRIATION. NOW
MORE EVER WE ARE AWARE OF HOW
MANY FAMILIES AND HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ARE ONE PAYCHECK
AWAY FROM BEING HOMELESS. WE
CANNOT FULLY RECOVER FROM THIS
PANDEMIC UNTIL EVERY FAMILY AND
CHILD IS HOUSED IT'S MY BELIEVE
THAT ESTABLISHING THIS
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO HOUSING.
MOVES US FROM A PURELY
VOLUNTARY EFFORT TO ONE THAT
CREATES NEEDED ACCOUNTABILITY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TONIGHT
BUT- THANK YOU MISS BURKE
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
NINE KNOWS THREE THE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME LEGAL
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE BY SOME
MEMBER QUIRK AN ACCOLADE IN
LAND USE MISS RIVAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED PERCENT ON DOCTOR
WORKS BEHALF. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE ON BEHALF OF OUR
COLLEAGUE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK. AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
ONE ENABLES MOBILE
COMMUNICATION PROVIDERS TO
INSTALL BACKUP. POWER
GENERATORS AND EXISTING CELL
SITES AT A FASTER RATE. THIS
TIMELY INSTALLATION WILL BE
CRITICAL PREPARING FOR THE
COMING WILDFIRE SEASONS. AND
POSSIBLE PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFF. MY ENERGY COMPANIES.
ENABLING THE RAPID DEPLOYMENT
OF EMERGENCY STANDBY GENERATORS
IS VITAL FOR PUBLIC SAFETY TO
HELP INSURE. CONSUMERS MAINTAIN
ACCESS TO NINE ONE ONE SERVICES
WIRELESS EMERGENCY ALERTS AND
OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS. PREVIOUS
WILDFIRE WILDFIRES HAVE TAUGHT
US THAT WE NEED TO BETTER
PREPARE FOR THE GROWING THREAT
OF WILDFIRES. POWER OUTAGES.
AND OTHER DISASTERS. THIS IS
WHY ORGANIZATIONS LIKE A TNT
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS. AND THE
WESTERN FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY ONE AS WELL AS MANY
OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK. HAS
WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS A RESULT. THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA R. C. R. C. ARE NOW
IN SUPPORT. AND OTHERS THAT HAD
CONCERNS ARE NOW NEUTRAL. THIS
BILL HENRY HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS RIVAS
MR LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES THANK YOU <c.cyan>G. MADAM</c>
CHAIR I RISE IN SUPPORT IN THIS
OF VERY. DETECTIVE OF A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE DURING A PER
EMERGENCIES LIKE OF BIG GO WILD
FIRES AN EXTENDED POWER SHUT
OFFS MOBILE COMMUNICATIONS
BECOME VERY VERY CRITICAL VERY
VERY DIFFICULT DURING THESE.
THESE EMERGES CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT'S WHY. THIS BILL LEARNS
THE SUPPORT OF A HOST OF
ORGANIZATIONS ARE JUST TO NAME
A FEW THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HIGHWAY
PATROLMAN PORAC THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE WESTERN
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION. I
WOULD ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
VERY COMMONSENSE APPROACH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISS YOU
THIS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SURE- ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK I'D LIKE TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM PALM DEL- FOR
SUPPORTING- AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THOSE GUYS SIXTY FOUR
NEWS HERE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK UP IN FILE ORDER TO FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY ONE AB THIRTY
TWO OH FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY TWO OH FIVE
BY SOME REMEMBER SALAS AND
OTHERS NOT COMING TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT MR SALAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TWO OH FIVE WHICH
ESTABLISHES THE REGION'S RISE
GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN GOBIZ
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN IVAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER OF THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROOM. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. WHERE WILL. CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
ONE NEWS HERE THE MEASURE
PASSES WE WILL NOW MOVE DOWN TO
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY FIVE AB
THIRTY THREE OH TO THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
THREE OH TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SALAS IMMACULATE THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT IT'S JUST SALAS YOUR
AGAIN RECOGNIZED. LIKE AROUND
FIGURE MEMBERS ARE PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY THREE OH
TWO WHICH IS A BIG NEGOTIATED
BETWEEN BARGAINING UNIT THANKS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED THEIR TO. MOM MEMBERS GO
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. QUIRK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE EYES FIFTY FIVE NEWS FOR
THE MEASURE PASSES. GIVING BACK
TO FILE ORDER WE DISPENSE WITH
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY ONE WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY TWO WE'VE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY THREE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
FOUR AB TWO FIVE NINETEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME OF BILL
TWENTY FIVE NINETEEN BY SOME
REMEMBER WOULD ACTUALLY THE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION. MISTER
WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBER AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETEEN SEEKS TO
ADDRESS A SHORT COMING IN THE
GRANT PAYMENT PROCESS AND CUT
THE GREEN TAPE THAT IS
PREVENTING RESTORATION PROJECTS
AND LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE. AS IT EXISTS
RIGHT NOW GRANT TO WORK THE
AWARDING MUST FLOW THE COST OF
A PROJECT OUT OF POCKET. AND
APPLY FOR REIMBURSEMENT FROM
THE WORDING AGENCY AFTER THE
FACT THIS PROCESS TAKES THREE
SIX MONTHS THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE GRANTING AGENCY TO
PROVIDE UP 225% OF THE GRANT IN
ADVANCE OF THE PROJECT FOR THIS
CLIMATE RESILIENCE RESTORES
WATERSHEDS OR PROTECTS AND
PRESERVES NATURAL LANDS. THE
AMENDMENTS FROM APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ADDRESS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL FOR FRAUD
THE BIPARTISAN BILL WITH NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER
WOODS SEEING HERE FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. LONG
MEMBERS THIRTY DESIRED BOTH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
BURKE WELL. CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TAX TALLY THE VOTE HI SIXTY ONE
NEWS HERE THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL PASS THIRTEEN ON FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY FIVE BY LATE
ONE EIGHTY SIX AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME AGO TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY ONE
BY SOME MEMORY AS ANOTHER SNACK
LATER CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
MITHRAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY PRESENT AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY ONE A BILL
WHICH CREATES A WORK BROOKE
WORK GROUP TO CONSIDER CRUCIAL
STAKEHOLDER CONCERNS IN THE
EVENT OF ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGES
IN EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS. IN THE PAST FEW YEARS
THERE'S BEEN INCREASED FOCUS ON
HOW TO BETTER ADMINISTER EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
IT IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
AND THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET
PROCESS AN ARRAY OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
ARE BEING CONSIDERED. TO BE
TRANSITION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TO THE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
FOR PURPOSES OF ALIGNMENT. AB
TWENTY FIVE AB ONE COMPLIMENTS
THIS PROPOSAL BY REQUIRING THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A WORK GROUP
WHICH WILL FOCUS ON VERY
SERIOUS STAKEHOLDER CONCERNS
SURROUNDING ISSUES OF
ALIGNMENT. CONTRACTS AND
PROGRAM TRANSITIONED WITHOUT
DISRUPTION. THIS BILL SERVES AS
THE ONLY LEGISLATIVE VEHICLE WE
HAVE AS A LEGISLATURE TO ENGAGE
WITH THE NUANCES OF
ADMINISTRATION AND GOVERNANCE
SURROUNDING EARLY CHILDHOOD
PROGRAMS PROGRAMS WHICH HAVE
PROVEN THE RECENSION NATURE
SINCE THE START OF THE PANDEMIC.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
DEVELOP A WORK GROUP THAT WILL
SERVE THE BEST INTEREST OF OUR
CHILDREN OUR FAMILIES AND
PROVIDERS I STRONGLY URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WRASSE
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE- ALL MEMBERS GO
TO DO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE A.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES FORTY NINE NO SIX
A MEASURE PASSES. PASS AND
RETAIN AND VIOLATED MONEY SEVEN
PASS TEMPORARILY IN FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE AB TWENTY
SIX FORTY FOR THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME BILL TWENTY SIX FORTY
FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER WOULD
NATURALLY THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. THROUGH IT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
FOUR REQUIRES DURING AN
EMERGENCY SUCH AS THE ONE WE'RE
CURRENTLY IN IN A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY TO REPORT EACH
DISEASE RELATED DEATHS OF
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH WITHIN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS. IT ALSO
REQUIRES THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO MAKE THE
TOTAL NUMBER DISEASE RELATED
DEATHS AVAILABLE ON ITS
INTERNET WEBSITE ON A WEEKLY
BASIS WE NEED ACCURATE REAL
TIME DATA TO ADDRESS THE HIGH
NUMBER OF DEATHS IN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. A LITTLE
OVER HALF OF THE CODE NOT
NINETEEN GAS IN CALIFORNIA-
ATTRIBUTABLE TO EITHER A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
RESIDENTS OR STAFF. THAT'S TOO
MANY. THAT'S A LOT TOO MANY.
THE BILL IS JUST A STARTING
POINT FOR THE CONVERSATION I
WANT TO HAVE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BETTER
SUPPORT THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES THEIR STAFFS AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY. THE PATIENTS.
SO WE CAN GET THOSE WITH
ITALIAN NUMBERS DOWN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS. OF A- SMALL MEMBERS GO
TO DESERVE IT. ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL YOU
THAT I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME OF BILL
TWENTY SIX SIXTY BY SOME
REMEMBER BURKE MACULATA
TAXATION. BURKE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS INTERNATIONAL
EMPLOYEES OFTEN TRAVEL TO
CALIFORNIA ON BUSINESS FOR
SHORT PERIODS OF TIME WHICH
GIVE RISE TO PERSONAL INCOME
TAX OBLIGATIONS UNDER EXISTING
LAW. THESE BUSINESS TRAVELERS
HOWEVER ARE NOT ELIGIBLE TO
APPLY FOR SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER WHICH IS REQUIRED FOR AN
EMPLOYER TO WITHHOLD AND REMAIN
TAXES AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY
PEROT'S PROPOSES A NOVEL AND
ENTIRELY VOLUNTARY SOLUTION TO
THIS PROBLEM. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISS BURKE SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO LEARN THE-
SMALL MEMBERS GO. OUT OF THE.
MOM SAID ARE THAT. QUIRK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL YOU
THAT ICE KNOWS HERE IMAGE
PASSES WE WILL PASS OR UNIFIED
ITEM ONE NINETY FILE ITEM WHEN
THEY NEED TO A TWENTY FORTY
DECLARE WILL READ SOME OF THE
TWENTY FORTY SIX BY SOME
MEMBERS GABRIEL SNACK IN A HOME.
TO GABRIEL YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THINKING OUT SPEAKER IN PLACE
TODAY PRESENT A. B. TWO SEVEN
FORTY. A BILL THAT BRING MORE.
AND NEEDED ACCOUNT OF TRANCE.
TO HOMELESS FUNDING IN OUR
STATE. THIS ILL IS A PART OF A
PACKAGE OF HOMELESS BILLS THAT
WERE DOING ON THAT ISSUE AND
COMPLEMENTARY TO SOME OF THE
WORK BY OUR- HOUSING COMMITTEE
CHAIR ARE A CALLING FROM SAN
FRANCISCO WHO ALSO HAS. SOME
SIMILAR AND RELATED
LEGISLATION. AS THAT WE ALL
KNOW WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF A
GREAT ECONOMIC AND MORAL AND
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS WITH
HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE. ON
ANY GIVEN EVENING WE HAVE A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
WE HAVE CONTINUED AS
APPROPRIATE TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN ADDRESSING OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. BUT THERE
HAS BEEN. A SERIOUS DEFICIENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARNCY.
AROUND NOT FUNDING. WHICH HAS.
IMPAIR OUR ABILITY TO DO DATA
DRIVEN POLICY MAKING. AND SO
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IS
REQUIRE A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
NONPROFITS. OTHERS TO REPORT
KEY DATA. ON THEIR HOW THEY ARE
USING THE FUNDING THAT THEY ARE
RECEIVING AROUND HOMELESSNESS.
SO THAT WE CAN CREATE BETTER
POLICY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE CAN
BETTER SERVE THOSE. WHO ARE
SLEEPING ON OUR STREETS AND
HELP TO BRING THEM OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS SO THAT WE CAN.
PROTECT SKATE SCARCE TAXPAYER
FUNDS. AND COME UP WITH A GOOD
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM. IN
INTO DRAFTING THIS LEGISLATION
WE WORKED WITH RESEARCHERS TO
FOCUS ON WHAT THE KEY DATA IS
THAT WOULD BE NECESSARY TO DO.
BETTER POLICY MAKING. AND TO
HOPEFULLY HAVE BETTER OUTCOMES
SO THAT WE CAN SERVE THOSE WHO
ARE MOST AT NEED. THIS BILL
ENJOYS BIPARTISAN CO
AUTHORSHIP- AND IT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
MISTER KILEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I RISE IS A CO
AUTHOR THE SAD TRUTH IS THAT AS
WE SPEND BILLIONS MORE ON
HOMELESSNESS THE PROBLEM IS
ONLY CONTINUED TO GET WORSE AND
IT'S TIME WE START ASKING WHY I
THINK THIS BET BILL IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION TOWARD
THE SMARTER AND MORE
COMPASSIONATE. APPROACH TO
HOMELESSNESS AND ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER KILEY
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MR GABRIEL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONCE WE GET
THE ONE THING I'D SAY IS I'D
LIKE MANY OF YOU I I'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS- A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS WITH FOLKS IN MY
COMMUNITY. I REPRESENT A
COMMUNITY OF VERY COMPASSIONATE
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO HELP OUR
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS ON THE
STREETS. AD MANY OF THEM TO
COME UP TO ME AND SAID. I HAVE
VOTED TWICE TO TAX MYSELF IN IN
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY THROUGH.
THROUGH MEASURE H. IN THE CITY
OF. LOS ANGELES THROUGH. A
PROPOSITION HHH SAID I HAVE
VOTED TO TAX MYSELF TO GIVE
MORE MONEY TO THE GOVERNMENT
SAYING PLEASE DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS ISSUE. AND YET WHEN
I LOOK AROUND IT SEEMS LIKE
HOMELESSNESS IS GETTING WORSE.
AND SO I THINK WHAT WE NEED TO
DO IS RESPECT THOSE OF.
CONSTITUENTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
WHO ARE OUT THERE WHO WANT TO
BE PART OF THE SOLUTION. WE
WANT TO HELP AND SAY WE ARE
GOING TO WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE SPENDING YOUR HARD
EARNED MONEY. IN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE THE MOST EFFICIENT
WAY POSSIBLE SO WE CAN DO THE
MOST TO HELP THOSE ROUND THE
STREETS AND IN THAT SPIRIT. I
WOULD RESPECT AND I'VE A- THE
CLERK WILL. THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS. DESERVE A- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
WELL WHO LOW'S THEIR ROLE AND
HOW THE VOTER SIXTY NEWS HERE
THE MAN PASSES IRELAND ONE
NINETY THREE AB TWENTY HUNDRED
CLERK WILL SOME LEGAL TWENTY
HUNDRED BY SOME QUIRK OTHERS
NOT LEYVA CLIMB CHANGE MR CHOW
YOU ARE TO RESENTMENTS MATTER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SOME
PRESENT AB TWO EIGHT HUNDRED ON
BEHALF OF FOR SOME OF QUIRK. AB
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED REMOVES A
SUNSET PROVISION TO ENSURE THAT
STATE AGENCIES WILL CONTINUE TO
ACCOUNT FOR CURRENT AND FUTURE
IMPACTS CLIMATE CHANGE WHEN
PLANNING BUILDING AND INVESTING
IN STATE INFRASTRUCTURE THE
CLIMATE SAVE INFRASTRUCTURE
WORKING GROUP CREATED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SUBMITTED ITS THE
STATUTORY REQUIRED REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REPORT PROVIDED A
NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS TO
MAKE STATE INFRASTRUCTURE
RESILIENT AND SUSTAINABLE TO
WITHSTAND A WIDE RANGE OF
CLIMATE IMPACTS HOWEVER THE
WORK IS FAR FROM OVER AND IS
WHAT THAT IS WHY THE SUNSET
DATE NEEDS TO BE REMOVED. THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER. SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE FOR WILL OPEN
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. HOME VOTED TO
VERY VOTE. LONG MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW YOU VOTE
EYES FIFTY ONE KNOWS THIRTEEN
THE MEASURE PASSES. WILL PASS
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE
NINETY FOUR AND ONE NINETY FIVE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
SIX AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME LEGAL
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGULAR ANOTHER
SNACK RELATED TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY. DR
EMILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY A PRESENT ON AB TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY NINE. CALIFORNIA IS
CURRENTLY THE ONLY STATE THAT
IMPOSES SALES TAX ON BLOOD
DONOR TESTING REAGENTS
EQUIPMENT AND SUPPLIES. ONLY
TWO DONOR TESTING LABORATORIES
REMAIN OPERATIONAL IN THE STATE
THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA BLOOD
CENTER IN FRESNO AND THE
STANFORD BLOOD CENTER IN PALO
ALTO. WITH ONLY TWO DONOR
TESTING LABS FUNCTIONING IN THE
STATE THERE IS SERIOUS CONCERN
OF DELAYED ACCESS FOR NEEDED
BLOOD SUPPLY FOR TRANSFUSIONS
AND TRANSFERRING BLOOD SUPPLY
ACROSS OUR STATE LINES. AB
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE WOULD
EXEMPT SALES AND USE TAX ON
LABORATORY EQUIPMENT AND
CHEMICAL REAGENTS USED BY THE
LICENSE BLOOD BANK TO TEST
VOLUNTARILY DONATED HUMAN
BLOOD. THE EXEMPTION WILL
PROVIDE VITAL RELIEF TO THE TWO
REMAINING CENTERS THAT PERFORM
IN STATE DONOR TESTING ON BLOOD
DONATIONS HELPING THOSE LABS TO
REMAIN VIABLE. AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY NINE WILL HELP US
BENEFIT THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE US I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MASS BIGGER AB.
ARISES A JOINT AUTHOR BUT MY
FRIEND FROM FRESNO THEY GET
THAT RIGHT. MR REGULAR. ALL
RIGHT I THANK YOU FOR THIS
CENTER CALIFORNIA BLOOD BANK
AND THE OTHER THAT IS
INCORPORATED THIS BILL DO
REMARKABLE WORK THIS IS GOING
TO MAKE IT SO MUCH EASIER FOR
THEM TO DO THE GOOD WORK THAT
THEY DO ESPECIALLY- WITH
RESPECT TO THE EQUIPMENT AND
ALL THAT SO CENTER CALIFORNIA'S
PRODUCTS BUT BLOOD BANK AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE OF THIS STATE FOR
RECOGNIZING THIS NEED AND FOR
PASSING THIS IMPORTANT TAX
RELIEF. THANK YOU. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER DR EMILY WOULD YOU
LIKE CLOSE. NO CARPOOL OPEN
THEIR OWN. ALL MEMBERS VOTED A
VERITABLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY DESERVE A. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE AYE
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
SEVEN AB THIRTY FIFTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME MIDDLE
THIRTY FIFTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALY AN ACCOLADE
TO EMPLOYMENT MR DAILY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. THIS BILL
HELPS ADDRESS THE BACKLOG IN
THE PROCESSING OF WAGE CLAIMS
BY REQUIRING THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE TO
ESTABLISH AN ONLINE FILING
PORTAL. THIS IMPROVEMENT
STREAMLINES THE PROCESS BY
ALLOWING CLAIMS TO BE FILED IN
TRACK MORE QUICKLY. THE LA
ALWAYS POINTED OUT PROBLEMS IN
THIS AREA AND I THINK THIS IS
ONE STEP TOWARD A SOLVING THAT
PROBLEM. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
DALY SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OF THE- ALL MEMBERS GO
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE AYE
SIXTY WHO KNOWS HERE THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY EIGHT AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR BY SOME MEMORY IS ANOTHER
SNACK LATEST SOCIAL SERVICES
MITHRAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM. NUMBERS I AM
PRESENTING AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR. AB WHICH EXTENDS REFUGEE
CASH ASSISTANCE OR ARE. PROGRAM
WOULD NINETEEN IS SHED LIGHT ON
THE NEED TO ENSURE. THIS
POPULATION RECEIVE SUPPORT FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR WILL
CODIFY CALIFORNIA MATCH TO THE
FEDERAL ARE CA PROGRAM. THIS
BILL HAS HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO OPPOSITION. IT IS WITH
THESE REFUGEES LIVELIHOOD IN
MIND THAT I URGE AND I VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS RAY
S. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. PAUL
MEMBERS VOTED ART OF THE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I FIFTY NINE NEWS HERE
THE MEASURE PASSES PATH TO
RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS ONE
NINETY NINE AND TWO HUNDRED.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS.
TO ONE. MOVING A FILE ITEM TO A
TO A B THIRTY TO SIXTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME AGO
THIRTY TO SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU
ANOTHER SNACK LATER
HOMELESSNESS. MISTER DAVID CHIU
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER. LET ME FIRST
THANK MEMBERS OF THIS BODY WHO
HAVE BEEN LEADING. IN SO MANY
YEARS WHEN IT COMES TO
HOMELESSNESS AND WORKING
TOGETHER. TO MAKE SURE THAT
DESPITE THE PANDEMIC AND ALL
THE THINGS ARE HAPPENING THIS
YEAR WE ARE MOVING FORWARD AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN. THIS BILL
WOULD ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
ACCOUNTABILITY. WE ALL KNOW HOW
DIRE THE CRISIS IS BàN WHAT
WAS IN PLACE BEFORECORONAVIRUS
IN THE FACT THAT WITH THE
PANDEMIC. HONEST ARE PREDICTING
A 20% INCREASE IN THESE NUMBERS
IF WE DON'T HOUSE PEOPLE. WE
WILL INTENSIFY VIRUS SPREAD.
THIS IS A BILL THAT CAME OUT A
TWO CONVERSATIONS FIRST THE
GOVERNOR'S COUNCIL ON REGIONAL
HOMELESS ADVISERS RECOMMENDED
THAT OUR STATE ESTABLISH. AND
ENFORCEABLE RESULT BASED
ACCOUNTABILITY MANDATE TO AND
HOMELESSNESS. SECOND THERE BEEN
NUMEROUS LAWSUITS BROUGHT BY
THE BROUGHT AGAINST CITIES AND
COUNTIES AROUND THE STATE WHO
FAILED TO HOUSE ARE ON
SHELTERED. LEGAL PROCEEDINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN COMPLEX AND TIME
CONSUMING FOR ALL PARTIES. THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE A PROCESS FOR
HOLDING STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE. FOR
DRESSING HOMELESSNESS BASED ON
MEASURABLE GOALS IN EXISTING
RESOURCES HOPEFULLY AVOIDING
THE NEED FOR EXPENSIVE
LITIGATION. THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE A GAPS NEEDS ANALYSIS
FOR ALL LOCAL AND STATE
AGENCIES INVOLVED. AS WELL AS
ESTABLISH A HOMELESSNESS
INSPECTOR GENERAL POSITION THE
WHOLE LOCAL AND STATE AGENCIES
ACCOUNTABLE. BY DOING THAT THIS
BILL WILL HOPEFULLY MOVE
CALIFORNIA TOWARD FINALLY
ADDRESSING THE MORAL CRISIS OF
OUR DAY WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- SEEING
HEARING NO FOR THAT. THIS SO
WERE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE AGAIN
TODAY FOR THE FOURTH TIME TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND
TO SUPPORT A HOUSING FOR OUR
HOMELESS. AS WE KNOW OUR
HOUSING NUMBERS HAVE DROPPED
AND ARE HOMELESS NUMBERS HAVE
INCREASED. AND WITH PRODUCTION
GOING AT A SNAIL'S PACE WE CAN
ASSUME THAT NOT ONLY DURING THE
COVERT BUT AFTER THE CO THAT
ARE NOT OUR HOUSING OR ARE
HOMELESS THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WILL INCREASE.
THIS PLAN AND THIS BILL SAYS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WORK ON AN
ACTIONABLE PLAN IT SAYS CREATE
A PLAN THAT YOU WILL BE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR WORKING WITH
THE STATE AND THIS MY FRIENDS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO DO
ALL TOO OFTEN. WE HAVE SOME
LOCAL ELECTED WHO SAY THEY JUST
CAN'T DO ANYTHING WE ALL HAVE
TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
OUR CITIES AND THAT MEANS
TAKING RESPONSIBILITY SO ARE
YOU SUPPORT AB THIRTY TO SIXTY
NINE AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER TO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK ARE CALLING FROM
ORANGE COUNTY A BILL FOR YOUR
WORK IN THIS AREA AND FOR YOUR
MORAL AUTHORITY ON THIS TOPIC.
AND YOU ALSO KNOW THAT THIS
BILL IN PART CAME OUT OF SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES AND
EXPERIENCES THAT WE SAW IN
TRYING TO TACKLE A HOMELESS AS
AN ORANGE COUNTY- WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND ONE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VERY VOTE. HOME VOTED START OF
A- ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE. WORK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALITHA AYE AYES FORTY
NINE KNOWS FIVE THE MEASURE
PASSES WE ARE MOVING BACK UP IN
FILE ORDER FILE ITEM TWO ONE
TWO ZERO ONE AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME PEOPLE THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR BONTA
NATURALLY INTO DETENTION
FACILITIES. BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT
PROVIDES ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT AND FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE IMMIGRATION DETENTION
FACILITIES IN OUR STATE. THIS
BILL DOES THIS BY REQUIRING
PRIVATE OPERATORS TO ADHERE TO
THE MINIMUM STANDARDS THEY
AGREED TO IN THEIR OPERATIONS
CONTRACTS AND PROVIDES FOR A
LEGAL MECHANISM PROVIDE. IS OF
THE STATE. BUT IT. STILL IS IN
CALIFORNIA UP OPERATE UNDER IS.
INSPECTION REGIME. THEY ARE
LARGE. BEING HELD UNDER TODAY I
LIMóN DO NOW IS THIS TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE TO. THAT OPEN AND IN
OUR AND HERE TO HIGH STANDARDS
PARTICULARLY AT SUCH A CRITICAL
TIME FOR PUBLIC SAFETY. THANK
YOU MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
BONTA. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE A. WHERE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY VOTE ICE FIFTY
ONE KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. LINK TO- WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY IN FILE ITEM TWO OH
THREE WILL PASS RETAIN FILE AND
TO- FOR FILE ITEM TWO OH FIVE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME OF THE
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX BY SOME
REMEMBER AG ACKLEY. HEALTH IF
AND WHEN YOU ARE A- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RUN SPEAKER HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WHICH
UPDATED EXPAND SOME ASPECTS OF
LAURA'S LAW. IT'S ALSO KNOWN AS
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
LARA'S LAWS AN EVIDENCE BASED
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE FRIEDMAN TO THOSE WHO
MAY NOT OTHERWISE BE UNABLE TO
ACCESS COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH.
DUE TO THEIR SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A- T.
STATEWIDE WHILE STILL PROVIDING
COUNTIES THE FLEXIBILITY TO OPT
OUT TO A RESOLUTION BY THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. THIS BILL
ALSO ENSURES THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A- T.
SERVICES WILL NOT REDUCE ANY
VOLUNTARY MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS FOR CHILDREN AND
ADULTS WITH IN PARTICIPATING
COUNTIES. AFTER EIGHTEEN YEARS
OF CONTINUED IMPLEMENTATION I
FEEL AT THIS DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL SO
THIS BILL ALSO RECRUIT BLOOM
REPEAL THE SUNSET DATE. IN THE
LOS STILL REQUIRES REGULAR
REPORTING. I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE THAT THIS IS A UNIQUE
MOMENT FOR US TO BE CRAFTING
PUBLIC POLICY DURING THE
HOUSING CRISIS A PANDEMIC ON
REST RELATED TO POLICE
BRUTALITY AND WE'RE ALL
THINKING ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE CHANGES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES SO THAT WE ARE
BETTER SITUATED TO DEAL WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. I KNOW
THAT IN SOME LAST MINUTE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL BUT
MEMBERS IS THE EXACT KIND OF
THING THAT WE WANT TO PUT.
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES OF CARE
ISSUES INTO THE HANDS OF
PROFESSIONALS AND SO THEY ARE
NOT IN AND OUT INTERACTING WITH
THE POLICE AND IN AND OUT OF
HOSPITALS THAT'S WHY THIS BILL
IS SUPPORTED BY HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS. HELP YES BECAUSE
THE CAL SITE SO IN THE
CALIFORNIA MAN SO. AND THE
CALIFORNIA. PATIENT ALSO THIS
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU FOR
AN. AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WITH
EGGMAN DOT WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE AS A OF AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX LARA LAW
WAS ENACTED EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO
AN EXTENDED THROUGH SUNSETS
IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT PERMANENT-
FOR THOSE COUNTIES HAVE ADOPTED
A O. T. PROGRAMS HAS WORKED
VERY WELL. AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX ALLOWS MULTIPLE COUNTIES TO
JOIN TOGETHER TO PROVIDE ANY-
T. PROGRAM IN SMALLER MORE
RURAL AREAS LIKE MY DISTRICT NO
ONE COUNTY MAY HAVE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
ADEQUATELY AND APPROPRIATELY
PROVIDE THESE SERVICES. THAT'S
THE ABILITY TO JOIN TOGETHER
AND FOR THE PURPOSES OF
PROVIDING AOTI MAY MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN NOT OFFERING
THE SERVICES AT ALL AND BEING
ABLE TO OFFER THIS A VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE TO THOSE IN NEED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE ABOUT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD. SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ADAM DR EGGMAN YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER SPEAKER THIS PROVIDES US
MEMBERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
PEOPLE WHO NEED HELP IN TO
HELP. AND TO NOT HAVE TO HAVE
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS OUT
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THESE
ISSUES ON THE STREET. DURING
TIMES OF CRISIS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN WITH THAT
QUIRK LIBERAL. IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE ABOUT.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE FILE.
FOR MISS CERVANTES TO TAKE UP.
ITEM SIXTY ONE THIS IS AB.
TWENTY EIGHT OH EIGHT FILE ITEM
SIXTY ONE AB TWENTY EIGHT AWAIT
CORKERY SUMMER BILL TWENTY
EIGHT AWAIT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CERVANTES ANOTHER'S IMMACULATA
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE THIS
SERVICE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHT TODAY AB TWENTY- A
PROVIDES A BALANCED APPROACH
THAT WILL ALLOW FOR THE
CRIMINAL CASE AGAINST AN
ASSAILANT TO BE DISMISSED SO
THEY CAN SEEK REHABILITATION
OPTIONS LIKE APPLYING FOR JOBS
WHILE STILL PROVIDING THE
SURVIVORS WITH THE PROTECTIONS
THAT THEY BOTH NEED AND
DESERVE. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BI PARTISAN SUPPORT AND
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN THE
SOMEWHAT PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE ABOUT. DAVIS
MOUNTAINS SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM QUIRK OVER
THERE ALL. ALL MEMBERS OF A
RESERVE A. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF A CAR WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES WELL MISTER
BONTA SAYS IN THE WELL LET'S
TAKE UP FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN MEMBERS
THIS IS AB. TWENTY SIX OH SIX
CORPORATION SOME AGO TWENTY SIX
OH SIX BY SOME MEMBER CERVANTES
NOT RELATE TO CRIMINAL. THE
SERVER THIS THANK YOU MISTER
AND I FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLYBILL TWENTY
SIX OH SIX TODAY WHICH PROVIDES
OUR STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WITH UP TO DATE AND ACCURATE
INFORMATION REGARDING
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE UNDER POST
CONVICTION SUPERVISION BY THE
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENTS IT
WILL DO THIS BY EXTENDING- IN
EXISTING TEN DAY REPORTING
REQUIREMENT IMPOSED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS TO COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS THIS INFORMATION
WILL BE ENTERED INTO AN
EXISTING STATEWIDE DATABASE
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THIS LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. AMOS BY SEE DISCUSS OR TO
ON ITEM QUICKLY. ALMOST OF.
THIS THAT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT AYE SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES AND NOW WILL TAKE UP
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY THREE.
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY THREE AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY CORPORATE
SOME OF BILL TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY BY SIMPLY MEMBERS OF
ARTISTS NOT RELATE TO EMERGENCY
SERVICES THIS CERVANTES THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ARE FOR ALLOW ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY TODAY. WHEN DISASTER
STRIKES OUR STATE MEMBERS OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
ARE OFTEN UNABLE TO EVACUATE OR
SEEK SHELTER PEOPLE IN THESE
COMMUNITIES OFTEN LACK THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
OWN TRANSPORTATION ARE MY ALSO
HAVE DIFFICULTY ACCESSING
CONVENTIONAL PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. WE CANNOT
ACCEPT THAT SOME PEOPLE MIGHT
BE LEFT BEHIND IN EMERGENCIES
BECAUSE THEY ARE UNABLE TO
EVACUATE THEMSELVES TO MINIMIZE
THE RISK AND THE POTENTIAL LOSS
OF LIFE IT IS CRITICAL THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WORK
TOGETHER. TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE READY TO COORDINATE
RESOURCES DURING A DISASTER YOU
BACK. THIS BILL WILL HELP
ACCOMPLISH THIS BY REQUIRING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND AGENCIES
TO WORK TOGETHER UPON REQUEST
OF ONE LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR
AGENCY TO SURE LOGISTICAL
RESOURCES SUCH AS PARA TRANSIT
VEHICLES DRIVERS AND MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT. WE THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT WHEN THE DISASTER
NATURAL DISASTER PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY STRIDES CALIFORNIA NO
ONE GETS LEFT BEHIND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THINGS RUN THIS NO SEEKING
WHERE CLUB. THAT VITAL MEMBERS
VOTERS AT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS TO VOTE. CLICK WELL
CULTURAL TIES BUT I SIXTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. A
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO WITHOUT
OBJECTION ALLOW THE ASSISTANT
SPEAKER PRO TEM TO TAKE UP HER
ITEMS. THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE
EIGHTY TWO. FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY TWO AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE OPERATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
BAUER-KAHAN AN ACCOLADE COUNTY
JAILS. MISS BARRICADE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
THREE WILL REQUIRE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S COMPILING SUBMIT DATA
ON THE RECEIPT IF THEY DIDN'T
PROGRAMS OFFERED IN COUNTY
JAILS AND THE PROGRAM'S SUCCESS
RATES IN REDUCING RECIDIVISM.
EACH YEAR SINCE REALIGNMENT WAS
ENACTED APPROPRIATIONS IN THE
STATE BUDGET HAVE PROVIDED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
COUNTIES LAMENT DIVERSE
APPROACHES TO SUPERVISION AND
REHABILITATION WITH THE AIM OF
REDUCING RESEARCH THEM WE HAVE
NO IDEA HOW THESE PROGRAMS ARE
WORKING AND YET WE CONTINUE
APPROPRIATE THIS MONEY WE NEED.
BETTER WE ARE ANXIOUS AND WHAT
OUR RETURN ON IT AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE WILL US TO IN
SUPPORT THEM PUBLIC SAFETY
SHRINK THE SIZE BEEN CURSED
APART. AND REDUCE CORRECTION
COSTS WELL THE SAME TIME CREE
BATTER BETTER OUTCOMES FOR THE
FOUR BILLION. AND BLACK TO
CONCENTRATE MAINLY STRETCH BY
ON WE A PROVEN TRACK. OUR ASK
YOUR. MISTER COOPER YOUR- THIS
I SINCE FOR MY CALL AND THE WHO
ARE MO FOLKS DON'T WITH JUST A
PER THE DAY. THEY GO TO COUNTY
JAIL AS SAID THEY HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT WAS. RATE WE ALSO FOR
DEEPER MAYBE 60% LOT OF. I
THERE THE FIFTH ACCOUNT. IN
THIS COUNTY IS CREATED THERE
SOME PRO. THERE'S SOME HORRIBLE
PROGRAM WE GOT TO BEST IF WE
CHOI WILL LOWER FITNESS. RATE
OF GOT TAKE A LOOK AT THE- IS
AMAZING THIS BEEN GOING ON.
SINCE REALIZED THAT'S WHAT TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TEN. IN NO
ONE THERE TAKE DEEP DIE TO SEE
WHAT THE NUMBERS ARE. AND YOU
THINK ABOUT IT EVERY COUNTY
JAILS FOR A YEAR ARE YOU
LESSONS. WE FOLKS AND TO FOR
YEARS COUNTY JAIL. SYMBOLS FOR
ARE GONNA US A REAL. SO I WANT
TO COMMEND YOU FOR BRING A UP
BY HER SUPPORT. THANK YOU
COOPER. NO ADDITIONAL DISK OR
THE AS OUR QUE HAN BOTH THANK
YOU I TRY I THINK MY AND FOR
HIS SUPPORT AND RESPECT YOUR
EYES. THE CLUB LOW. CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
SIXTY DOES ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. AND NOW MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP. WE. FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHT. FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX
CORPORATE SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SIX BY SOME MEMBER
OF BAUER-KAHAN AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO DISTANCE LEARNING
THIS BACK A HAND THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX WHICH
WORKS TO ADDRESS THE INEQUITIES
IN OUR SCHOOLS AND AMONG
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS WHEN IT
COMES TO BRIDGING THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. THE KOBE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGED THE LANDSCAPE OF
EDUCATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE NATION ALMOST
OVERNIGHT SCHOOLS WERE CLOSED
IN CHILDREN WERE SENT HOME TO
LEARN REMOTELY BUT THERE ARE
FEW RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR
STUDENTS WHO DON'T ON A LAPTOP
OR OF ACCESS TO THE INTERNET
OUR SCHOOLS HAVE HAD TO SPEND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TRYING TO
BRIDGE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
DOLLARS THEY DO NOT HAVE WE
NEED TO ADDRESS THIS AND THIS
WITH POLICY SOLUTIONS THE
BRIDGE THE DIVIDE AND IDENTIFY
WAYS TO PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH
THE EQUIPMENT AND TECHNOLOGY.
AND GIVE THE SCHOOLS THE MUCH
NEEDED RELIEF THEY NEED WITH
THAT THE BILL HAS NO NO VOTES
IN THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN AN
APPROPRIATION REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU WAS VERY
HANDS SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE- CAR CLUB
GIRL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIGN OF THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE AYES SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS OF THE CHANGES. OF
THANK. MEMBERS WE CAN TAKE VOTE
CHANGES AT THIS TIME. MR
MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
EIGHT AB THIRTY ONE OH SEVEN
YES TO NOW. BURKE CHANGED
MAIENSCHEIN ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE OH SEVEN I TO KNOW.
MS RAY S. VOTE CHANGE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE HI TO ALL. RAY IS
SYMBOL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE I
TO NOT VOTING. THIS FRIEDMAN.
ACA TWENTY FIVE I TO NOT VOTING.
FRIEDMAN ASSEMBLY
CONSTITUTIONAL MOMENT TWENTY
FIVE I TO NOT LOADING. MAYES
AGUIAR-CURRY THE SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO ALRIGHT ENOUGH VOTING.
AGUIAR-CURRY SOME WIGGLE TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO I TO NOT
VOTING. MR DAILY. A. B. TWO TWO
EIGHT ZERO FROM ALL RIGHT TO
KNOW. DALY ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY TO KNOW THANK YOU.
MR BONTA. CHANGE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY ONE AB TWENTY EIGHT ZERO
EIGHT I TO NOT VOTING. BONTA
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY EIGHT OH
EIGHT TO NOT VOTING. MR GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY I
TO NOT VOTING. GRAYSON SOME
LEGAL TWENTY TWO EIGHTY I TO
NOT VOTING. MISTER PATTERSON
WELL NUMBER ONE SIXTY AB ONE
EIGHT THREE SEVEN FROM NO I.
PATTERSON ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN THIRTY SEVEN NO TO I'D.
MR LACKEY. AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY TWO NOT A HIGH. LACKEY
SO WE WILL TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
TWO NO TO A HIGH. MISTER
GLORIA. BIGGEST SPEAKER THE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
SIXTEEN FROM I TO NOT VOTING.
GLORIA ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
SIXTEEN I TO NOT VOTING. NUMBER.
AND. I SOME OF THE OLD ONE
ALONG WITH. THE APPARATUS BUT-
BUT I'M SCREENING. YEAH. OKAY
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON THE FILE.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP MS THE
MOANS MEASURE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY TWO. FIVE OUT OF
ONE FIFTY TWO. AB THIRTY TWO
FOURTEEN COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE MOMENT ACCOLADES OIL
AND GAS. IS A LONG THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB THIRTY TWO
FOURTEEN INCREASES THE CRIMINAL
PENALTIES FOR OIL SPILLS AND
THE CERTIFICATE OF FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY TANK AND NON
TANK VESSELS MUST CARRY IN
STATE WATERS CRIMINAL PENALTIES
FOR OIL SPILLS. HAVE BEEN
UPDATED HAVEN'T BEEN UPDATED
SINCE THE NINETEEN NINETIES AND
MAJOR OIL SPILLS CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN ACROSS CALIFORNIA IT IS
THE CENTRAL TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE MEANINGFUL DETERRENCE FOR
ESPECIALLY BAD ACTORS. SECONDLY
THIS BILL DOUBLE THE
CERTIFICATION OF FINANCE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR TANK AND NON
VESSEL TANKS REQUIRED TO KERRY
THE INSURANCE FOR HOME
INSURANCE THESE VESSELS HAVE
ADEQUATE FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO
PAY FOR CLEANUP AND DAMAGE COST
OF AN EVENTUAL SPILL. THESE
AMOUNTS HAVE ALSO NOT BEEN
RAISED IN THE LAST
1-922-221-9220 YEARS I'M
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
OPPOSITION TO IDENTIFY OPTIONS
TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
ESPECIALLY REGARDING THE
AVAILABILITY AVAILABILITY OR
LACK THERE OF INSURANCE I'M
COMMITTED TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION TO FIND. A WORKABLE
SOLUTION TO READ DIFFERENT IS A
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
ITEM. THANK YOU MS AMONG.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. QUIRK LIBERAL ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL
MEMBERS HER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY TWO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THERE IS WHERE
TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR MISS
WICKS. THIS IS A. B. TWENTY
NINE THIRTY SIX. COREY ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY NINE THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AN
ACCOLADE TO CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON THAT ITEM.
THAT BILL LORRAINE ON CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHT. THIS
IS A CA FIVE DOCTOR WEBER.
CALGARY WELL SEMI
CONSTITUTIONAL MOMENT FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER ANOTHER
CYNICAL IN THE GOVERNMENT
PREFERENCES. DOCTOR WEBER YOU
MAIL. MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
TO YOU A CA FIVE THE CALIFORNIA
ACT ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AND
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL THIS
MEASURES SEEK TO ALLOW
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORT TO TAKE
MEANINGFUL STEPS TO MINIMIZE
INEQUALITY PREVENT
DISCRIMINATION AND PROMOTE
ECONOMIC FAIRNESS. ACA FIVE
WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA VOTERS
TO RESTORE THE CONSIDERATION OF
RACE AND GENDER DIVERSITY AND
PUBLIC CONTRACTING PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND PUBLIC EDUCATION
IN ORDER TO CREATE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY. THE DAY WE ARE AS
WE LOOK AROUND THE WORLD AND WE
SEE HOW THERE IS AN URGENT
CRIME. AN URGENT CRY FOR
SYSTEMIC CHANGE. THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC AS WELL AS RECENT
TRAGEDIES OF POLICE VIOLENCE IS
FORCING CALIFORNIA'S TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE DEEP SEATED
INEQUALITY AND FAR REACHING
INSTITUTIONAL FAILURES. THAT
SHOW THAT YOUR OF RACE AND
GENDER STILL MATTERS. AND AT
LEAST PEOPLE WOULD DRAMATICALLY
DIFFERENT RESULTS DEPENDING ON
THE COMBINATION OF THE TWO IN
YOUR LIFE. THE VIRUS IN ITSELF.
DID NOT DISCRIMINATE AND YET WE
SEE THE DISPROPORTION ELEGY OF
HIGH IN TERMS OF HIGH INFECTION
DEATH RATES AMONG AFRICAN
AMERICANS LATINOS NATIVE
AMERICANS AND FILIPINOS. WE SEE
RECORD JOB LOSS CONCENTRATED IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND THE
SHATTERING OF WOMEN AND
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE STATE. AFTER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OF QUANTITATIVE AND
QUALITATIVE DATA. WE CAN SEE
THAT RACE NEUTRAL SOLUTIONS
COULD NOT FIX PROBLEMS STEEPED
IN RACE. CALIFORNIA'S
REGRESSIVE BAN ON EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS SUCH AS
AFFIRMATIVE SUCH AS AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION DENIES WOMEN AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
IN THE WORKPLACE AND IN
EDUCATION. OPPOSITION TO ALL
NINE PASSED IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX SIEMENS THE GLASS CEILING
FOR WOMEN IN BUSINESS AND
STIFLES EFFORTS TO GET YOUNG
WOMEN TO PURSUE STEM MAJORS. IT
DIVERT IT DIVERTS OVER IT IS
DIVERTED OVER ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS OF INVESTMENT
EACH YEAR FOR WOMEN AND BLACK
AND BROWN OWN BUSINESSES.
UNRAVELING THE YEARS OF GROWTH
AND ADVANCEMENT FOR THAT FOR
THESE ENTREPRENEURS. THE BAN ON
RACE CONSCIOUS AND GENDER
CONSCIOUS REMEDIES DO NOT ALLOW
FOR US TO DEAL WITH THE ROOT
CAUSES OF SYSTEMIC FAILURES AND
IT PREVENTS US FROM DESIGNING
EFFECTIVE POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS. TO CORRECT A ONGOING
HISTORY OF BIAS AND EXCLUSION.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA'S OUT OF
STEP WITH FORTY TWO OF THE
STATE'S BEING ONLY ONE IN EIGHT
STATES WITH THIS BAND. FOR
THOSE WHO DON'T WANT TO
PARTICIPATE. I DO NOT HAVE TO
HAVE TO TAKE UP THE MANTLE IN
ACT TOWARD RACIAL AND GENDER
EQUALITY. THE REMOVAL TOOL NINE
WOULD NOT BURDEN YOU BECAUSE IT
IT IS PERMISSIVE AND NOT
PRESCRIPTIVE. AND DOES NOT
MANDATE ANYTHING. WHAT THE
LEADERS WHO WANT TO HELP REMEDY
GENDER BIAS AND DISPARITIES.
PROPOSITION TWO HAD NINE IS ALL
HAS ONLY SERVED AS AN
IMPEDIMENT TO ACT ON BEST
PRACTICES ALIGNED WITH THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION. ACA
FIVE WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA
VOTERS TO RE VISIT AND EXPRESS
THEIR VIEWS AFTER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS. BOTH THE NEW GENERATION
WHO ARE CALLING FOR CHANGE AND
THOSE WHO RECALL THE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS AND
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FOR
BEFORE AND AFTER PROP TWO NINE
WOULD WAS IN EFFECT. ACA IS A
PRIORITY BILL OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
ISN'T BOARD BACK DOORS BY THE
JEWISH CAUCUS IN THE LGBT
CAUCUS AND PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS.
IT IS IT IS SPONSORED TODAY BY
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND INDIVIDUALS IN
SUPPORT. MEMBERS WITH THE WORLD
WATCHED IN MINNEAPOLIS THE
SYMPTOMS OF A MUCH LARGER
PROBLEM. AND THAT WAS EQUALLY
DISTURBED AS US OFFICE WHO HAD
HIS KNEE ON ON GEORGE FLOOR
FLOOR ITS NECK. WAS OFFICER WHO
STE AND AS WELL AS THE OFFICE
WHO STOOD BY AND WERE COMPLICIT
AND ALLOWED IT TO HAPPEN. EVEN
BLOCKING STAND BUYERS FROM
HELPING. TODAY I ASK THIS
LEGISLATURE. I HOPE IT IS
LEGISLATURE WOULD NO LONGER BE
COMPLICIT IN THE STATUS QUO.
THAT WILL NOT IDLY SIT BACK AND
REST IN GENDER WITH GENDER AND
RACIAL INEQUALITY. AND FURTHER
THAT AT THE VERY LEAST WE WOULD
BE WE WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA
VOTERS. TO MAY HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD ABOUT THE LACK OF
OPPORTUNITY THE UNJUST AND
UNFAIR SYSTEM AT AND WHETHER
NOT THEY WANT TO UPHOLD
PROPOSITION TOOL NINE. FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON A CA
FIVE. FIGURED WEBER THIS RACE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF A CA FIVE.
CALIFORNIA'S INCREDIBLE
ACHIEVEMENTS IT'S A BEACON OF
HOPE AND NEW BEGINNINGS WOULD
NOT BE POSSIBLE WITHOUT TO
DIVERSE CITY. WITHOUT OUR
DIVERSITY WE CANNOT CELEBRATE
THE DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE
WITHOUT ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
MINORITY GROUPS FACE
DISCRIMINATION AND DISPARITIES
STEMMING FROM INSTITUTIONAL AND
SYSTEMIC CHALLENGES.
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE BEEN
HIT THE HARDEST BY THE CORONA
VIRUS PANDEMIC WITH BOTH THE
ECONOMIC AND HEALTH IMPACTS. AS
THESE COMMUNITIES MOURN HIGHER
RATES OF KOBE INFECTIONS AND
DEATHS THEY ALSO HAVE TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY NAVIGATE HIGHER
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES. IT IS CLEAR
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE AN EQUAL
PLAYING FIELD. BY ALLOWING
CALIFORNIA VOTERS TO REMOVE THE
BAN ON AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AND
ALLOW DENTRE GENDER RACIAL AND
ETHNIC DIVERSITY TO BE
CONSIDERED AS ONE OF THE
FACTORS IN PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT IN
PUBLIC EDUCATION. IF WE DO THAT
WE WORK TOWARDS EQUITY. EQUITY
IS NOT GIVING EVERYBODY THE
SAME RESOURCES IT IS GIVING
EACH PERSON THE APPROPRIATERESOURCES AND OPPORTUNITIES
THEY NEED TO SUCCEED. EQUITY IS
LEVELING THE PLAYING FIELD SO
THAT NO ONE GROUP HAS A HIGHER
RATE OF POVERTY. AND OTHER
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES. UNTIL WE
ACHIEVE EQUITY WE CANNOT TRULY
CELEBRATE THE MANY FACES THAT
MAKE CALIFORNIA EXCEPTIONAL FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
URGE AND I VOTE. THANK YOU MS
REYES IS GOOD SALAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I RISE TODAY AS THE
CHAIRWOMAN OF THE LATINO CAUCUS
IN SUPPORT OF REPEALING PROP
TWO OH NINE WE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORTIVE AND OUR
DESIRE TO HAVE THIS PROPOSITION
REPEALS AND THE REASON IS QUITE
SIMPLE IF YOU LOOK AROUND OUR
CAUCUS WE KNEW THAT A VAST
MAJORITY EXCEPT FOR THERE ARE
VERY YOUNG ENDS. WE ALL
BENEFITED FROM AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION. WE KNEW THAT. IN FACT
EVERYBODY ON THIS FLOOR WHO IS
A WOMAN. A PERSON OF COLOR A
NATIVE AMERICAN AND LATINO AND
AFRICAN AMERICAN OF FILIPINO.
IN IS OVER THE AGE OF FORTY.
BENEFITTED FROM THIS PROGRAM
WEATHER WAS YOUR OWN PERSONAL
STORY LIKE MINE HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND STANFORD
UNIVERSITY I WAS JUST SOMEBODY
WHO HAD NEVER SET FOOT ON A
COLLEGE CAMPUS COMING FROM A
FAMILY WHO HAD NEVER DREAMED.
THAT THEIR CHILDREN COULD GO ON
TO A SCHOOL LIKE THAT. AND IF
IT WEREN'T FOR THE ABILITY TO
HAVE A SECOND LOOK BECAUSE
DIVERSITY MATTERED. BECAUSE MY
STORY MATTER TO THE ADMISSIONS
OFFICER I WOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN
ABLE TO ATTEND STANFORD TO GO
ON TO PROVE MYSELF AT
GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY AND
EVENTUALLY. GOING TO A FULL
RIDE SCHOLARSHIP AT UCLA LAW
SCHOOL. WHEN I WAS AT THAT
SCHOOL LAW SCHOOL AT MY FIRST
YEAR. THEY REPEAL PROP TWO OH
NINE AND I ALSO SAW WHAT
HAPPENED. TO THE NEXT
GENERATION OF LOS STUDENTS TO
NEXT YEAR OF OS STUDENTS. AND
WE SAW A CLASS GO FROM BEING
INCREDIBLY DIVERSE. COMPLETELY
QUALIFIED. REALLY ROBUST IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS TO ONE THAT LACKED
ALMOST A SINGLE BLACK OR LATINO
STUDENT. IT WAS DEVASTATING NOT
JUST TO THE STUDENTS WHO MAYBE
DIDN'T HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY
BUT DEVASTATING TO THE ENTIRE
STUDENT BODY THAT DIDN'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO LEARN FROM EACH
OTHER. SYSTEMATIC RACISM DIDN'T
STOP BECAUSE OF TWO OH NINE.
PEOPLE DON'T STOP BEING.
PREJUDICED THEY DIDN'T STOP
TREATING CHILDREN DIFFERENTLY
WHO CAME FROM OFTEN POOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. TEACHERS
DIDN'T FAMILY THINK THAT YOU
HAD THE SAME ABILITIES AS MAYBE
YOUR UPPER MIDDLE CLASS WHITE
SCHOOL MATE YOU CAN CERTAINLY
GET EXPECTED TO GO INTO HONORS
CLASSES INTO YOUR BEST BECAUSE
PROP TO AND I WAS PULLED BACK.
WE CAN'T CREATE COLOR BLINDNESS.
IT DOESN'T EXIST. AND SO WHAT
WE'VE SEEN OVER THESE
GENERATIONS IS A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY OF SO MANY KIDS. IN
OUR COMMUNITIES WHO HAVEN'T HAD
THE BENEFIT THAT WE ALL HAVE AT.
AND AS A RESULT.WE'RE SEEN.
EVEN INCREASE SYSTEMATIC
RACISM. WHEN PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND HAVE THIS DIVERSITY.
EVEN IF YOU'RE WHITE THAT HURTS
YOU TO. IT HURTS THE ENTIRE
PROCESS AND GETS US INTO A
SITUATION QUITE FRANKLY LIKE
WE'RE IN TODAY. I'VE BEEN A-
REALLY FLABBERGASTED BY
EVERYTHING GOING ON I THINK
LIKE WE ALL ARE AND WATCHING
THE FRUSTRATION ESPECIALLY OF
YOUNG PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR REALLY JUST REACHING
OUT TO TRY TO CHANGE THINGS
RIGHT NOW TAKING TO THE
STREETS. AND WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THEM CHANGE
THINGS HERE TO CORRECT A
MISGUIDED SET WE THOUGHT BY
REPEALING ARE ONE FORM OF
EQUITY WHAT WOULD PUT US IN A
BETTER SPOT AND IT HASN'T SO
WE'RE ASKING TO GIVE
OPPORTUNITY EVERYBODY TO ONCE
AGAIN OPEN IT BACK UP. TO
ALLOWS AN OPPORTUNITY. WHETHER
YOU'RE A WOMAN A PERSON OF
COLOR. AN UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITY TO HAVE THAT TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT AS ONE OF MANY
FACTORS WHEN YOU'RE QUALIFY
OTHERWISE QUALIFIED TO GET A
GOVERNMENT CONTRACT OR TO GET
INTO A SCHOOL. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO US. AND OUR LATINO CAUCUS IS
PROUD TO STAND SHOULDER TO
SHOULDER WITH OUR BLACK CAUCUS
IN ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE ON A
CA FIVE. THANK YOU MS
CONSULTANTS GRAYSON YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND CALLING SITE RISES
WELL SUPPORT OF ACA FIVE. IT
DOES NOT TAKE MUCH TO LOOK AT
CURRENT EVENTS AND SEE WHERE
THE NATION IS. THIS IS A NATION
THAT IS GRAPPLING WITH ITS
IMPRESSIVE PAST AND LINGERING
AFFECTS. THE KILLINGS OF GEORGE
FLOYD BRIANNA TAYLOR. AND FAR
TOO MANY MORE HAVE SHOWN. THAT
WE MUST DO MORE TO LIVE UP TO
OUR NATION'S PROMISE OF LIBERTY
AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. I BRING
THIS UP IN THE CONTEXT OF A CA
FIVE. BECAUSE SYSTEMIC RACISM
IS INTERCONNECTED. THE SAME
SYSTEM THAT HAVE ALLOWED FOR
DISPROPORTIONATE POLICING OF
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE ALSO
ALLOWED FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND WOMEN. TO BE LOCKED
OUT OF EDUCATIONAL AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES. AS A AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY. WE SHOULD BE
COMMITTED TO ENSURING EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY. THAT IS LONG LONG
OVERDUE. AND I AM PROUD TO
SUPPORT ACA FIVE A MEASURE THAT
TAKES. A STEP CLOSER TO.
ACHIEVE A FAIR AND JUST
CALIFORNIA. BY PASSING A SIXTY
FIVE WE CAN SEND A CLEAR
MESSAGE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
COMMITTED TO UNDOING DECADES OF
EDUCATIONAL AND ECONOMIC HARM
TO WOMEN. THAT COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. THIS PROVIDES IMMEDIATE
SUPPORT TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES BY INCREASING
PUBLIC. IN A PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND ACCESS TO
QUALITY EDUCATION THAT YOU SEE
IN THIS YOU CAMPUSES. WHILE
THERE IS STILL MUCH WORK TO BE
DONE TO FURTHER ADDRESS
INEQUITIES AND EMPLOYMENT.
WAGES PUBLIC SCHOOL FUNDING AND
R. K. THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM. AC
FIVE WILL SET US ON THE PATH
TOWARDS EQUALITY AND JUSTICE.
AND I DO CHALLENGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO DO MORE THAN JUST
CAST YOUR VOTE IN FAVOR AND
SUPPORT TODAY. BUT TO ALSO
CHALLENGE TO SHOW UP AND BE
PRESENT IN YOUR COMMUNITIES. SO
THAT NOT ONE CONSTITUENTS IS TO
NOT AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY. TO
SUCCEED. SIMPLY BECAUSE O
THEIR THANK YOU. NAME IS AND
DOCTOR CHOI YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS SAW OF THE ASSEMBLY I
STANDING OPPOSITION OF ALL A.
C. A. FIVE FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT I HAVE A GREAT THE
RESPECT OF ALL MY COLLEAGUES
ACROSS THE I. L. FOR THE
AMAZING WORK. THAT YOU DO IS
SEND THE EVERYDAY IN THIS A
GREAT STATE. I AM A MINORITY A
PERSON OF COLOR YOU MAY SAY.
LET US BE CLEAR WHAT THE AC
EIGHTY FIVE IS ARE TRYING TO DO
TO DO THAT IS SO REPEALING
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE.
PROPOSITION TWO OR NINE PASSED
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX TO END
THIS SPECIAL AND THE
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT OF WHAT
INDIVIDUAL SO BASED ON THEIR
RACE SEX COLOR ETHNICITY. AND
THE NATIONAL ORIGIN THE ACT OF
WAR GIVING SPECIAL OR
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT TO
SOMEONE BASED ON THEIR RACE IS
SO RAISES SOME ITSELF. OR ON
THE SEX IS A SUBSYSTEM. JUST
ASK YOURSELF FOUR IS IT RIGHT
TO GIVE US SOMEONE A JOB. JUST
BECAUSE OF THE WHITE WHAT BLACK
OF ONE GREEN WHY ARE YELLOW OR
JUST BECAUSE THEY ARE MALE.
REPEALING PROPOSITION TWO OR
NINE ENACTED A BY THE BORDER
LOS TWENTY FOUR YES OUR GOAL IS
TO REPEAL THE PROHIBITS CHEN OF
A JUDGMENT A BASED ON RACE SEX
COLOR ETHNICITY AND NATIONAL
ORIGIN. WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE LEGALIZING RACISM AND
SEXISM. COLLEAGUES ARE I DO NOT
DOUBT WHEN I LEAVE A IN A STATE
TO WHERE THE COLOR OF MY SKIN
OR MY READY SO ONE MAIS SEXO
WERE MINE NATIONAL ORIGIN
DETERMINES ON MY QUALIFICATIONS
SO FOR A POSITION. A JOB POOL
WA ENTERING TOLL COLLEGE. I
CAME HERE TO THIS COUNTRY TO
GET AWAY FROM IDEOLOGIST SELECT
THAT. IT IS SO FOR THOSE
REASONS OF THAT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK OF FOR YOU A
NO VOTE. COLLEAGUES THANK YOU.
THEY ARE CHOI MISTER DAVID CHIU
YOUR RECOGNITION READ CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF A CA FIVE. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE PRESIDENT
JOHN F. KENNEDY SIGNED THE
FIRST EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. TO ENSURE
THAT AMERICANS ARE TREATED
FAIRLY WHEN IT COMES TO RACE
COLOR. OR NATIONAL ORIGIN. THE
VISION TO REVERSE THE LEGACY OF
PAST RACISM IN THE IMPACT OF
ONGOING DISCRIMINATION. AND I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
IT'S AN UNDERSTATEMENT TO SAY
THAT THAT VISION WAS NEVER
CHEAT. DECADES AFTER HIS
ASSASSINATION AND THE
ASSASSINATION OF CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADERS. RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATION AND THEIR IMPACT
ON INEQUALITY AND POVERTY
CONTINUE TO THIS DAY. DECADES
AFTER THE FIRST MARCHES FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE MARCHING IN THE STREETS TO
DATE AND THOSE SAME WRONGS. NOW
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT THAT'S
GONNA BE SAID ON THIS TOPIC
TODAY SO I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON
THE CONVERSATION AND MY AT THE
COMMUNITY. AS RELATED IN SOME
OF THE ELEVEN THOUSAND EMAILS
I'VE RECEIVED ON THIS TOPIC.
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION WANT YOU
TO BELIEVE THAT ASIAN AMERICANS
UNILATERALLY OPPOSE AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION. THAT IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
OVER A HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS
AND COMMUNITY LEADERS
REPRESENTING HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF ASIAN AMERICANS
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE SURVEYS
SHOW A MAJORITY OF OUR
COMMUNITY SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
AND WHY. THEY KNOW THAT WHEN
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE IS
LIFTED. ASIAN AMERICANS WILL
RECEIVE MORE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO ADVANCE IN
CONTRACTING THE DATA SHOWS THAT
ASIAN AMERICAN BUSINESSES. WHEN
MORE CONTRACTS AND CITIES WITH
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION LIKE A LANA
FOR CHICAGO THEN IN MY CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO WITH THE OLDEST
ASIAN COMMUNITY IN THE COUNTRY.
IN PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT I. HER ALL
THE TIME THAT MY ASIAN AMERICAN
CONSTITUENTS WANT MORE TEACHERS
WHO LOOK LIKE US MORE
PRINCIPLES UNIVERSITY
PRESIDENTS MORE FIRST
RESPONDERS FIREFIGHTERS BI
LINGUAL POLICE OFFICERS.
CURRENT LAW PREVENTS THAT. AND
FINALLY SOME FACTS ABOUT
EDUCATION FACT. UNIVERSITIES
THE PRACTICE AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
OF SEEN GREATER GAINS IN ASIAN
AMERICAN ENROLLMENT IN SCHOOLS
THAT DON'T. FAX ASIAN ADMISSION
RATES TO THE UC'S INCLUDING THE
GREAT SCHOOLS ARE BERKELEY AND
UCLA HAVE ACTUALLY GONE DOWN
SINCE THE PROP TWO OH NINE BàN
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. AND ONE
MORE FACT IF ACA FIVE PASSES
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
HAS ALREADY RULED THAT
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION CANNOT BE
USED TO SET QUOTAS. I ALSO WANT
TO SAY SOMETHING ABOUT MY OWN
PERSONAL HISTORY. I WOULD NOT
BE STANDING HERE ON THIS FLOOR.
AS THE FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN TO
REPRESENT EASTERN SAN FRANCISCO
BUT FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
WHEN I WAS NINETEEN. I WAS
ADMITTED TO A PROGRAM TO
ENCOURAGE MINORITY STUDENTS TO
CONSIDER CAREERS IN PUBLIC
POLICY. I WOULD HAVE GOT A
FELLOWSHIP TO GO TO PUBLIC
POLICY SCHOOL AT HARVARD OR PUT
ON THE PATH TO BE WHERE I AM TO
DAY. AND AS OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO SAID SO MANY OF US
WOULD NOT BE HERE TODAY. BUT
FOR THESE PROGRAMS. WHEN HEREBY
POINTING OUT ONE THING ABOUT
TODAY'S VOTE. TODAY'S VOTE IS
NOT GOING TO DO WAY WITH PROP
TWO OH NINE TODAY'S VOTE SIMPLY
GIVES CALIFORNIANS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THAT
DECISION A QUARTER CENTURY
AFTER PROP TWO ONE NINE WHEN WE
SHOULD ALLOW A NEW GENERATION
OF VOTERS TO DECIDE WHETHER WE
ARE DOING ENOUGH TO IT. TO
ADDRESS THE SPIRITS. VOTERS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO THE SIDE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD RUN STEM
CAMPS FOR GIRLS. AND NOT HAVE A
BAND BECAUSE IT CONSIDERS
GENDER. VOTER SHOULD BE ABLE TO
DECIDE IF A POLICE REVIEW
BOARD. SHOULD CONSIDER THE
RACIAL BACKGROUND OF ITS
APPLICANTS AND NOT HAVE A BAND
FOR CONSIDERING RACE. VOTERS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DECIDE IF WE
CAN A PROGRAMS TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF LET NEXT DOCTORS TO
ADDRESS ENORMOUS HEALTH
DISPARITIES. AND VOTER SHOULD
DECIDE IF ASIAN OWNED
BUSINESSES DECIMATED BY COVERT
RACISM SHOULD GET SOME
ASSISTANCE. IF THIS MEASURES
PASSED BY VOTERS IT'S SIMPLY
LIFTS A BAN. BUT WHAT WILL
HAPPEN AFTER NOVEMBER IS THAT
THE PUBLIC. LOCAL STATE
GOVERNMENTS. SCHOOL DISTRICTS
PLEASE ACCOUNTABILITY BOARDS.
CAN GO TO THE PUBLIC AND CAN
WORK ON NEW SOLUTIONS TO MAKE
OUR STATE. A TRUE STATE OF
OPPORTUNITY. IN CLOSING LET ME
ALSO ADMIT THAT I HAD SOME
INITIAL MISGIVINGS ABOUT
WHETHER THIS WAS THE RIGHT TIME
TO MOVE ON THIS MEASURE.
BECAUSE THIS IS A TOUGH
CONVERSATION. BUT LET ME SAY IF
NOT NOW THEN WHEN. IF NOT US
THEN WHO THE TIME IS ALWAYS
RIGHT TO DO WHAT IS RIGHT IT'S
TIME TO DO THE RIGHT THING. I
ASK YOU TO SUPPORT ACA FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER TO. MS WICKS.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE CA
FIVE AND COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO FOR TAKING ON
YET ANOTHER RIGHTEOUS FIGHT. AS
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
PROTEST THE MURDER OF GEORGE
FLOYD AND THE CENTURIES OF
OPPRESSION RACISM THAT LED TO
THE LAST EIGHT MINUTES AND
FORTY THREE SECONDS OF HIS LIFE.
IT IS PAST TIME TO ADMIT THE
RACISM HAS INFECTED EVERY
SYSTEM OF THIS NATION.
CALIFORNIA IS NOT IMMUNE FROM
THIS DISEASE OF RACISM YET
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX WITH
THE PASSAGE OF PROP TWO NINE
WE'VE ATTEMPTED TO PUT THE
BLINDERS ON TO THIS
UNCOMFORTABLE TRUTHS. PROP TWO
NINE IS A MANIFESTATION OF OUR
REFUSAL TO ACKNOWLEDGE. THE
DAMAGE THAT SYSTEMIC RACISM
SEXISM HAS CAUSED CALIFORNIANS
OF COLOR. THIS IS MADE EASIER
TO BE SHOCKED- ME SEE
DISCRIMINATION FIRSTHAND
WHETHER IT'S AS A MICROGRAPHS
IN PUBLIC HATE SPEECH ONLINE
ONE UNARMED BLACK PERSON BEING
MURDERED BY POLICE IN THE
STREETS. THE FIRST STEP TO
CURING THE DEEPLY ROOTED RACISM
DISEASE OF RACISM IS BY
DIAGNOSING IT AND REJECTING
FAULTY TREATMENTS LIKE PROP TWO
OH NINE. THAT PROMISE RESULTS
SUCH AS COLOR BLIND CALIFORNIA
DOES NOT SEE RACE. THE REALITY
IS THAT PROP TWO NINE WAS NOT A
CURE ALL. FOR DISCRIMINATION IN
FACT THE MEASURE WAS A
REGRESSIVE CHANGE TO OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION THAT DECIMATED
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO FIGHT
DISCRIMINATION. SINCE PROP TWO
NINE PASSED WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR HAVE LOST BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
IN STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTS. THERE'S BEEN
DRAMATIC AT THERE'S BEEN
DRAMATIC DECREASES IN ADMISSION
RATES FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR IN
THE UC SYSTEM. AND WOMEN HAVE
CONTINUED TO BE PAID LESS THAN
MEN A WAGE GOT THAT IS EVEN
WORSE FOR WOMEN OF COLOR. WELL
A CA FIVE WILL NOT REMEDY ALL
THE ILLS CAUSEWAY RACISM AND
SEXISM IN CALIFORNIA. IT IS A
HUGE LEAP FORWARD. THE WILL OUR
STATE TO PROACTIVELY FIGHT THEM.
THIS WILL REDUCE RACE CONSCIOUS
PROGRAMS THIS WILL INCLUDE RACE
CONSCIOUS PROGRAMS THAT MEET
THE NEEDS OF EVERY COMMUNITY BY
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE FULL
BREADTH OF PEOPLE'S
EXPERIENCES. WHICH ARE SHAPED
BY THE SYSTEMIC RACISM AND
SEXISM THE PREVENTS EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY. REPEALING PROP TWO
NINE IS NOT ABOUT SETTING
QUOTAS. IT'S ABOUT CREATING
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL. THAT
STARTS WITH RECOGNIZING THAT
THE BARRIERS SYSTEMIC RACISM
AND SEXISM CREATE SUPPORTING
PROGRAMS THAT HELP PEOPLE
OVERCOME THESE OBSTACLES I
WORKING TO PARMALEE DISMANTLE
THEM. WE CANNOT HAVE COLLECTIVE
SUCCESS WITHOUT SHARED
OPPORTUNITY AND A CA FIVE IS
UNNECESSARY AND LONG OVERDUE
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION. IF
YOU'VE WATCHED THE EVENTS OF
THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS LIKE MANY
OF US HAVE. WATCH THIS UNFOLD
ON YOUR TELEVISION ON YOUR
PHONE YOU'VE SEEN THE VIDEOS IF
YOU WATCH THE PAIN AND ANGUISH.
THAT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE
EXPRESSED. IN THESE WRETCHES
PROTESTS AND DEMONSTRATIONS AND
IF YOU HAVE WONDERED WHAT CAN I
DO TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
SOLUTION. HOW CAN I BE AN ALLY
HOW CAN I BE A PART OF THE
SOLUTION WELL HERE'S A CHANCE
FOR YOU. I AM PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS. IMPORTANT
MEASURE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
WICKS MISTER RAMOS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND PROP TWO OH NINE IS
AN AREA THAT WE NEED TO REPEAL
I STAND HERE TO FULLY SUPPORT
ACA FIVE. THE NEXT THURSDAY
JUNE EIGHTEENTH HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MARKS. THE
ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY THAT THIS
STATE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FORMER WE APOLOGIZE FOR THE
HISTORICAL VIOLENCE
MALTREATMENT NEGLECT AND
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES
AGAINST CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICANS. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REPEAL TWO OH NINE WILL GO TO
THE VOTE OF THE PEOPLE WE'RE
HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT ACA FIVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL.
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE REPRESENTED. IT
IS RECOGNIZED THAT THE STATE
SANCTIONED OVER CENTURY OF
ATTACKS PLUNDERING PILLAGING
AND PREJUDICIAL POLICIES
AGAINST CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICANS. I WANT TO THANK US A
QUAN BAND. THE PEOPLE OF CALL
ME I NATION FOR THEIR SUPPORT
ALSO IN MOVING FORWARD THE
REPERCUSSIONS OF THOSE
DESTRUCTIVE POLICIES STILL
PERSIST TODAY. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE.
BECAUSE OF THOSE PRACTICES
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICANS
REMAIN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT THROUGH DISEASE
EDUCATION ATTAINMENT LACK OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
DIMINISHED EMPLOYMENT
ENTERTAINMENT 31% A NATIVE
AMERICANS EXPERIENCE
DISCRIMINATION WHEN APPLYING
FOR JOBS. I STAND HERE TODAY.
IN THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY AS
THE FIRST CALIFORNIA INDIAN
ELECTED TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. WHAT WE HAVE TO
ASK OURSELVES WHY HAS IT TAKEN
SO LONG FOR THAT TO HAPPEN.
IT'S BECAUSE OF POLICIES LIKE
THIS. THAT WE NEED TO REPEAL TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ALL HAVE A
FAIR AND EQUAL TREATMENT AND
MOVING FORWARD. IT'S TIME THAT
WE ALL COME TOGETHER AS
CALIFORNIAN ALL COMMUNITIES
COME TOGETHER TO FURTHER THE
QUEST OF EQUALITY FOR ALL OF US
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- JR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
RAMOS MR GLORIA. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM THE PODIUM IN
THE WALL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE THIS AFTERNOON
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE LGBT Q. CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF A CA FIVE. I WANT TO
TAKE MY GREAT COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN
BRINGING THIS LEGISLATION
FORWARD. I'D LIKE TO BELIEVE
MEMBERS THAT ALL OF US ARE
MINDFUL OF THE STATE OF OUR
NATION. AND THE CONVERSATIONS
WE HAD IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
FUNDAMENTALLY THE CHALLENGE
BEING FACED IS THE STRUCTURE OF
THIS NATION FROM ITS LAWS TO
ITS OPPORTUNITIES HAVE BEEN
RIGGED AGAINST COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND UNDER REPRESENTED
POPULATIONS. WHAT WE'RE
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST RIGHT NOW
IS NOT ONLY POLICING. THAT'S
JUST THE START. IF THE SYSTEMIC
AND HISTORIC LACK OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT INVESTMENT AN
OPPORTUNITY IN AND FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND LET'S
BE VERY CLEAR. PROPOSITION TWO
OH NINE HAS CONTRIBUTED TO THIS
SAD HISTORY. MEMBERS IT'S NOT
THAT COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND THEY START BEHIND. IT
HAS PREVENTED EQUITABLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR BLACK AND BROWN
BUSINESSES FOR WOMEN IN BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE IN PUBLIC
CONTRACTING PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
AND PUBLIC EDUCATION FOR
DECADES. IT'S OUT OF DATE IT'S
OUT OF SYNC WITH WHO WE ARE AS
CALIFORNIANS IT DOES NOT HELP
US BUILD THE CALIFORNIANS FOR
ALL THAT WE SHOW UP HERE EACH
EIGHT TO WORK TO CREATE. IT'S
TIME THAT WE ARE THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA TO RECONSIDER ITS
DECISION. IT'S FINALLY TIME TO
UNDO THIS INJUSTICE IN ADVANCE
REAL RACIAL AND GENDER EQUITY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS
WHEN I WAS YOUNG. MY PARENTS
SAT ME DOWN AND EXPLAINED TO ME
THE SUMMER WITH THIS COMPLEXION
HAS TO WORK TWICE AS HARD. TO
GET JUST AS FAR. THE QUESTION
THAT WE SHOULDASK OURSELVES IS
WHY IS THAT. WHY SHOULD THAT
STAND PARTICULARLY IN THE
GOLDEN STATE. HI HUMBLY SUGGEST
YOU THE ANSWER IS THAT IT JUST
SHOULD NOT WE CAN DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT AND JUSTICE HERE
TODAY. SO I STAND HERE IS THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LGBT Q. CAUCUS IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE BLACK CAUCUS. IN
ASKING THIS BODY TAKE THIS STEP
TO FINALLY GIVE WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THIS STATE.
A GREATER SHOT AT SUCCESS OF
THAT CALIFORNIA DREAM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU EITHER.
THANK YOU MISS GLORIA. MISS THE
MARK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. MISTER
SPEAKER. I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ACA FIVE WHICH IS A PRIORITY
BILL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
WE'RE LIVING THROUGH
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES THE
PANDEMIC COUPLED WITH
ACTIVITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IN THE NATION CALL ON TO AND-
THE MANY VOICES THAT FOR
DECADES HAVE GONE ON HEARD. AS
WE HE'LL PICK UP THE PIECES WE
MUST WRK TO MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
STATE AND NATION BETTER THAN IT
WAS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. THE
CONVERSATION THAT BRINGS US
HERE TODAY IS ONE THAT WILL
ALLOW THE MANY VOICES IN
CALIFORNIA TO WEIGH IN ON WHERE
WE WANT TO FALL ON ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MINORITIES.
IF YOU ARE WOMEN BETWEEN THE
AGES OF FORTY AND SEVENTY
THREE. AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
APPLIED TO YOU. YOU BENEFITTED
FROM AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. AC
FIVE GIVE CALIFORNIA VOTERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECONSIDER AND
POTENTIALLY REPEAL PROPOSITION
TWO OH NINE THROUGH THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE WELL WOMEN
ENTREPRENEURS ARE FLOURISHING
NATIONALLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES ARE NOT
GETTING THEIR FAIR SHARE OF
OPPORTUNITIES. CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO THE GREATEST NUMBER OF
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES IN THE
NATION WITH ABOUT ONE POINT
FIVE FIVE MILLION WOMEN OWNED
FIRMS EMPLOYING MORE THAN ONE
MILLION PEOPLE AND GENERATING A
COMBINED ANNUAL REVENUE OF
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
AND YET. A TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN STUDY SHOWS THAT
BUSINESS OWNED BY BUSINESSES
OWNED BY WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR LOSE ONE POINT ONE
BILLION. ANNUALLY IN GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTS. 60% OF ALL AMERICANS
THAT HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS
DURING THE KOBE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC ARE WOMEN. ACA FIVE
WOULD ALLOW FOR A CONVERSATION
AND HOW WE LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD FOR WOMEN AND MINORITIES
GIVING A VOICE TO THOSE WHO
HAVE NOT BEEN AWARDED
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS AND STATE
HIRING TO ENSURE THAT
GOVERNMENT SOLUTION SPUR
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND WILL HELP.
ALL MEMBERS A KID OR OF OUR
COMMUNITY INCLUDING THE MOST
VULNERABLE. BY EXPANDING JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WOMEN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TAKES A
CRITICAL STEP IN CLOSING THE
GENDER GAP. WOMEN MAKE EIGHTY
ONE CENTS FOR EVERY DOLLAR
EARNED BY MEN. IT IS NO SECRET
THAT THE WAGE GAP IS EVEN WIDER
FOR WOMEN OF COLOR. BLACK WOMEN
MAKE SIXTY TWO CENTS TO THE
DOLLAR FOR A WHITE MAN AND
LATINOS MAKE FIFTY FOUR CENTS
TO THE DOLLAR. WITH EIGHTY FIVE
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
UNLOCK CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
POTENTIAL AN OPPORTUNITY THAT
CANNOT AND SHOULD NOT BE MISSED.
REALIZING THE ECONOMIC
POTENTIAL OF WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES REQUIRES CHANGING
POLICIES BUSINESS PRACTICES AND
ATTITUDES. THIS IS WHY THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS VOTED TO MAKE AC FIVE A
PRIORITY BILL FOR US THIS YEAR
AND ALLOWING CALIFORNIANS TO
WAIT IN ON ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL. THANK YOU MISS AMOUNT
MR GABRIEL. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I TO
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF A CA
FIVE AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS. OUR CAUCUS HAS VOTED TO
SUPPORT ACA FIVE WE THINK IT'S
AN EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT
MEASURE. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
BEING. SUCH A MORAL VOICE IN
THIS BODY AND FOR BRINGING
FORWARD THIS THIS IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JURORS
CAUCUS SUPPORTS THIS BILL. FOR
A VARIETY OF REASONS BUT FIRST
AND FOREMOST BECAUSE IT IS
DEEPLY ROOTED IN OUR VALUES OUR
TRADITION TEACHES US TO VALUE
JUSTICE. TO VALUE EQUITY TO
VALUE HUMAN DIGNITY TO VALUE
PROTECTING THE VULNERABLE SO
THIS IS A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
IS VERY CONSISTENT WITH WHO WE
ARE. AND HOW WE DEFINE
OURSELVES AS A COMMUNITY.
THERE'S ALSO FIRMLY ROOTED IN
OUR HISTORIC SUPPORT FOR THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT. I CAN
TELL YOU THERE'S A DIVERSITY OF
OPINIONS ON MANY THINGS IN THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY. THE ONE THING
THAT IS BROADLY SHARED IN OUR
COMMUNITY IS THE PRIDE THAT WE
FELT THAT SO MANY RABBIS. SO
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE WHEN IT
SUPPORTED THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT. NURSING KNOWLEDGE
MINT IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT THAT
THE STRUGGLE THE STILL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT IS SO FAR FROM
FINISHED. AND SO WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION AND STAND. IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE BLACK
COMMUNITY WITH OTHER
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND WITH
WOMEN IS THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
ST STRIVE TO. EQUALITY ONE
RESPECTFULLY SUGGEST TO SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES WHO MIGHT NOT BE
INCLINED TO SUPPORT THIS THAT.
I ACTUALLY THINK IT SHOULD BE
HOPEFULLY IT'S AN EASY VOTE FOR
A LOT OF FOLKS TODAY. BECAUSE
IRRESPECTIVE OF HOW YOU FEEL
ABOUT THE POLICY I HOPE THAT
YOU RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE IN AN
EXTRAORDINARY MOMENT. IN
HISTORY RIGHT NOW. AN
UNPRECEDENTED MOMENT WE HAVE
WITNESSED PROTESTS. ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY. OFTEN IN PLACES WHERE
WE WOULD NOT EXPECT THEM. WHERE
PEOPLE AND PARTICULARLY YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE DEMANDING. NOT JUST
JUSTICE FOR GEORGE FLOYD. THE
DEMANDING SYSTEMIC CHANGE. THE
DEMANDING SO SOME EXCHANGE AND
MY- COLLEAGUE AND I FROM HOW
ALSO WERE TALKING LAST NIGHT
ABOUT THE FACT. THAT ANYONE WHO
IS UNDER THE AGE OF FORTY ONE
HAS NOT HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WEIGH IN ON THIS ISSUE. THAT
THEY ARE THAT OUR GENERATION
HAS NOT HAD THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
SPEAK TO THIS AND TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT IT IT'S
BEEN. A QUARTER OF A CENTURY
SINCE VOTERS WERE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY. I RESPECTFULLY
SUGGEST THAT OUR GENERATION.
I'M THIRTY EIGHT A COLLEAGUE I
THINK IS A IS APPROACHING FORTY
WERE NOT THAT YOUNG- OUR-
GENERATION. HAS A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE ON THINGS. AND I
THINK. THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON THIS
ISSUE. THAT LEFT OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALL PEOPLE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION. I THINK AT THIS
MOMENT IN TIME. I THINK DEMAND.
FOR CHIU THIS. THE DEMAND FOR
OFFICE. CHANGE THAT WE ARE
WITNESSING FOR PEOPLE A- THIS
COUNTRY. BE EXTRAORDINARILY
SHORT SIGHTED ABBAS AND I THINK
I WOULD SUGGEST. REALLY TONE
DEAF. FOR US NOT TO PERMIT
VOTERS HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WEIGH ON ON THIS. AT THE SAME
TIME OUT ALSO. THAT THIS IS A
CHEN. AND COMPLEX ISSUE FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE. BECAUSE IT
REQUIRES US TO BE HONEST ABOUT
SOME PARTS OF OUR HISTORY THAT
ARE HARD TO THINK ABOUT.
REQUIRES US TO BE HONEST ABOUT
HOW BADLY THE SYSTEM IS RIGGED
IN THIS COUNTRY. I'M A WHEN I
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH FOLKS
ABOUT THESE ISSUES OFTENTIMES
PEOPLE SAY WELL WHAT ABOUT
ECONOMIC AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
WHY CAN'T WE JUST FOCUS ON ON
POVERTY IN THERE THERE'S MERIT
TO THAT BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
POVERTY IS A REAL ISSUE. BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT RACE AND GENDER
MATTER. WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE
STUDY AFTER STUDY HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENT OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE
BASED ON RACE AND GENDER IN
EDUCATION AND HEALTH AND JOB
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE WAY THAT
THEY LIVE THEIR LIVES. IN AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO BE HONEST ABOUT. IT ALSO
IGNORES HIS. IGNORES THE FACT
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN CENTURIES
OF SAYS OF SYSTEMIC RACIAL
INJUSTICE THAT HAVE BEEN
EMBEDDED IN SO MANY PARTS OF
OUR PUBLIC POLICY IN THIS
COUNTRY. IN EDUCATION IN ZONING
AND HOUSING AND IT'S SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS AND SO MANY
DIFFERENT. FACETS OF OUR PUBLIC
POLICY WE HAVE SEEN THINGS THAT
HAVE SYSTEMATICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND WOMEN. AND THE OTHER
THING THAT I WOULD SUGGEST ALL
OF US WHEN YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT THIS IS THAT I THINK ALL
OF US KNOW IN OUR HEARTS. THE
RACE AND GENDER MATTER. I DON'T
THINK THAT THERE'S A PERSON IN
HERE WHO WOULD WOULD DISPUTE
THAT AT THE END OF THE DAY
THESE ARE THINGS THAT THAT
IMPACT US AND THAT THE IMPACT
ON THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS
VERY DAY. AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
SUGGEST TO MY COLLEAGUES THAT
THIS IS A REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT VOTE. AND TO THOSE
WHO MIGHT THINK THAT. IS THAT.
THAT AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. IS
SOMETHING THAT ZERO SUM MIGHT
OFFER. I OFTEN ALTERNATE
PERSPECTIVE. BUT THIS IS
ACTUALLY. WHEN I THINK A LOT
ABOUT THE- THE SEMINAL SUPREME
COURT CASES FROM THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS ABOUT ABOUT
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IN PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION AND THE FACT
THAT SOME OF THE STRONGEST AND
MOST PERSUASIVE ARGUMENTS THAT
WERE ULTIMATELY CITED IN
JUSTICE O'CONNOR'S OPINION CAME
FROM THE MILITARY. THE SECOND
IS COMMUNITY THAT IS WAITING IN
SUPPORT OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT IT'S A
IT'S A CENTRAL TO OUR
COMPETITIVENESS OF OUR
BUSINESSES TO THE STRENGTH OF
OUR MILITARY AND SO I WOULD
SUGGEST EVERYBODY THAT
EVERYBODY WILL BENEFIT FROM
THIS WE WILL HAVE A SOCIETY
THAT STREET THAT FREE- THAT'S
HEALTHIER AND STRONGER.
WEALTHIER THAT'S MORE COHESIVE
THE MORE EQUITABLE AND MARCH
STE LOSS OF A SOCIETY THAT'S
BRAVE ENOUGH TO BE HONEST ABOUT
HOW BADLY THIS SYSTEM IS RIGGED
AND BRAVE ENOUGH TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT AND I
THINK THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL GIFT
FOR US IF TO OUR CHILDREN AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN IBM.
THANK WAS GABRIEL MS
BOERNER HORVATH. NEXT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I WANT
TO ECHO- MY SUPPORT FOR A CA
FIVE OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SHARED WITH YOU. BUT I WANT TO
SHARE PERSONAL STORY. IN MARCH
A FIFTH GRADE CLASS FOR MY
DISTRICT CAME TO THE CAPITOL TO
ADVOCATE FOR EQUITY NOT JUST
EQUALITY. AND THE PRESUMPTION
BE TO BEHIND AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
IS TO CREATE AN OPTION FOR
THOSE LEADERS WHO WANT TO FIGHT
THE HISTORIC GENDER AND RACIAL
BIAS. AND CREATE A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD. EQUITY AC FIVE
IS ONE STEP IN THAT DIRECTION
IT GIVES THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THEIR VOICE HEARD.
ESPECIALLY OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
COULDN'T VOTE TWO DECADES AGO.
WHICH IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
GIVEN THE CURRENT NATIONAL
DISCOURSE. I THINK OF THOSE
FIFTH GRADERS CAN UNDERSTAND
EQUITY WE CAN'T TO I ORDERED
YOUR SUPPORT OF A FEW FIVE.
THANK YOU THIS BOERNER HORVATH
MR STONE YOUR RECOGNIZE. I'M AN
ENDING SEXISM AND THAT'S NEVER
WHAT IT WAS ABOUT. AB TWO OH
NINE WAS ABOUT PRESERVING
PRIVILEGE AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY FOR SOMEONE
TO SAY I AM COLOR BLIND WHAT
THEY'RE BLIND TO IS THEIR OWN
PRIVILEGE. WHAT THEIR BLINDS TO
IS THE BENEFIT AND THE
RESILIENCE IN THE BEAUTY OF
CULTURES THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY FAMILIAR WITH.
MEMBERS IF WE STOP TALKING
ABOUT GENDER. SEXISM WHEN. IF
WE STOP TALKING ABOUT RACE.
RACISM WITH THAT'S WHAT PROP
TWO OH NINE IS ABOUT AND
ANYTHING ELSE. IS THAT LIVE. IT
IS TIME WE AND THAT WHY IT IS
TIME WE STAND UP TO THOSE WHO
HAVE HAD PRIVILEGE. AND USE
THAT PRIVILEGE TO KEEP OTHER
PEOPLE DOWN. AND AWAY FROM THAT
PRIVILEGE ACA FIVE IS A STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION AND IF WE CAN'T
COMPLETELY REPEAL PROP TWO OH
NINE. IF WE CAN'T COMPLETELY
REPEAL THE LAWS THAT HAVE BUILT
SYSTEMIC RACISM AND SEXISM INTO
MOST EVERYTHING THAT WE DO WITH
OUR INSTITUTIONS. THEN WE HAVE
A LOT MORE WORK TO DO THAT JUST
A CA FIVE THIS IS A STEP WE CAN
TAKE THIS IS FOREVER ALL OF US
WHO HAVE BEEN OUT TO THE
PROTESTS AND SHOWN SOLIDARITY.
THAT'S ONE THING THIS IS WHERE
WE CAN SHOW THAT THERE'S MORE
THAN JUST. LIP SERVICE TO THIS
ISSUE THAT WE CAN START TO
REALLY ADDRESS RACISM SEXISM AT
ITS CORE WE HAVE TO PASS A-
MISTER KALRA. YOUR RECOGNIZE.
AN MEMBERS OF MY RISE IN.
SUPPORT OF AC FIVE AND HOPE
THAT WE CAN PUT TO THE VOTERS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN FORTY
TWO OTHER STATES IN ALLOWING
FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION ONCE
AGAIN. AND ESPECIALLY IF YOU
LOOK AT. THE LAST FEW WEEKS IN
PARTICULAR- IF WE'RE GOING TO
STAND WITH OUR BLACK SISTERS
AND BROTHERS IN THE STREETS AND
CLAIM THE BLACK LIVES MATTER.
YEAH JUST DO THAT WITH WORDS WE
ACTUALLY HAVE TO TAKE CONCRETE
STEPS. THAT ACTUALLY CAN PROVE
THAT WE MEAN IT. IF WE'RE GOING
TO BE MARCHING WITH WOMEN OR
LAMENTING THE GENDER PAY GAP.
WE CAN'T SIMPLY JUST OUR HANDS
UP. AND EXCEPT FOR A FACT. THAT
THAT'S JUST THE WAY IT IS IN
OUR COUNTRY OR OUR STATE. IF
WHAT WHAT WE'RE GONNA MORE THE
STAINS OUR HISTORY BUT THE
CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT OR
JAPANESE INTERMENT WE HAVE
UNDERSTAND THE CONTEXT UNDER
WHICH THOSE HORRORS OF KURT OR
FOR GOING TO CELEBRATE THE
FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN SICK
AMERICAN INDIAN AMERICAN
CONGRESS NUMBER DOLLOP SING
SONG. WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT
BACK IN THE FIFTIES AND SIXTIES
HE WAS OF PURE SUPPORTER OF THE
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT. HE WAS A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS
AND FARMWORKERS. AND HE DROPPED
TO THE CONSTITUTIONAL HE WORKED
TO DROP A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT. DECLARING THE
QUALITY OF THE RIGHTS OF MEN
AND WOMEN. WHAT HE KNEW SIXTY
YEARS AGO IS WHAT WE STILL KNOW
TODAY THE WE HAVE TO BE
INTENTIONAL AND ROOTING OUT
RACISM AND SEXISM THIS IS NOT
ABOUT LEGALIZING RACISM AND
SEXISM AS ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUE
SAID. IT'S ACTUALLY QUITE THE
OPPOSITE IS BUT RECOGNIZING
THAT RACISM AND SEXISM EXISTS
AND IT'S OUR DUTY TO DO WE'VE
NEVER WEEKEND TO ROOT IT OUT.
NOW MY FAMILY CAME HERE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. WE
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
COME HERE IF IT WASN'T FOR THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND
THAT'S A FACT. AND WE CAN COUNT
MANY MANY THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES- API FAMILIES. WITH
THAT SAME SCENARIO THAT OF A
WASN'T FOR THOSE THAT GAVE
THEIR LIFE GIVE THEIR BLOOD. IN
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT WE
WOULDN'T BE HERE. SO HE FACT
THAT. THIS COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED.
AND BECAME A GLOBAL SUPERPOWER
ON THE FOUNDATION OF STORM LAND
A STONE LABOR IS NOT A MATTER
THAT IS RELEGATED TO CHAPTERS
IN DUSTY HISTORY BOOKS IT
ACTUALLY RUNS THROUGH THE VEINS
OF OUR NATION THIS DAY AND TO
ALL OF US. WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE.
THE REALITY THAT RACE MATTERS.
AND THAT THE LONGER WE DENY IT
AND THE LONGER WE TAKE ACTION
ON IT THE LONGER IT'S GOING TO
TAKE FOR US TO REACH THE
PROMISE. OF OUR GREAT NATION.
WE AT THE RECOGNIZE THE REALITY
THAT GENDER MATTERS AND WE NEED
TO BE HONEST AND INTENTIONALLY
THAT REALIZATION SO THAT WE MAY
SOME DAY HAVE CHIU EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR WOMEN AND AS
OTHER COLLEAGUES OFSAID THE
DATA IS VOLUMINOUS. IT'S AS
CLEAR AS DAY THAT WE HAVE IN
OUR SOCIETY. BY NO FAULT OF AN
INDIVIDUAL BUT JUST BASED UPON.
OUR COMMON SHARE HISTORY. WE
HAVE BARRIERS THAT ARE PUT UP
STRICTLY BECAUSE OF ONE GENDER
AND RACE. AND RIGHT NOW WHAT
WE'RE SEEING AROUND THE WORLD
ARE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE RISING
UP BECAUSE THEY KNOW NOT ONLY
THAT IT'S WRONG BUT THEY WANT
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT. AND
SO WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ALLOW THE VOTERS. TO GET IT
RIGHT. AND TO STAND UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE FOR GENDER
JUSTICE THE STAND UP FOR
EQUALITY AND WHAT WORDS ON
PAPER DO YOU MUST TO BE AS
AMERICANS. WE NEED TO KEEP
FIGHTING FOR IT AND I URGE YOU
JUST TO VOTE I ON A CA FIVE SO
WE CAN FIGHT TOGETHER. THANKS
CALLER MISTER COOLEY IN THE
REAR CHAMBER. COLLEAGUES I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT ACA FIVE. AND
PERMISSION TO READ EVER SO
BRIEFLY WITHOUT OBJECTION. I
HAVE HERE THE CLOSING LINES OF
THE GETTYSBURG ADDRESS. I WANT
TO OFFER A LITTLE REFLECTION
UPON. IT IS RATHER FOR US TO BE
HERE DEDICATED. TO THE GREAT
TASK REMAINING BEFORE US THAT
FROM THESE HONORED DEAD WE TAKE
INCREASED DEVOTION TO THAT
CAUSE. FOR WHICH THEY HERE GAVE
THE LAST FULL MEASURE OF
DEVOTION. THAT WE HERE HIGHLY
RESOLVE THAT THESE DEAD SHALL
NOT HAVE DIED IN VAIN. THAT
THIS NATION UNDER GOD. SHALL
HAVE A NEW BIRTH OF FREEDOM.
AND THE GOVERNMENT OF THE
PEOPLE BY THE PEOPLE FOR THE
PEOPLE SHALL NOT PERISH FROM
THE EARTH. TO REFLECT UPON THIS
I THINK IS SO MANY THOUGHTS
COME TO MIND. ABRAHAM LINCOLN
WAS A SPARRING FOR NEW BIRTH OF
FREEDOM. FOR OUR NATION TO
ENTER INTO A DIFFERENT QUALITY.
OF ITS UNDERSTAND OF WHAT
FREEDOM MEANT. THAT WAS WHAT HE
SAW BEFORE US. HE SAW THIS AS
SOMETHING THAT WAS AN EXTENSION
OF THE WORK AND THE- SACRIFICE
IT PRECEDED IT. HE SAW IT AS
SOMETHING THAT WAS FOUNDED IN
THE PEOPLE OF AMERICA. I HAVE
THE UTMOST REGARD FOR THIS
CAPITAL IN THIS CHAMBER. BUT
THE MEANING OF AMERICA WILL NOT
BE SETTLED HERE. IT WILL BE
SETTLED IN THE HEARTS OF
AMERICANS IT'LL BE SETTLED IN
THE HEARTS OF CALIFORNIANS. I
THINK ACA FIVE. COMING AS IT
DOES IN THIS YEAR. WHEN WE HAVE
SEEN SO MUCH DIVISION. REALLY
PRESENTS A PLEBISCITE. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GO BEFORE
CALIFORNIANS AND SAY WHAT IS
THE NATURE OF OUR DEMOCRACY
WHAT IS THE EXTENT TO WHICH ANY
ONE INDIVIDUAL. CAN CELEBRATE
AND HARBOR HOPE FOR ANOTHER WHO
MAY BE DIFFERENT FROM NOW. YOU
KNOW THERE CANNOT BE DEMOCRACY
IF THERE IS NOT COMPASSION. IF
THERE IS NOT EMPATHY. FOR
PEOPLE IN THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THEY FIND THEMSELVES IN. I
THINK THAT THE WHOLE MILIEU OF
SOCIAL MEDIA. ACTUALLY HAS THE
BENEFICIAL EFFECT OF
CONFRONTING EVERYONE WITH A
DIFFERENT LIVES UPON REAL LIFE.
SO I THINK THIS IS A
OUTSTANDING TIME TWENTY TWENTY.
TO REACH OUT TO ALL CALIFORNIA
SAY SEARCH YOUR HEART. WHAT IS
THE MEANING OF AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY WHAT IS THE MEANING
OF CALIFORNIA MARK PERCY. CAN I
CELEBRATE AN OPPORTUNITY
CONFERRED UPON SOMEBODY WHO IS
FACE BURDENS. YOU KNOW IT WAS
JOHN DUNN WHO LIVED IN THE
FIFTEEN HUNDREDS SERVED IN THE
PARLIAMENT. WHO SAID NO MAN IS
AN ISLAND COMPUTER TO ITSELF.
IF A CLOD FALLS AWAY EUROPE IS
DIMINISHED. DON'T ASK FOR WHOM
THE BELL TOLLS IT TOLLS FOR
THEE. THIS NOTION THAT WE. IF
WE ARE PARTISAN TO BURN
OURSELVES. WE'RE ALL IN IT
TOGETHER. SO I SORT OF VIEW
THIS AS A VERY IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY I WILL SAY FOR MY
WHOLE CAREER. THE MOST
IMPORTANT QUOTE ON LEADERSHIP
I'VE EVER HEARD WAS AGAIN NAMED
MICHELLE ROO. WHO SAID THE JOB
LEADERS NOT TO CHALLENGE PEOPLE.
DON'T BE RATE PEOPLE DON'T WEB
ON PEOPLE. THE JOB LEADERS NOT
TO CHALLENGE PEOPLE BUT TO GET
THEM TO CHALLENGE THEMSELVES I
THINK ACA FIVE IN A VERY
FUNDAMENTAL DEMOCRATIC WAY IN
KEEPING WITH THE GETTYSBURG
ADDRESS REFLECTION UPON A
MARKER SEE THAT ABRAHAM LINCOLN
PROVIDED IS NOT TRUE FOR PEOPLE
ASIDE WHAT IS IT CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA MARK PERCY AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY I THINK IT IS A VERY
FITTING QUESTION TO BRING FOR
DOUBLE WRIST. AT THIS TIME.
MUCH LIKE. THE OTHER ACA WE
DISCUSSED I THINK THIS IS THE
YEAR TO BRING FOR THIS
QUESTION. AND ASK ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO REFLECT UPON
THE MEANING OF CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRACY. THANK WAS COOLEY
MISTER SANTIAGO. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I WANT TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUES OFFERED FOR THE- FOR
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE BILL.
ACA FIVE AS ASSEMBLY EQUALITY
IT'S ABOUT TAKING A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. TO BRING US
JUSTICE. AND QUITE FRANKLY IT'S
A VERY MODEST THAT. ALL THIS
SAYS ANALYTICAL OF MY
COLLEAGUES A SAID LET THE
VOTERS DECIDE. THIS IS NOT THE
SAME CALIFORNIA THAT VOTED ON
THIS ABOUT TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO BECAUSE I'LL REMIND YOU
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA THERE
VOTED ABOUT A TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO. THEY PASSED PROPOSITIONS.
THAT ATTACKED OUR LANGUAGE.
THEY PASSED PROPOSITIONS THAT
ATTACKED IMMIGRANTS. A PAST
PROPOSITIONS THAT ATTACKED OUR
OPPORTUNITIES BUT THE THING
CALIFORNIA TODAY AND ALL WE'RE
SAYING IS LET THE VOTERS DECIDE
TODAY. AND ALTHOUGH IT'S A
MODEST. YOU DON'T HAVE AN
IMPACT ON GENERATIONS TO COME
IT'S A LITTLE TO NOT TODAY WE
DENY GENERATION THAT
OPPORTUNITY. WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT OPPORTUNITY. YEAH YOU
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT. HOW KIDS
ARE RAISED. AND I'LL BE GOOD
BREAK INTO A VERY VERY SIMPLE.
SIMPLE STORY WHICH IS MY STORE
AND IT'S NOT UNIQUE. MOST OF US
HERE WHO ARE OF COLOR OR WOMEN.
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION MANY MANY OF
YOU SHARE SIMILAR STORIES. IF
YOUR PARENTS CAN'T CAME HERE
FROM A DIFFERENT COUNTRY AND
THEY WORK EXTREMELY HARD.
WASN'T MY CHOICE TO BE BORN
POOR. IT WASN'T MY CHOICE THE
BE BORN AND NOT UNDERSTAND A
LANGUAGE. WASN'T MY CHOICE TO
LIVE IN SECTION EIGHT HOUSING.
WASN'T MY CHOICE TO WORK FULL
TIME- WHILE I WAS IN COLLEGE.
THE DID I GET THE BEST GRADES
IN THAT I GET A FOUR POINT
THREE AND DIE SLAM DUNK IT IN
THE IN THE UCLA RIGHT AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL. COURSE NOT. THEY
TAKE ME A LONG TIME. LIKE IT
TOOK OTHERS TO GET THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF COURSE.
PROBABLY LONGER THAN IT SHOULD.
FIVE SIX YEARS ON LIKE THAT.
BUT THIS IS THE REALITY. WHEN
YOU HAVE TO WORK AND YOU HAVE
TO HELP YOUR PARENTS MAKE RENT
NO ONE CHOOSES THAT. SO THIS
WHOLE IDEA. AND I'M NOT SAYING
ANYONE IS THAT IT. BUT THIS
WHOLE IDEA AT THE TIME. THAT
CERTAIN KIDS ONE QUALIFIED THAT
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE EQUAL AND
THAT RE SHOULDN'T MATTER WILL
IT DOES. BECAUSE THE ZIP CODE
THAT YOU WERE BORN IN
DETERMINES WHERE YOU'RE GOING
TO GO. AND IT'S NOT COINCIDENCE
THAT THE ZIP CODE YOU ARE BORN
IN OFTENTIMES REFLECTS WHAT YOU
LOOK LIKE THAT'S NOT A SECRET.
IF YOU GREW UP IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT I REPRESENT.
MORE THAN LIKELY YOU'LL BE
LOOKING. IF YOU GO UP IN
CERTAIN AREAS WITHOUT THE LATE
MORE THAN LIKELY YOU COULD BE
AFRICAN AMERICAN. AND WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A HARDER TIME
GETTING. SOME OF YOU I'VE HAD
THIS CONVERSATION WITH BUT I
NEVER REALLY SHARED PUBLICLY.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHEN I WENT TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE YEAH I
STRUGGLED. NIGHTFALL ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN AND WE THOUGHT ONE
PROPOSITION AND IT WAS FOR THIS
HEARTENING TO KNOW. THAT NO
MATTER HOW HARD I TRIED. I JUST
DIDN'T HAVE THE TIME TO STUDY I
DIDN'T HAVE THE TIME TO BE
POLITICALLY ACTIVE. I COULD DO
THOSE THINGS. AND WHEN APPLIED
TO UCLA MY ONE DREAM. MY ONE
DREAM NICE TO SAY WHEN I WAS A
KID MY ONE WAY TO GET OUT OF
THE HOOD. TO GET EDUCATION. BUT
I WAS THE NIGHT. I WAS DENIED
BECAUSE I DIDN'T HAVE THE
GRADES. AND I WAS HEARTBROKEN.
IT ALMOST DESTROYED MY LIFE I
THINK THAT THE ONE OPPORTUNITY
THAT I COULD HAVE TO HELP MY
PARENTS GET A SECTION EIGHT
HOUSING. GET MY LITTLE BROTHER
NOT PER TUTTI. WITH THE NIGHT
BECAUSE INSTEAD OF STUDYING I
HAD TO GO TO WORK. AND INSTEAD
OF A RECREATIONAL SUMMER
VACATIONS. WE PICKED THE BAXTER
JOBS. SO I APPEALED. AND THAT
IS EXACTLY THE CASE THAT I MADE
THE UCLA. WITH A OOK I WOULD
LOVE TO GO HOME AND STUDY IN A
PIE WITH A GOT A FOUR POINT
THREE. BUT I COULDN'T. THIRTY
SECONDS AND BECAUSE OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. AND BECAUSE
CONSIDERATION WHERE I CAME FROM.
WHAT I LOOK LIKE THE LANGUAGE I
SPOKE I GOT IN. I WAS ABLE TO
GRADUATE. MEGHAN COLLIDED AND
IT WAS NEVER IT WAS NEVER ABOUT
QUALIFICATIONS IT WAS NEVER
ABOUT THE ABILITY. BUT HE GAVE
ME AN OPPORTUNITY LIKE HE GAVE
MANY OF US. IN THAT'S THE
OPPORTUNITY. THAT THAT WE'RE
GONNA GIVE GENERATIONS. A
PEOPLE OF COLOR. WOMEN AND
WE'RE GONNA CHANGE THE STATE IT
WILL HAVE A DRAMATIC IMPACT ON
WHO GOES TO THESE INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER LEARNING. AND WHO HAD
WHO HAS A SAY. IN THE COME UP
THE WHAT WHEN THEY BECOME
DOCTORS ATTORNEYS LEGISLATORS
BECAUSE WE GOT AN OPPORTUNITY
AND WE WILL NOT WASTE THAT
OPPORTUNITY I CAN GUARANTEE.
BECAUSE WE KNEW HOW HARD IT WAS
TO GET HERE. AND WE'RE WILL DO
ALL WE CAN. TO MAKE IT EASIER
AND PROVIDE MORE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS. AND ALL
OUR ALLIES WERE SUPPORTING THIS
TODAY. GOD BLESS YOU FOR DOING
IT IN TAKING A STAND. FOR EACH
AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. YOU CAN BE HERE
TODAY THANK YOU. DECORAH
SANTIAGO MISTER JONES SAWYER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AS A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS AS CHAIR OF THE
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS. I JUST WANT
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF ACA FIVE
BUT MOST IMPORTANT. ABOUT THE
HORRORS OF THE PREMATURE REPEAL
OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX WHICH IS A
LEFTY EXPERIENCE OF BLACK AND
LATINO PEOPLE. OUT OF THE
EQUATION FOR THE SAKE OF A
COLOR BLIND WORLD THAT HAS
NEVER EXISTED IN THIS COUNTRY
BUT WE ALL KNOW IT HAS. WELL MY
UNCLE WALKED UP THE STEPS OF
LITTLE ROCK CENTRAL HIGH SCHOOL
IN NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN IT WAS
BECAUSE OF HIS BLACKNESS THAT
THE SUPREME COURT. TO RULE THAT
HE BE ALLOWED ACCESS TO THE
SAME SCHOOLS AS WHITES STUDENTS.
HIS SKIN COLOR IN DOVER
THEREFORE HIS HUMANITY BY THE
VERY REASON HE HAD THE RIGHT TO
INTEGRATE INTO A SCHOOL WITH
MORE RESOURCES THERE WHERE HE
WAS BORN. IN MY DISTRICT WHICH
HAS 95% OF THE RESIDENTS EITHER
BEING LATINO OR AFRICAN
AMERICAN. AC EIGHT FIVE
DIRECTLY IMPACTS AND BENEFIT
THOSE IN MY DISTRICT BY
PROCLAIMING THEIR BACKGROUND.
AND EXPERIENCES MATTER AND
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED FOR PUBLIC
HIRING AND ADMISSION PURPOSES.
REALLY DO NOT LIVE IN A COLOR
BLIND SOCIETY SO IT IS TIME
THAT WE STOP ACTING LIKE IT.
WHEN I WAS DIRECTOR REAL ESTATE
FOR THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES. I
WOULD TELL MY STAFF WE WOULD
HAVE AN AUCTION TO SELL CITY
PROPERTY. THAT WE NEEDED TO
ADVERTISE IN THE PAPERS AFTER
AMERICAN LATINO FILIPINO
JAPANESE. AND THE FIRST AUCTION
THAT I WAS OVER THEY NEVER
ADVERTISED IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
THEY ADVERTISE IN A
PREDOMINATELY WHITE NEWSPAPERS.
AND WHEN I BROUGHT THEM INTO MY
OFFICE. ALL WHITE MALES. THEY
TOLD ME BECAUSE OF THE PROP TWO
OH NINE THE FACT THAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE TO FOLLOW ANY
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION POLICIES
THEY DID NOT HAVE TO ADVERTISE
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES. AND
BESIDES. THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT.
AFTER I CALMED DOWN. I MADE IT
VERY CLEAR FROM AN ECONOMIC
STANDPOINT THAT YOU'RE LEAVING
OUT INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO PAY MORE FOR THE
POOR THOSE PROPERTIES THEN THE
PEOPLE YOU BELIEVE IN AND THAT
YOU ARE GOING TO ADVERTISE IN
THOSE PAPERS. SO I FORCED AND I
NOTICE HOW READ THEIR FACES GOT
AND HOW ANGRY THEY GOT. THE
NEXT AUCTION WE HEAD. I WAS SO
HAPPY. THAT THE HIGHEST PRICE
FOR A PROPERTY IN THAT AUCTION.
WENT TO A MEMBER OF THE LATINO
COMMUNITY WHICH FURTHER PROVE
TO ME AND TELL THEM THAT YOU
NEED TO INCLUDE EVERYONE. BUT
THE OTHER THING THAT I ALSO
REALIZED WHY HE WAS SO ANGRY.
WHY THEY WERE SO ANGRY. THEY
DIDN'T NEVER THOUGHT IN THEIR
CAREERS. THAT THEY WOULD HAVE A
BLACK MAN TELLING THEM WHAT TO
DO. AND IN FACT I WAS PROBABLY
THE WORST NIGHTMARE. IN FACT
WHEN I SCORED NUMBER ONE ON THE
TEST TO BE THEIR BOSS. OTHERS
WERE TRYING TO UNDERMINE THAT
BY PICKING SOMEONE A WHITE MALE
FOR THAT POSITION EVEN THOUGH
HE HAD NOT. PASS THE TEST.
LUCKILY FOR ME. THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE DEPARTMENT SAID
WE'RE GOING TO GO WITH. THE
NUMBER ONE CANDIDATE. AND I
BELIEVE LUCKILY FOR ME THE
GENERAL MANAGER WAS AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN MALE. WHO WAS
APPOINTED BY AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN MAYOR. SO MAYOR TOM
BRADLEY. APPOINTED MY GENERAL
MANAGER HE WAS ELECTED NOT IN
THE SEVENTIES. YOU POINT AT MY
GENERAL MANAGERS IN THE
NINETIES. AND THEN I WAS
BROUGHT ON. IN THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND. IT WAS TO TRY TECH TO
OF NIGHTMARES OF NIGHTMARES FOR
ANY RACES IN ANY. COMMUNITY OR
ANY INFRASTRUCTURE BUT MORE
IMPORTANT ANY BUREAUCRACY LIKE
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES. I WAS
ABLE TO BREAK UP. THE RACISM
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT. BY BEING
NUMBER ONE ON THE TEST BY
STAYING TRUE TO MY NATURE BUT
MOST IMPORTANT MAKING SHORT DID
NOT DID NOT GO ALONG TO GET
ALONG OR TO PERPETUATE THE WORD
RACISM WITHIN MY DEPARTMENT AND
DOING WHAT I'M SUPPOSED TO DO.
ON THE LEGACY THAT I STAND ON
ON THE SHOULDERS THAT I STAND
ON TO MAKE SURE THAT NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN. THE REPEAL OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. WAS
TERRIBLE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LET THE VOTERS
DECIDE. THE MISTAKE THAT WE
MADE BECAUSE I VOTER DURING
THAT TIME AND I VOTED AGAINST
IT EVEN GOT. THE MAYOR OF LOS
ANGELES WHEN I WAS ASSISTANT
DEPUTY MAYOR. TO VOTE DOWN THE
REPEAL OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
THIRTY SECONDS SO WE ALL HAVE A
STAKE IN THIS. AND WE ALL HAVE
RIGHT NOW A BOAT IN THIS WE ALL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT
A WRONG. ONE MEMBER AT A TIME
ONE PERSON AT A AT A TIME. SO
THAT THIS BECOMES A BETTER
WORLD AND THANK GOD HOPEFULLY
HOPEFULLY WE NEVER SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE STREETS AGAIN
BECAUSE WE'VE NOW MOVED. WE
MOVED THE AGENDA TO A BETTER
PLACE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO ARE MORE
COMFORTABLE OPPOSING A CA FIVE
BASED ON AN ASSERTION THAT RACE
DOESN'T MATTER BUT FACTS ARE
FACTS WHEN IT COMES TO
EDUCATION JOBS SCHOOLS CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND HOMEOWNERSHIP.
AFRICAN AMERICANS PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND WOMEN HAVE SUFFERED
DISCRIMINATION. ACA FIVE WILL
ALLOW CALIFORNIANS TO VOTE TO
HELP END THIS DISCRIMINATION
RACE DOES MATTER I'M VOTING YES
ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MAIENSCHEIN.
MS CRISTINA GARCIA HERE
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU I READ
THROUGH THE PORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
I TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO LIKE
WITH THE DETAILS OUT THERE
PROTESTING AS MAKING PHONE
CALLS ALL TALKING AND DOORS
AGAINST FIVE TWO ONE NINE AND
MY ARGUMENT THEN IS THE SAME AS
IT IS TODAY. UP TO A NINE IS
ABOUT PUSHING A FALSE
NARRATIVE. THAT WE HAVE AN
EQUITABLE EQUAL SYSTEM. SO
CALLED NEGATIVE THAT PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND WOMEN ARE IN FULL
CHARGE OF THEIR FAITH. BUT WE
KNOW THAT IF YOU'RE BLACK OR
BROWN IF YOU'RE A WOMAN. NO
MORE LIKELY TO BE POOR MORE
LIKELY TO LIVE IN POLLUTION. I
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE ON TRAIN
TEACHERS. ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
INCARCERATED OR TO THEIR WHICH
REALLY. AND THE LIST GOES ON.
THIS FALSE NARRATIVE ALSO
IMPLIES THAT WE FAIL TO SIXTY.
BECAUSE WE DON'T TRY HARD
ENOUGH. BECAUSE THIS IS THE
REWARDS HARD WORK EQUALLY. WE
ALSO NOTICED A SMALL. THE
REALITY IS THAT THE SYSTEM IS
MADE TO MAKE BROWN AND BLACK
PEOPLE FEEL MORE OFTEN THAN
NOT. AND IT'S AMERICA SOME OF
THOSE DO HAVE MOBILITY. BUT
WHEN WE DO THAT MOBILITY IS
USED TO PRESERVE ALTERNATIVE.
THAT WE WORK HARD ENOUGH WE CAN
MAKE IT AND WE CAN BE A SUCCESS.
THE REALITY IS THAT BEING A
TOKEN. IS FAR FROM BEING AN
EQUAL VOICE. AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
IS THAT ABOUT PREVENTIVE
TREATMENT. IT'S ABOUT A
KNOWLEDGE IN THAT THE SYSTEM IS
AN EQUAL. THAT WE HAVE A SYSTEM
OF INSTITUTIONAL RACISM AND
SEXISM. THAT MAKES IT MUCH
HARDER. MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
US I COULD DO EVERYTHING RIGHT
IN BECAUSE I'M A WOMAN AND A
WOMAN OF COLOR IS LIKELY NOT TO
BE ENOUGH. EASY ADVISED
OPPORTUNITIES THAT AGAINST THE
SMALL OF NARRATIVE. IN TO BE AN
ALLY IN THE KNOWLEDGE THAT THIS
IS THE MOST ANYTHING BUT FAIR.
WE HAVE TO DO ALL WE CAN TO
ENSURE WE HAVE INCREASED AT
THE- TOP OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND WOMEN. AND
MAYBE CLEARLY HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY NOT ONLY DO WE RISE
TO THE OCCASION BUT WE NEED
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN TAUGHT TO
BE. TWICE AS GOOD FOR D. SANTA
FOR GOOD. AND SO I HOPE THAT
TODAY WE HAVE CORRECT AND
JUSTICE THAT WAS THE TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO AT THE BALLOT.
IN IS NOT ENOUGH TO VOTE YES ON
THE CA FIVE. WILL BE ON YOUR
DISTRICT YOU CAMPAIGN BETWEEN
NOW AND NOVEMBER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE PULL THIS AND WE. AND
THE SOUTH AREAS. THANK YOU.
THANK MISTER CMS. GAL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS- I RISE TODAY
IS AS SOMEONE WHO IS DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RACIAL
DISPARITIES THAT WE SEE IN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM. AND. YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN CONFRONTED ONCE
AGAIN. IN THIS COUNTRY WITH THE
FACT THAT THINGS ARE NOT EQUAL
AND THAT AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID.
REYES DOES MATTER. BUT AS I
STAND AND CONSIDER THIS MEASURE.
I CAN'T SAY THAT PROP TWO OH
NINE IS THE PROBLEM. IT'S MUCH
DEEPER THAN THAT WHEN WE LOOK
AT THAT AND I AND I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS THAT WE'VE- THAT
HAVE BEEN STATED HERE ON THIS
FOR TODAY AND THE AND THE
EXPERIENCES THAT. MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE SHARED TODAY THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT AND IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HAVE THIS DISCUSSION. TO TALK
ABOUT HOW DO WE GET TO THE ROOT
CAUSES. THE INEQUITIES THAT. WE
CAN SEE VERY CLEARLY IN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM. BUT I SAY
THAT PROP TWO NINE IS NOT THE
PROBLEM- WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
STATS- THE GETTING RID OF A
RACIAL PREFERENCES DID NOT
ACTUALLY LEAD TO DECREASES IT
ACTUALLY LEAD TO INCREASES- AND
LATINO STUDENTS BEING ADMITTED
IT LEAD TO INCREASES IN ASIAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS BEING
ADMITTED. BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE STATS. ADMISSIONS OF BLACK
STUDENTS REMAINED STAGNANT. IN
THE UC SYSTEM 4% THERE HASN'T
IN PROGRESS THERE. THAT'S A
PROBLEM LET'S GO A LITTLE BIT
DEEPER IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT A
MISSION BECAUSE LET'S TALK
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON IN
RETAINING STUDENTS WHILE
THEY'RE IN. HIGHER EDUCATION.
THE STATS SHOW THAT 38% OF
BLACK STUDENTS GRADUATE IN FOUR
YEARS FROM THE UC SYSTEM. IN
CSU IT'S EVEN MORE SINCE 8% SO
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT EMISSIONS
AND USING BRING BACK FROM AN OF
ACTION BUT WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
ENSURE THAT. BLACK AND BROWN
STUDENTS GRADUATE AND GET THAT
EDUCATION THAT'S A
CONVERSATION. THAT WE NEED TO
BE HAPPENED WE NEED TO GO EVEN
DEEPER. BUT LET'S TAKE EVEN TO
THE NEXT LEVEL BECAUSE THIS
STARTS WAY BEFORE. HIGHER
EDUCATION. NOW IS ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES SAYS IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHERE YOU WHERE YOU
LIVE. IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
YOUR ZIP CODE IS. IN OUR CASE
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION SYSTEM.
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE SOME
SERIOUS RACIAL DISPARITIES. AND
SOME OF US HAVE ADVOCATED FOR
REFORMS THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
DEAL WITH THAT VERY ISSUE. THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING NEW. NINE
MINORITY STUDENTS. STOOD UP AND
BROUGHT A LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF
THESE PROBLEMS IN OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. AND THIS
STATE GOVERNMENT FOUGHT THEM
TOOTH AND NAIL IN THE REGARD
VERSUS- CALIFORNIA DECISION.
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN FOUGHT
THEM TOOTH AND NAIL. SAY NO
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THOSE
SYSTEMS IN PLACE. AND THE
AUTHOR OF THIS LEGISLATION
BROUGHT HER OWN LEGISLATION
SAYING WE ARE GOING TO CHANGE
TENURE FOR EXAMPLE. AND THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY KILLED THAT
LEGISLATION. THE CHANGES THAT
MINORITY STUDENTS ARE BRINGING
TO US SAYING PLEASE CHANGE
THESE THINGS. THE GIVE US
BETTER OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE IT
SO THAT IT'S NOT WHERE IS IT
CODE IS THAT IS NOT MY RACE.
THE DETERMINES MY SUCCESS IN MY
ABILITY TO GET AN EDUCATION THE
THINGS THAT THEY BROUGHT TO US
THIS BODY. KILLED IN THIS IN
THIS IN THIS BUILDING DESPITE
THE EFFORTS OF A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN THIS ROOM. BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THE MAJORITY SAID NO.
SO IT'S A LOT DEEPER. THEN JUST
TALKING ABOUT PROP TWO OH NINE.
IT'S TALKIN ABOUT A FIRST IN
FIRST OUT POLICY THT WE HAVE
FOR TEACHERS. IS TALKING ABOUT
IN LA UNIFIED IN THAT TRIAL.
EXPERT WITNESSES TESTIFIED. THE
BLACK AND LATINO STUDENTS WERE.
MANY TIMES OVER PERCENTAGE WAS
LIKELY. TO BE TAUGHT BY A
TEACHER IN THE 5% EFFECTIVENESS
RATE THIRTY SECOND LOWEST 5%
I'LL GIVE YOU THE STATS AFRICAN
AMERICANS AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS WERE 43% MORE LIKELY
THAN WHITE STUDENTS TO BE
TAUGHT BY A TEACHER IN THE
BOTTOM FIVE PERCENT. LATINO
STUDENTS ARE 68% MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE A TEACHER IN THE BOTTOM 5%
OF EFFECTIVENESS IN LA UNIFIED
THAT'S THE PROBLEM. AND THAT'S
IN THAT IS SHOWING ITSELF. ALL
THE WAY UP AND WAY BEFORE WE
GET TO HIGHER EDUCATION WAY
BEFORE WE GET TO ADMISSIONS. SO
THIS BODY NEEDS A START DOING
THINGS ABOUT THIS AND IT'S HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY. AND DON'T TELL
ME TODAY THAT IS TWO OH NINE IF
YOU'RE NOT ON BOARD WAS GET RID
A TWO OH NINE YOU'RE NOT ABOUT
TRYING TO GET EQUITY IN
EDUCATION BECAUSE THERE'S A
WHOLE LOT MORE THAT WE NEED TO
DO. PLEASE CAN WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT IN THIS
SPOT. AND I WOULD SAY LET'S
HAVE LET'S CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION IS MUCH NEEDED IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN. IT SHOULDN'T
TAKE WHAT'S HAPPENED. FOR US TO
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS BUT
LET'S LET'S REALLY GET TO THE
ROOT CAUSES OF WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH EDUCATION THE RACIAL
DISPARITIES WERE SEEN IN THIS
COUNTRY I'M READY TO WORK ON
THOSE ISSUES BUT I CAN'T
SUPPORT. WHAT'S A COVER UP OF
THOSE ISSUES OF THE SAME WHAT'S
ABOUT TO AN IRA LET'S ELIMINATE
THAT LET'S GET TO THE ROOT.
CAUSES OF THIS ISSUE THANK YOU
MEMBERS THERE WAS GALLAGHER MR
MCCARTY IN THE REAR CHAMBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER YOU KNOW IT
REALLY IS TIME FOR THIS
CONVERSATION. I'VE BEEN WAITING
TO VOTE ON THIS FOR AGAIN FOR
TWENTY FOUR YEARS. I'VE
AWAITING A VOTE ON THIS AS AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SINCE THE DAY I
GOT ELECTED SIX YEARS AGO I
KNEW IT'S TIME. CON I THINK
IT'S ABOUT I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE
FROM IS NICOLAS JUST NORTH OF
MY DISTRICT. HAS STRONG
OPINIONS AS WELL. YOU KNOW WHAT
WE HAVE EIGHTY OPINIONS HERE
THERE ARE NEARLY TWENTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO DESERVE A
RIGHT TO WEIGH IN ON THIS. AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ENCINO SAID.
MAYBE ONCE IN A GENERATION
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA TO ENGAGE
ON SOMETHING SO IMPORTANT.
WHICH ALSO I FIND. AN ACHE. AND
SOMEWHAT HYPOCRITICAL IS THIS
MEASURE BEFORE WAS LET'S PUT ON
BY A VOTE OF THE PEOPLE. KNOWS
AGAINST US. DON'T ASK TO HAVE A
VOTE. SO WASN'T LEGISLATURE
THAT PUT THIS POLICY THE FACT
IT WAS THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. THEY GOT A CHANCE
TO VOTE ON IT AT THE BALLOT. SO
WHY NOT JUST LET US HAVE
ANOTHER CHANCE TO GO OUT AGAIN.
YOU KNOW I WANT TO FOCUS ON A
FEW SECONDS OF WHAT THIS. BILL
AND THIS MEASURE BEFORE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WON'T DO.
IT WON'T BRING QUOTAS AROUND
AND YOU HERE THE RHETORIC.
ABOUT WHAT IT WILL DO AND
THAT'S JUST FLAT OUT FALSE THE
SUPREME COURT. RULED ON THAT
AND YOU KNOW THAT'S THE LEGAL
IT WON'T HAPPEN. IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE KNOW IT WON'T HAPPEN IN.
WITH OUR UC ADMISSIONS WE KNOW
THAT THAT WAS NOT THE POLICY.
THIS STATES THAT RACE WILL BE A
CONSIDERATION A FACTOR. AND I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT SOME REAL.
IMPLICATIONS FOR ARE THINGS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO FOCUS IN
CALIFORNIA. HIGHER EDUCATION
COLLEGE ACCESS. TO OUR SCHOOLS.
THROUGH THE WITH REGARD TO YOU.
ALL OF. THEY'VE REFORM THEIR
ADMISSIONS POLICIES OVER THE
LAST FIFTEEN TWENTY YEARS AFTER
PROP TWO NINE. THE REPEAL PROP
THREE FIELD THE MEASURES. WITH
SP ONE FIFTEEN YEARS AGO. WE
NOW HAVE COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW.
PUBLIC REVIEW OF CASES WITH A
LOOK AT ALL THESE FACTORS AND
SO. THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE
THIS QUARTER SYSTEM IN PLACE.
REALLY CHANGING THE PROCESS HOW
TO GET THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WE NOW HAVE. THE TAX
AS FAR AS I ELIGIBLE THE LOCAL
CONTEXT IF YOU'RE IN YOUR- RAP.
A LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL YOU GET A
MINUTE. FOR THAT THERE'S NOT
GONNA BE QUITE AS WHO GETS IN
AND WHO DOESN'T FOR YOU SEE.
BUT THIS WHAT THIS WILL DO
IT'LL SEND A HUGE MASSES AS FAR
AS WELCOMING TO UC CAMPUSES.
AFRICAN AMERICAN ROME IS ABOUT
4% UC CAMPUSES. IN LARGE PART
BECAUSE THERE'S A BIG NOT NOT
WELCOME SIGN. WE HAVE A TALENT
DRAIN THAT GOES TO SCHOOLS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. EAST COAST
SCHOOLS TO HISTORICALLY BLACK
COLLEGES ACROSS THE SOUTH.
TALENT LEAVES CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WE HAVE A ON WELCOME
SIGN AND FORTUNATELY. SO THIS
WILL SEND A MESSAGE THAT
CALIFORNIA ONCE AND VALUES
EVERYBODY BECAUSE WE NEED
EVERYBODY TO SIXTY. WE HAVE TWO
MILLION COLLEGE GRADUATES IN
CALIFORNIA FILL THE JOBS OF
TODAY AND TOMORROW WE NEED MORE
PEOPLE GRADUATING FROM COLLEGE
OF ALL OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
THROUGHOUT. SO WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN THAT MEANS HAVING FACULTY
THAT REFLECT OUR COMMUNITY.
THEY ARE RIGHT NOW WITH HIGHER
DO FACULTY AT UC AND CSU
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. REYES CAN'T
BE A CONSIDERATION. THIS WILL
CERTAINLY MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
AS MY COLLEAGUE TO MEET
NICHOLAS AS WE DO HAVE PROBLEMS
WITH HIGHER EDUCATION
ACHIEVEMENT WE HAVE THE-
GRADUATION RATES FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS. FOR BROWN TO BLACK
STUDENTS IS NOT THE SAME AS IT
IS FOR OTHERS SO WHAT WITH THIS
ALLOWS TO DO. HAVE RACE BASED
REMEDIES THAT WE KNOW WORK
RIGHT NOW THOSE ARE ILLEGAL AND
THEIR THEIR THE MANY THE
CAMPUSES ARE AFRAID OF BEING
SUED. SO THEY CAN'T GO AND MAKE
A DIFFERENCE AND HOW WILL THAT
HELP S THAT WOULD MEAN MORE
PEOPLE GETTING OUT OF THE UC
AND CSU IN FOUR YEARS. BRING UP
SPOTS FOR ALL OF THE BROTHER
CALIFORNIANS AND DEALING WITH
OUR NEEDS AS FAR AS- HIGHER
EDUCATION GRADUATES BILL THE
JOBS IT TODAY. FOR K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS MY COLLEAGUES SAN DIEGO
THE AUTHOR IS MEASURE MINUS
LAST YEAR THE BLACK MINDS
MATTER WE HAD TREMENDOUS
RESEARCH TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE
CAN DO TO ADDRESS THE
ACHIEVEMENT OPPORTUNITY GAP WE
GIVE OUT MONIES FOR ELSE YET
THAT FORMULATION BASED UPON HI
NEAT. ANYTIME SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COME UP WITH COME UP WITH THE
REMEDIES BUT THEY CAN'T
IMPLEMENT THEIR PROGRAMS
BECAUSE- THEY CAN'T FOCUS ON
RACE AND EVEN KNOW THEY KNOW
THOSE PROGRAMS WOULD BE PROPER
INTERVENTIONS TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. SO WE KNOW THAT
EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
REMEDIES AND SOLUTIONS WE CAN
ALWAYS FOCUS ON THE BECAUSE
WERE HELD BACK BECAUSE OF PROP
TWO NINE. THIS WILL ALLOW US TO
GO THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA TO
WEAR. WHAT MANY PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. MY FAMILY
MY FATHER GOT HIS FIRST JOB
HERE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS
AN ATTORNEY RIGHT DOWN THE
STREET THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND HE GOT AN
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION POLICY. AND
MANY PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
DONE THE SAME AND FOR THE LAST
TWENTY FOUR YEARS WE ELIMINATE
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES FOR SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS. AND WE KNOW THIS
ISN'T IT I SEE. I HOPE WITH
PASSES I'M GONNA BUT FOR TODAY
UP THE VOTERS. WEIGH IN AS WELL
IN A FEW MONTHS THIRTY SECONDS
THERE ARE STATES ACROSS OUR
NATION THAT HAVE THESE POLICIES
AND THEY HAVE THEIR TROUBLES TO
THE WHAT THIS SAYS IS THAT RACE
DOESN'T MATTER. AND GOVERNMENT
POLICY ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES
AND ACKNOWLEDGING RACIAL
INEQUALITY IT'S IMPORTANT STEP
CALIFORNIA TAKE TO TAKE UP.
THANK YOU JUST BE. THANK YOU.
MS CALL SILVA. YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS MEMBERS WE'VE HEARD A
LOT ON THE FLOOR TODAY ABOUT A
CA FIVE AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU.
I WAS HERE IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
WHEN THIS CONVERSATION CAME UP
AND IT WAS QUITE A CONVERSATION
THERE WAS NOT AN AGREEMENT AND
IT ACTUALLY CAUSED QUITE A BIT
OF I THINK FROM FRUSTRATION. TO
THE AUTHOR DR SHIRLEY WEBER
BECAUSE WE COULD NOT GET THAT
UP ON THE FLOOR IT WAS ACTUALLY
TABLE. AND NOW IN TWENTY TWENTY
WE STAND HERE WITH THIS ON THE
FLOOR. AND I DID WASN'T READY
TO JUMP IN AS I'VE SAID A FEW
TIMES ON THIS FLOOR THESE ARE
DIFFICULT VOTES THESE ARE TOUGH
VOTES AND IN MY DISTRICT I'VE
SEEN MORE THAN A FEW TIMES.
WHEN YOU TAKE A VOTE THERE'S A
CONSEQUENCE. AND I HAVE
RECEIVED MANY MANY HUNDREDS OF
LETTERS TO SAY DO NOT SUPPORT A
CA FIVE MATTER FACT THE LEADING
OF. PERSON IN MY DISTRICT WROTE
THESE DON'T VOTE ON A CA FIVE
THAT IS A RACIST POLICY. I
RECEIVED MANY. RESPONSES SAYING
THIS LETS PEOPLE GET AHEAD OF
SOMEONE ELSE WHEN THEY DON'T
DESERVE IT. BUT I'M GONNA
QUICKLY SHARE A FEW OF MY
STORIES IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
I WAS THIRTY TWO YEARS OLD WITH
THREE YOUNG CHILDREN SEVEN
YEARS OLD SIX YEARS OLD AND A
THREE YEAR OLD AND A CLASSROOM
TEACHER I HAD BEEN TEACHING FOR
ALMOST TEN YEARS BY THAT TIME
AND RIGHT AFTER PROP TWO NINE I
WENT BACK TO THE CLASSROOM. AND
ARE BILINGUAL PROGRAMS WERE
DISMANTLED. SO WITH IN A SHORT
FEW MONTHS. CHILDREN THAT WERE
IN BILINGUAL PROGRAMS. THAT
WERE LEARNING THAT WAY THOSE
PROGRAMS WERE DISMANTLED WE HAD
BEEN TRAINED IN VARIOUS
PRACTICES THROUGH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THEY WERE JUST
RACED. WITH THAT BEING SAID IF
YOU WERE A PERSON OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
ORANGE COUNTY FULLER TEN WE
WERE TRACKED WE WERE TRAPPED
RIGHT INTO BILINGUAL PROGRAMS
WHETHER WE WERE BI LINGUAL OR
NOT. AND THAT MEANT USUALLY NOT
AN OPTION FOR COLLEGE I WAS THE
FIRST IN MY FAMILY TO GO TO
COLLEGE BUT MANY OF MY
COUNSELORS IN HIGH SCHOOL. DID
YOU EVEN THINK THAT I WAS A
CANDIDATE. AS I CAME FROM A
FAMILY OF TEN AND UP NOBODY IN
MY FAMILY HAD BEEN TO COLLEGE
BEFORE BUT THE POINT IS THAT WE
WERE OFTEN DISCOUNTED HOUSING
POLICIES IN MY AREA LATINO
FAMILY OWNS WORK UP PUSHED INTO
ONE NEIGHBORHOOD. AND THAT WAS
A POLICY AT THAT TIME SO WHEN
WE LOOK TO NOW WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THIS POLICY THERE IS A
HUGE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN EQUITY.
AND EQUALITY AND THAT IS SO
HARD FOR PEOPLE. THEY REALLY
WANT EVERYTHING TO BE FAIR. BUT
AS WE KNOW EVERYTHING IS NOT
FAIR AND THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT
HERE SO WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO
THE NORTH I DO AGREE WE HAVE AN
MUCH CHANGE THAT THAT NEEDS TO
BE MADE PUBLIC EDUCATION WE ARE
FAILING SOME OF OUR STUDENTS
AND THAT IS WHY. AS A LOCAL
ELECTED I STARTED THE CHIEF
MEANT GAP CONVERSATION THAT TEN
YEARS AGO WE WOULDN'T EVEN
RESPOND TO THERE WAS NO CHIEF
IT MAKE GAP WHICH WE KNOW IS
NOT TRUE SO I STAND HERE AS
SOMEONE THAT YOU JUST HAD TO BE
PUSHED A LITTLE BIT. TO GET
HERE BUT DOCTOR ARE ALWAYS HAS
THAT EFFECT ON ME SHE KNOWS
THAT I'M ALWAYS GOING TO GET
THERE BUT- THESE ARE DEEPLY
VOTES AND I'VE STOOD STILL I
HAVE. BEEN ON THIS FOR MORE
THAN A FEW TIMES THAT HAVE SAID
SOMETIMES YOU GOT TO TAKE A
HARD VOTE. AT IT'S NOT EASY BUT
I WON'T DO THAT BECAUSE IT
MEANS SO MUCH TO SO MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES AND THE MORE WE
INCREASE. THE VALUE TO OUR
PEOPLE OF COLOR BLACK. LATINO
STUDENTS ALL ETHNICITIES WE ALL
RICE SO I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR A SEE A FIVE. THANK YOU MS
QUIRK SILVA MISTER GARCIA THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I'M MOVED AND
MOTIVATED TO STAND UP AND RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AC A FIVE AND
THANK THE- AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE DOCTOR WEBER. WHO I
THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE AS A
LEADER. IN CIVIL RIGHTS AND
WHAT'S RIGHT FOR ALL PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US TOGETHER ON THIS
ISSUE LET ME JUST SAY THAT IF I.
YOU KNOW WE RECOGNIZE THE
THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON IN
THIS COUNTRY THE PROTESTS THAT
WERE SEEN. THE UPROAR ABOUT
RACE AND POLICE AND COMMUNITY
RELATIONS- THAT IF WE TRULY
STAND WITH THE IDEA THAT BLACK
LIVES MATTER DAN THIS ACTION
TODAY- SHOULD MATTER TO YOU AND
YOU WOULD VOTE YES ON AC FIVE
MEN YOU KNOW A FIVE. YEAR GOAL.
THIS COMEY MONTEZ OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM HIGHLAND THE FIRST
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN TO
BE ELECTED TO THIS BODY REMINDS
US OF THE APOLOGY THAT WE'VE-
MADE TO CALIFORNIA NATIVES. FOR
GLOBAL OF HISTORY FIRST
GOVERNOR OF THIS STATE.
IMPOSING EXTERMINATION POLICIES
IN FUNDING MALICIOUS TO GO
AFTER CALIFORNIA NATIVES TO
EXTERMINATE THEM AND WE
APOLOGIZE LAST YEAR IF THAT
MATTERED LAST YEAR AN- AND IF
BLACK LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT AND
WHAT'S HAPPENING TODAY MATTER
TO YOU THEN VOTING YES ON A CA
FIVE IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO
IT FIVE WE RECOGNIZE THAT IN
THE TRAGIC RACISM. AND DIVISION
OF THIS THE STATE'S HISTORY
WITH POLICIES LIKE ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN AND- WHAT WERE
DELIBERATING HERE TILL NINE AND
TWO TWO SEVEN AND- THE REPEAL
OF- THIS MEASURE IS IMPORTANT.
TO CHANGE ALL THAT THEN YOU
WOULD VOTE ON A CA FIVE I THINK
YOU KNOW FOLKS HAVE SAID TODAY.
THAT THE WE ARE MANY OF US ARE
PRODUCTS OF THESE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN GIVEN TO US I IS
A PROUD CHICANO FROM THE
COACHELLA VALLEY FIRST
GENERATION AMERICAN BORN- YOU
KNOW I'M VERY PROUD OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT I'VE-
RECEIVED AND- THREE FOR SECOND
CHANCES THAT HAVE BEEN GIVEN TO
ME. TO BE ABLE TO SERVE THIS
BODY BUT IT HAS COME BY YOU
KNOW NO JUST THE EASY PATH. AND
THE SACRIFICES OF MANY OTHER
PEOPLE ARE BEFORE US AND BEHIND
US THAT OF OPENED UP THESE
PADS. FOR US TO SERVE IN THIS
BODY AND SO I JUST WANT TO
REMIND US IN. IN THE TIME THAT
WE BRAIN AND YESTERDAY AS A
BODY WE- ACKNOWLEDGE THE TERM
ALL THAT IS. TAKING PLACE IN
OUR COUNTRY AND IN OUR STATE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES- WITH. A BLACK
PEOPLE BEING PERSECUTED BY. YOU
KNOW BAD COPS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES- BROWN PEOPLE-
BEING PERSECUTED BY BAD POPS IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND NOW LOOKING
THAT THIS. EFFORT TO. ENSURE
THAT INSTITUTIONALIZED RACISM.
IS A RADIC HEATED TO ENSURE
THAT YES THEN WE CAN TALK ABOUT
EQUALITY FOR ALL BUT RIGHT NOW
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
GIVING CALIFORNIANS AN
OPPORTUNITY A TWO WAY ON THIS A
WEIGH IN ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE- WHICH IS AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION TO MAKE SURE THAT- WE
READ A CAKE YOU KNOW SEXISM.
RACISM AND THE EXCLUSION OF
CALIFORNIANS AT ALL LEVELS OF
THE PROFESSIONAL- SPECTRUM AND
DIE JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR OF THE MEASURE
FOR INTRODUCING A CA FIVE.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA I SEE MISS
KAMLAGER IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER THIS KAMLAGER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT. OF
AC EIGHT FIVE. YOU KNOW YOU SEE
A FIVE WAS. A PERNICIOUS TACTIC.
TO PICK REYES AGAINST REYES.
ETHNICITY AGAINST ETHNICITY.
GENDER AGAINST GENDER. IT WAS
DONE TO BREED DESCENT. CONTEMPT.
TO DEFAME PEOPLE'S DIGNITY. IT
FALSELY PRESUMES. THAT YOUR
ACCESS AND YOUR OPPORTUNITY IS
EQUAL BECAUSE YOUR
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE EQUAL. AND WE
KNOW THAT THAT'S A LIE. THAT IS
A LIE. AND TO CLING TO THAT
LINE. IS TO ABDICATE. THE MORAL
WORK THAT WE HAVE TO DO. TO
CONFRONT. THE HISTORY OF THIS
COUNTRY. IT IS OKAY TO TALK
ABOUT THE FACT THAT NOT
EVERYONE WAS BORN UNDER THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE. IT IS NOT OKAY.
TO DENY. ACCESS OPPORTUNITY A
SPACE BECAUSE OF THAT. IT'S SO
MUCH EASIER TO PAY SOMEONE
AGAINST SOMEONE ELSE. THEN IT
IS TO GET HONEST AND
UNCOMFORTABLE ABOUT THE WORK
THAT WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US.
KING SAID. EVERY SOCIETY. HAS
ITS PROTECTORS OF THE STATUS
QUO. AND ITS FRATERNITIES OF
THE IN DIFFERENT. WHO ARE
NOTORIOUS FOR SLEEPING THROUGH
REVOLUTION. OUR SURVIVAL.
DEPENDS ON US STAYING AWAKE.
STEPPING UP TO THE TASK.
REMAINING VIGILANT AND FACING
THE CHALLENGE OF CHANGE
COLLEAGUES WE ARE IN A SEASON
OF CHANGE. WE ARE IN A
REVOLUTION OF CHANGE. LET'S NOT
SLEEP THROUGH THIS. LET'S NOT
LET NOVEMBER COME. AND FORCE.
CALIFORNIANS TO SLEEP THROUGH
THIS THE COMBUSTION IN THIS
COUNTRY THE COMBUSTION IN THIS
STATE. IS A TESTAMENT TO FOLKS
SAYING I DON'T WANT TO LIVE
THIS LIFE ANYMORE. I'M AWAKE
THAT'S WHY I'LL BE VOTING FOR A
CA FIVE. AND I ASK THAT YOU ALL
VOTE FOR IT TOO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS KAMLAGER MISTER
GIBSON. IN THE REAR CHAMBER
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE AS A PROUD TO JOINT
AUTHORED AC A FIVE I THANK THE
AUTHOR FROM SAN DIEGO FOR HER
FIGHT. HER COURAGE TO BRING US
ALL TOGETHER TO HAVE THIS BUS
CONVERSATION ON THIS MEASURE.
COVERT NINETEEN DID MORE TO
EXPAND THE SCALE OF CRISIS THAT
PEOPLE OF COLOR HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATE FACED IN THIS
GENERATION. PEOPLE OF COLOR
HAVE DISPROPORTIONATELY FACE
EXCESSIVE DISCRIMINATION
LEADING TO THE LACK OF ACCESS
TO QUALITY EDUCATION JOBLESS
AND HOMELESS. WITHOUT JUST
LOOKING THE OTHER WAY. WE HAVE
THE CHANCE NOW TO REIMAGINE.
THE SCOPE. OF EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
AND ON ROUTE A SYSTEM THAT IS
UNFAIR. THAT IS DENIED WOMEN.
PEOPLE OF COLOR. FAIR A FAIR
SHOT. OF SUCCESS WITHOUT
LOOKING THE OTHER WAY WE HAVE
THE CHANCE TO RESTORE THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM. THAT DREAM IS
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL. THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM IS FOR
EVERYONE BUT- THE DEVIL. ME OF
AND JUSTICE AND A HISTORY OF
DISCRIMINATION IS SITTING ON
THE NECK. ALL THE HARD WORK OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT NEED IN AN
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD. HEY CA FIVE
FOCUS ON WHAT MUST BE MADE
RIGHT IN PUBLIC CONTRACTING.
HIRING AND EDUCATION ACA FIVE
WOULD RESTORE AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION AND PUBLIC CONTRACTING
HIRING EDUCATION THREE AREAS
IMPORTANT TO REBUILD THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM OF EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL AC A FIVE
WOULD RESTORE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
SO THAT WE CAN SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE THE
LIFEBLOOD OF OUR COMMUNITY. HEY
CA FIVE WOULD GIVE OUR LEADERS
THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO HELP THE
MOST. AMONG US IN OUR COMMUNITY.
ACA FIVE WOULD GIVE US THE
CHANCE TO HIRE MORE WOMEN.
INVEST IN MORE SMALL BUSINESSES
AND PROVIDE GOOD FAMILY
SUPPORTING JOBS. ACA FIVE. IS
OUR CHANCE TO REBUILD
CALIFORNIA. THAT ACTUALLY
REFLECT THE VALUES AND THE
DIVERSITY OF THIS STATE. ACA
FIVE STANDS ON THE PRINCIPLE OF
AN EXCLUSION AND WILL RESTORE
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION TO HELP OUR
STATE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.MEMBERS I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME AND
PUSHING THE GREEN BUTTON. I
WOULD ASK YOU TO JOIN ME. IN
WRITING A NEW CHAPTER IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY. MEMBERS I
WOULD INVITE YOU TO JOIN ME AND
OTHERS. IN REFLECTING ON OUR
PATH AND CHARTING A NEW ARE
PASS IT ALSO CHARTED A NEW
COURSE FOR THE NEXT GENERATION.
MEMBERS I INVITE YOU TO DO THE
RIGHT THING. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOU AYE VOTE ON A CA. FIVE
THANK YOU MISS GIVE SAID. MR
MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. ARE
WE ON WELL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- WASN'T SURE I WAS
GONNA STAND UP BUT TODAY TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK ON THIS- VICTOR
WASN'T SURE WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP
ISSUES LIKE LIKE THIS- BECAUSE
OF COVERT ABOUT YOU'RE GOING TO
DEAL WITH MOSTLY COVERED
RELATED- LATED ITEMS AND HAD A
CONVERSATION JUST LAST WEEK
WITH OF THE AUTHOR AND SHE SAID
HEY CHAD WHERE YOU OUT AN ACA
FIVE AND I SAID HA. WHAT'S THAT.
NOAH AND WE HAD A LITTLE BIT OF
A- OF A CONVERSATION I SAID MY
SAID TO THE AUTHOR GIVE ME. THE
WEEKEND LET ME SPEND A LITTLE
BIT TIME DIGGING IN AND- AND
I'VE I'VE GONE FROM- THINKING I
WASN'T EASY NO. TO BEING A HARD
YES TO. THE I DON'T KNOW. A TO
BE HONEST WITH YOU. OVER THE
WEEKEND I READ THE LANGUAGE OF
PROP TWO OH NINE IF IT'S OKAY
MISTER SPEAKER I JUST WANT TO
READ THE FIRST PARAGRAPH WHICH
IS REALLY THE HEART OF THE- OF
THE PROPOSITION IS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SAYS THE STATE SHALL
NOT DISCRIMINATE AGAINST OR
GRANT PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT TO
ANY INDIVIDUAL GROUP ON THE
BASIS OF RACE SEX. COLOR
ETHNICITY OR NATIONAL ORIGIN IN
THE OPERATION OF PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT PUBLIC EDUCATION OR
PUBLIC CONTRACTING. SO I'M FOR
FORTY THREE YEARS OLD IT'S HARD
FOR ME TO SAY THAT NOW BECAUSE
I'VE ALWAYS THOUGHT ABOUT ME
BEING THE YOUNG GUY IN THE
ROOM- SO I WASN'T I'M NOT FORTY
ONE- IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX I
WOULD HAVE BEEN. A NINETEEN
YEARS OLD AND I AM. ALMOST
CERTAIN THAT WHEN I WAS
NINETEEN YEARS OLD I VOTED IN
FAVOR OF THAT LANGUAGE BECAUSE
WHERE I COME FROM I WANTED TO
BELIEVE I STILL WANT TO
BELIEVE- THAT WE LIVE IN A
COLOR BLIND A WORLD- AND THAT
WE- THERE IS EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL I WANTED TO BELIEVE
LIKE. ALL OF YOU HEARD ME SING
A FEW YEARS AGO OF THE- THE
COURSE THAT WE SAYING WHEN I
WAS IN. IN IN SUNDAY SCHOOL RED
AND YELLOW BLACK AND WHITE THEY
ARE PRECIOUS IN HIS SIGHT THAT
WE ARE ALL EQUAL WANT TO LEAVE
AT THEN I VOTED FOR IT THAT.
THAT IS ALMOST TWENTY. YEARS
AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHERE AT
WHERE WE'RE AT TODAY AS A
SOCIETY IF WE ARE HONEST WITH
OURSELVES. RACE DOES MATTER.
WE'RE BEYOND FIFTY YEARS PASSED
THE NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT AND THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE I DID WASN'T CUTTING GROUP
GROPE IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT ALL OF
THAT WAS WAS ALL ABOUT I WAS
BORN IN THE LATE SEVENTIES AND
FOR ME I DIDN'T SEE ALL OF
THOSE THOSE THINGS. BUT WHEN I
WAS NINETEEN I HAD HOPED THAT
WE HAD GOTTEN BEYOND ALL OF
THAT AND THE TRUTH IS TWENTY
FIVE YEARS LATER IT IS VERY
CLEAR THAT WE HAVE WE ARE NOT
BEYOND THAT AND THE FACT IS IT
HAS BEEN. A GENERATION. BEFORE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE HAD THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO STAND UP.
AND PINE ON THIS. AND I THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THIS BODY
FROM TIME TO TIME LOOKING AT
OUR STATE CONSTITUTION. TO PUT
THOSE QUESTIONS BACK BEFORE THE
VOTERS AND SAY IS THIS STILL
WHAT YOU WANT. TO BE IN YOUR
CONSTITUTION. AND FOR THAT
REASON I THINK IT IS MORE THAN
APPROPRIATE FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO SEND THIS ACA FIVE TO BE
ABLE TO GET ON THE BALLOT. IN
NOVEMBER AND ASK THIS QUESTION
OF WHERE THE CALIFORNIANS WANT
TO MOVE IN THE FUTURE. IF WE
JUST LISTEN AND I GUESS IS THE
OTHER THING THAT I WOULD WANT
TO SAY IS WE'VE BEEN OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS WE'VE
WE'VE SEEN THIS EVERYONE SAYS-
I'VE GOT THE ANSWERS BECAUSE
WHEN I WAS NINETEEN YEARS OLD I
HAD ALL THE ANSWERS YOU HAVE
ASKED ME THEN I WAS THE
SMARTEST GUY THAT I KNEW- STE
SOME OF YOU MIGHT ACTUALLY SAY
THAT CHECK GIVEN CHANGE MUCH.
FROM A BUT- BUT WHAT I REALIZE
IS THAT WE DON'T HAVE ALL THE
ANSWERS I DON'T HAVE ALL THE
ANSWERS BUT WHEN YOU LISTEN TO
ONE ANOTHER AND YOU LEARN FROM
ONE ANOTHER YOU TRULY LISTEN TO
ONE ANOTHER. LIKE AT THE TONE
OF THE CONVERSATION TODAY. YOUR
REALIZE THE PERSPECTIVE THAT WE
ALL HAVE- ARE VALUABLE. AND I
WOULD SAY AS THE MAJORITY OF
HIS BODY HAS SAID AND I BELIEVE
IT'S GONNA BE SUPER MAJORITIES
BODIES SAID. IT'S TIME TO GO
BACK AND LOOK AT THIS TIME TO
GIVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO THE TO
OPINE ON THIS. AND FOR THAT
REASON I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT
TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER MAYES.
MISTER MURATSUCHI. YOUR
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU I WANT TO
START OFF BY SAYING THAT- I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE DIVERSITY
OF PERSPECTIVES THAT ARE. BEING
REPRESENTED IN OUR DISCUSSION
TODAY YOU KNOW I WOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED IF WE ARE THE MOST.
DIVERSE STATE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY. AND I. I
THINK WE TRULY BENEFIT. FROM
THIS DIVERSITY OF PERSPECTIVES.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IT WAS
ONE OF THE- FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES UNDERLYING
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. TO ENSURE
THE RICHNESS OF. DEBATE OF CA
OF CONVERSATIONS ESPECIALLY A
PUBLIC CONVERSATIONS BY HAVING
SUCH A BROAD RANGE OF
PERSPECTIVES. BEING REPRESENTED.
I WANT TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES IN
ACKNOWLEDGING THE MOMENT THAT
WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW. I THINK A-
YOU KNOW RECENT EVENTS ARE
CLEARLY SHOWN THAT THE
CORONAVIRUSES HAD A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES.
THE MURDER OF GEORGE FLOYD
ANOTHER YOUNG BLACK MEN IS
CLEARLY SHOWED. THAT WE STILL
LIVE IN A RACIST AND SEXIST
SOCIETY. AND I WOULD AGREE WITH
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
TALKED ABOUT HOW RACE STILL
MATTERS GENDER SO MATTERS. AND
THAT WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THIS REALITY. BY OPENLY
CONSIDERING RATHER THAN
PRETENDING. THAT WE LIVE IN A
COLOR BLIND AND GENDER NEUTRAL
SOCIETY THAT WE DO NEED TO
OPENLY. CONSIDER RACE AND
GENDER. BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THE VOICES THAT ALL VOICES
ARE HEARD IN THIS DEBATE AND I
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE VOICES.
AND THE ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY THAT HAVE NOT. BEEN
DONE JUSTICE IN OUR
CONVERSATION THUS FAR AND SO I
WANT TO. RAISE A VOICE FOR.
MANY NOT ALL BECAUSE THE ASIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IS EXTREMELY
DIVERSE. BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR VOICES ARE
HEARD IN THIS DEBATE. ASIAN
AMERICANS EVEN DURING THIS
CORONA VIRUS PANDEMIC I MEAN WE
HAVE EXPERIENCED RACISM WE HAVE
BEEN ATTACKED. THE VICTIMS OF
MORE HATE CRIMES BECAUSE OF OUR
PRESIDENT THAT CALLS THIS. THE
WUHAN VIRUS THE CHINESE VIRUS.
THAT A JAPANESE GUY LIKE ME IS
GETTING ATTACKED OR YOU KNOW AT
RISK OF BEING ATTACKED BECAUSE
IN THE EYES OF SO MANY
AMERICANS WE ALL LOOK THE SAME.
ASIAN AMERICAN THIS IS JUST THE
LATEST EXAMPLE OF HOW ASIAN
AMERICANS ARE NOT. IMMUNE FROM
RACISM HERE AND NOW AND OF
COURSE ASIAN AMERICAN WOMEN.
ARE JUST AS MUCH VICTIMS OF
SEXISM. IF NOT MORE. AND SO
THAT IS THE REASON WHY. THE
MAJORITY OF ASIAN AMERICANS
SUPPORT AFFIRMATIVE ACTION BUT
WE SUPPORT AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
AT THE SAME TIME WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S- DONE IN A
WAY THAT DOESN'T DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS THAT
DOESN'T UNFAIRLY. LIMIT OR
EXCLUDE. IN A MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. IN THE PRACTICE OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. ASIAN
AMERICANS ARE DIVERSE AMMANAI
AT THE RISK OF ENGAGING IN
STEREOTYPES A MAN WE HAVE A
WEALTHY RECENT IMMIGRANTS FROM
CHINA. WE HAVE FOURTH
GENERATION JAPANESE AMERICANS
LIVING IN MIDDLE CLASS SUBURBS
WE HAVE COLLEGE EDUCATED
KOREANS AND SOUTH ASIAN
IMMIGRANTS WORKING IN GROCERY
STORES THIRTY SECONDS. AND YET
THE ONE THING THAT BRINGS ALL
ASIAN AMERICANS TOGETHER IS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF EDUCATION AS
YOU KNOW THE TICKET FOR OUR
CHILDREN TO ACHIEVE THE
AMERICAN DREAM. THERE IS A
WIDELY HELD PERCEPTION AMONG
MANY ASIANS THAT WE HAVE TO
WORK HARDER AND GET BETTER
GRADES AND HIGHER TEST SCORES
TO GET INTO THE MOST
COMPETITIVE SCHOOLS IN OUR
COUNTRY. AND THAT. THAT
PERCEPTION CONTINUES TO GET
HAVE SOME SUPPORT. IN THE DATA
THAT I RECEIVED RECENTLY FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA I
MEAN ADMISSION RATES FOR ALL
GROUPS HAVE DROPPED BECAUSE THE
APPLICATIONS. HAVE DRAMATICALLY
INCREASED IN THE PAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS EVER SINCE PROP TWO
OH NINE PASS PLEASE INCLUDE.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS. IS
THAT. ASIAN AMERICANS JUST LIKE
ANYONE ELSE. WE ARE SEEKING
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY. WE WANT. TO
BE TREATED FAIRLY. AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION IF DONE RIGHT. IT IS TO
PROMOTE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND
DIVERSITY FOR ALL. AND SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU TO NOT ONLY SUPPORT
THE REPEAL OF PROPOSITION TWO
OR NINE. BUT TO MAKE SURE THAT
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. WORKS FOR
ALL COMMUNITIES AND THAT DOES
NOT. UNFAIRLY DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST ANYONE COMMUNITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI MISTER COOPER. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ACTUALLY
HADN'T PLANNED ON TALKING BUT I
AM VOTING TO SUPPORT OF ACA
FIVE I DON'T THINK THE MEMBER
FROM SAN DIEGO- SHOULD TAKES
THE EASY ROAD AND- I APPRECIATE
THAT BUT- IT'S DEFINITELY WORTH
DOING YOUR WHEN THE HARDWORKING
MEMBERS I KNOW- THE MILL MEMBER
FROM SAN DIEGO WHEN HE SPOKE
AND IT REALLY TOUCHED ME WE
SAID HIS PARENTS TOLD THEM
LET'S NOT FOR YOU GOT WORK
TWICE AS HARD. MY MOM TOLD ME
THE SAME THING SO THINK ABOUT
THAT WHY WOULD APPEAR EVER TELL
THEIR CHILD THAT LIFE IS NOT
FAIR YOU HAVE TO WORK TWICE AS
HARD AS EVERYBODY ELSE I HAVE
FOUR DAUGHTERS I TOLD THE SAME
THING THAT'S REALITY PEOPLE
FACE IT'S INTERESTING TO THINK
ABOUT THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF
SIXTY FOUR VOTING RIGHTS ACT
THE SIXTY FIVE I WAS BORN IN
SIXTY FOUR A FIFTY SIX MY DOZEN
MILITARY IN FRANCE MY FAMILY'S
OVER THERE. AND HE HAD BEEN
ABLE TO VOTE BEFORE THEN. GOOD
MISSISSIPPI. COULDN'T VOTE. SO
IT'S CRAZY THINGS GO ON. IN
THINK A- THIS IS TO LET THE
VOTER VOTE. DOESN'T GET ANY
BETTER THAT WE'RE NOT THIS IS.
THEY'RE MAKING. IN A RICE TIDE
LIFTS ALL BOATS. WITH LOW ABOUT
BLACK PEOPLE EVERYBODY ELSE.
FOR THE API COMMUNITY SOUTHEAST
ASIANS LAWFUL ARE GOING TO
BENEFIT FROM THIS JUST TO HAVE
A CHANCE SO THINK ABOUT THAT A
RISING TIDE LIFTS ALL BOATS.
HOW MY FOUR DOLLARS HAVE A
CHANCE THEIR THEIR BLACK WOMEN.
AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT THIS FOR
THE PAST FOUR YEARS I'VE BEEN
THE PAY EQUITY BILL FOR WOMEN
IN THE LEGISLATURE. INITIALLY
THE BILL IS WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON IT NO FOR THE
BILL GETS THROUGH BUT WHO KNOWS
BUT WE KELLY CHART TELLS ME
COULD TAKE TEN YEARS. TO BRING
UP THE PAY OF WOMEN TO MEN. IN
STATE SERVICE THAT IS INSANE.
THAT IS FAR TOO LONG. THINK
ABOUT THAT TEN YEARS TO BRING
UP. IF YOU'RE FEMALE CHIEF IN
THIS BUILDING. YOU MAKE LESS
THAN MIL CHIEFS DO. WHY IS
THAT. I CAME FROM I REFER
COUNTY FOR THIRTY YEARS IN A
CITY FOR FIFTEEN. AND WHATEVER
THAT CLASSIFICATION WAS MADE
THE SAME PAY IN THAT JOB
DESCRIPTION HERE THE CAPITAL.
IT IS THE GOVERNMENT PAYS
EVERYWHERE THERE'S NO EQUITY IN
THE I THINK ABOUT THAT SO WILL
SEEING IT'S BEEN TOO LONG. WE
GOT A CHANGE THAT. IT'S
EXCELLENT IT'S TOUGH TO HAVE
DISCUSSION ON RACE. IS TOUGH
KNOWN IT MAKES PEOPLE
UNCOMFORTABLE OR TALK ABOUT IT.
I CAN'T CHANGE COLOR OF MY SKIN
I'M A BLACK MAN. BUT IT IS
SOMETHING FOR THE VOTERS. TO GO
VOTE SO I DON'T KNOW WHY.
ANYBODY WOULD BEGRUDGE THE
VOTERS TO MAKE A DECISION. THE
VOTE ON THIS TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO LET THEM VOTE ON IT NOW. IT
IS NOT A BIG DEAL JUST MAKES
SENSE. AND I REALLY BELIEVE. WE
ARE AT A WATERMARK IN SOCIETY
WITH THIS THERE'S SO MUCH
THAT'S GOING ON. IN TO JUST
BEING GATES IN OF ALL. PLACES
LAWMAKERS EVER ELECTED WE VOTE
ALL THE TIME TO MAKE DECISIONS
FOR CONSTITUENTS. BUT THIS IS
THE CHANCE WE GET TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS. MAKE THE CHOICE
LET THEM HAVE A CHOICE I
SUPPORT THIS AND URGES SUPPORT
A CA FIVE. THANK YOU MISS
COOPER MISS CARILLO. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBER SINCE THE
ELDER MILLENNIAL CAUCUSES IS
ADMITTING THEIR AGES I'LL SHARE
THAT I WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY I WILL BE FORTY IN
AUGUST. THE YEAR THAT I WAS
BORN IS THE YEAR THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BEGAN INVESTING
IN THE PRISON SYSTEM. IN TWO
YEARS PRIOR THROUGH PROP
THIRTEEN BEGAN THE PROCESS OF
THE FUNDING PUBLIC EDUCATION.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY. THE
STATE HAS BUILT MORE THAN
TWENTY NEW PRESENCE AND ONLY
THREE CS USE. IT IS MY
GENERATION OF STUDENTS. AND
THOSE THAT FOLLOWED THAT
HAPPENED FUNNELED THROUGH A
VERY REAL SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE. I ATTENDED ROOSEVELT
HIGH SCHOOL IN BOYLE HEIGHTS MY
HIGH SCHOOL HAD FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS THREE DIFFERENT
TRACKS. I HAVE SHARED IN THE
PAST THAT IN ELEVENTH GRADE I
DROPPED OUT. BUT IWAS LUCKY.
THAT I HAD THE SUPPORT OF MY
HIGH SCHOOL PRINCIPAL WHOM
WE'VE HONORED ON THIS FLOOR.
MISTRUST KEEL AND I WAS ABLE TO
GRADUATE ON TIME AND WITH MY
CLASS. IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
I PROBABLY WALKED SHRINE
AUDITORIUM IN LOS ANGELES AND
MY RED CAP AND GOWN. IT'S ONE
OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT MOMENT
OF MY ENTIRE LIFE. AT THE TIME
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT TWO YEARS
PRIOR WHEN I WAS JUST SIXTEEN.
THE VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT PASSED PROP TWO OH NINE.
REMOVING ANY OPPORTUNITY I
WOULD HAVE HAD IN ATTENDING THE
UNIVERSITY. I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT MEANT TO BE AN
IMMIGRANT TO BE FORMALLY
UNDOCUMENTED TO BE AN ENGLISH
LEARNER TO COME FROM A LOW
INCOME FAMILY OR WHAT IT MEANT
TO GROW UP IN A NEIGHBORHOOD
RIDDLED WITH GANG VIOLENCE AND
LACK OF OPPORTUNITIES AND JOBS.
AFTER GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL A
FEW YEARS LATER. I MADE MY WAY
THROUGH EAST LA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FEW YEARS LATER CAL
STATE LA. AND A FEW YEARS AFTER
THAT U. S. C. FOR GRAD SCHOOL.
IT WORKED THE ENTIRE TIME. AND
OFTEN PAID FOR BOOKS I DIDN'T
HAVE TIME TO READ. I AM A FIRST
GENERATION AMERICAN. THE FIRST
ONE IN MY FAMILY TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND THERE ARE SO MANY
MORE LIKE ME. WHO DESERVE
ENOUGH WHICH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REACH OUR FULL POTENTIAL. I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER FOR HER DECADES LONG
FIGHT FOR KIDS LIKE ME. THANK
YOU. I AM A PRODUCT DOCTOR
WEBER OF YOUR FLIGHT. THERE IS
A NEW GENERATION OF
CALIFORNIANS WHOSE VOICE SHOULD
BE HEARD WHO BELIEVE THE PROP
TWO ONE NINE WAS AND CONTINUES
TO BE BAD POLICY. WHO WANT TO
PROVIDE A BETTER FUTURE FOR
THEMSELVES AND FOR GENERATIONS
TO COME. MEMBERS I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO VOTE ON AC A FIVE AND
ALLOW THE VOTERS OF OUR STATE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA UP TO DATE. AND THE
INCLUSIVE AND EQUITABLE
CALIFORNIA UP TOMORROW THAT IS
DESERVING OF THE FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE THE CALL CALIFORNIA
HOME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
CARILLO. MISTER LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- I
WON'T OF REFLECT BACK ON
NINETEEN NINETY SIX AS A
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS HAVE DONE SO
AS A LONG TIME AGO I WAS STILL
DATING WOMEN BACK THEN- AND
THAT WAS VERY VERY LONG TIME
AGO- SO WE'LL JUST LEAVE IT AT
THAT MUCH HAS CHANGED. OKAY SO
BUT NOW THAT I GOT THAT OUT OF
THE WAY. I STAND YOU WITH
SIGNIFICANT MIXED EMOTION. OF
SADNESS. A DEEP ANGER
FRUSTRATION. IN CONFLICT.
YOU'VE HEARD EARLIER ABOUT THIS
NOTION ABOUT WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER JUSTICE FOR ALL.
NINETY BELIEVE IN THAT JUSTICE
IS ONE JUSTICE TO ALL. BUT WE
MUST DO THAT COLLECTIVELY. AND
THIS IS A DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION ABOUT RACE BUT IT
NEEDS TO BE HAD BECAUSE WE ARE
A MICROCOSM OF OUR ELECTRIC.
AND IT CAN'T IT BE DONE IN
ISOLATION. YOUR HEARD FROM THE
AUTHOR THAT THIS LEGISLATION
HAS GREAT SUPPORT FROM MANY
CAUCUSES. NO THAT ONE CAUCUS
THAT'S MISSING. THE API CAUCUS.
WHY WE'RE NOT HAVING A FRANK
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS. WHY IS
THERE SUCH RESISTANCE WHY IS
NOT A SINGLE A PACK CAUCUS
MEMBER A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION. BECAUSE OF THIS
DEEP. FEAR THAT WE WILL LOSE
THAT WE WILL LOSE SEATS. AND
HOW DO WE RECONCILE THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT DEEP PAIN
AND RACE AND CHALLENGES THAT
EXIST THROUGH DIALOGUE. AND I
SUBMIT TO YOU THERE IS BEEN AN
ABSOLUTE ABSENCE OF THAT
DIALOGUE. COLLEAGUES I WAS NOT
EVEN GIVING THE DIGNITY NOT
GIVEN THE DIGNITY. OF HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR
ABOUT THIS THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS HAS NOT COME TO ME TO
ASK ME FOR MY VOTE. NOT A TEXT
MESSAGE ALL NOT A MEDIA REQUEST
NOTHING. AND THAT IS EMBLEMATIC
A PART OF THIS PROBLEM. WE
CAN'T DO THIS IN ISOLATION. YES
WE HAVE A MORAL COMPASS. WE
MUST HAVE CONVERSATIONS
DIFFICULT ONES EVEN WITH THOSE
COMMUNITIES IN OPPOSITION.
BECAUSE ALL THIS TOGETHER RIGHT
WE ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
AND LET'S THINK ABOUT SORT OF
THIS MITCHELL. AN UNCONDITIONAL
ALLY SHIP IT IS MUTUAL IT IS TO
WAIT. AND I SHARE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE DIFFICULTY OF THIS
BECAUSE- I WAS IT JUST DIRECTOR
FOR PAUL FONG WHO IS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS WHEN THIS FIRST CAME
ABOUT. WHO BY THE WAY
SUBSEQUENTLY LOST HIS NEXT
ELECTION BECAUSE OF THIS VOTE.
SO DOES COME POLITICAL PERIL.
BUT I DO NOT RUN FOR OFFICE FOR
SELF PRESERVATION. BUT I BEGIN
TO WONDER THEN WHY IS IT THAT
SO MANY IN MY COMMUNITY ARE IN
OPPOSITION. AREN'T YOU YELLOW.
WHY ARE YOU VOTING AGAINST YOUR
OWN PEOPLE. WHY ARE YOU
PORTRAYING US. THESE ARE FROM
SITTING ELECTED OFFICIALS
TELLING THIS IN MY DISTRICT AND
I WANT TO KNOW IF THIS WAS TRUE
OF THE ENTIRE DISTRICT. BECAUSE
I'VE HAD NINETY NINE CALLS AND
EMAILS IN SUPPORT. AND A
WHOPPING THREE THOUSAND AND
SEVEN HUNDRED IN OPPOSITION.
THIRTY SEVEN TO ONE. YOU MIGHT
THINK OKAY THEY'RE OUT OF THE
DISTRICT WEISSMAN SOMETIMES
LIKE LOOK ABSOLUTELY THE
REGISTERED VOTERS THE REAL
PEOPLE. REAL OPPOSITION SO ONE
OF MY TO DO. WITHOUT EVEN
HAVING THE DECENCY OF A
CONVERSATION TO DISCUSS
DIFFICULTIES OF RACE. AND THIS
INSTITUTION. HAS THE MECHANISMS
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE TALKING
TO EACH OTHER AND IF WE CAN'T
EVEN HAVE THESE TOUGH
CONVERSATIONS WHAT DO YOU
THINK'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE
ELECTORATE. IN WHICH
INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING TO BE
TALKING IN ISOLATION. SO WHY IS
THIS. THE CASE. IT'S ABOUT
POWER IT'S ABOUT FEARS ABOUT
RACE ABOUT THE LOSS OF POWER
AGE WAS ROUNDER'S PARTICULAR
THE CHINESE COMMUNITY FEAR THE
LOSS OF GOOD HARD WORKING
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE THAT IF YOU
DO THE HARD WORK AS YOUR TOLD.
THEY WILL HAVE THE CHANCE AS
WELL TO. MANY OF THEM GOING TO
DEBT BECAUSE OF THE VALUE OF
EDUCATION THAT'S A CULTURAL
THING. SO IF WE UNDERSTAND. THE
REALITIES NO ASIAN BECAUSE OF
UNDER CAUCUS SUPPORT OUR AS
AUTHORS CO AUTHORS OF THIS BILL
THE CLOCK IS MISSING AND WE'VE
SEEN WHAT HAPPENED BEFORE EIGHT
YEARS AGO NOTHING HAS CHANGED
IN TERMS OF THE CONVERSATIONS
THE DIFFICULTY OF THE
CONVERSATIONS. SO WHY IS THAT
THE CASE THAT SO MANY BELIEVE
THIS. MANY IN THE COMMUNITY ARE
RECENT IMMIGRANTS. THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND. THEY DON'T SEND THE
CHALLENGES OF OTHER COMMUNITIES
THAT'S WHY BY THE WAY WE NEED
MANDATORY ETHNIC STUDIES SO WE
CAN LEARN ABOUT THE HISTORY OF
ALL OF US AS A CULTURE SO YOU
REMEMBER THE UNCANNY PARALLELS
WITH THE CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT
LAW OF NINETEEN THIRTEEN WHICH
FOR BID ASIAN AMERICANS FROM.
OWNING PROPERTY. OR EVEN IN MY
COMMITTEE. THE DISCRIMINATION
WITH PROPOSITION EIGHT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT WHICH
ELIMINATE THE RIGHTS OF SAME
SEX COUPLES TO MARRY. AND THE
MESSAGE IS ACTUALLY REALLY
CLEAR TO ASIA PROVIDERS YOU
WANT THE BEST WAY TO GET. YOUR
CHILD YOUR KID AND HIGHER
EDUCATION GO TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WE HAVE PROPERTY
TRANSFERS. AND BY THE WAY AT
THE END OF COMMITTEE CALL IT'S
LIKE MINE IN MY COMMUNITY 79%
TRANSFER RATES THE UC SYSTEM
THAT'S THE BEST WAY. TO GET IT.
SO ABSOLUTELY IT'S APPROPRIATE
FOR US TO TALK ABOUT. THESE
CONVERSATIONS THESE ISSUES.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO HAVE RACE
NEUTRAL POLICIES FOR VERY VERY
SPECIFIC PROBLEMS. THIRTY
SECONDS MR LOW. AND SO TODAY MY
VOTE WILL BE BASED SOLELY ON MY
CONSCIENCE AND MY COMMITMENT TO
MY CONVICTION AND AS WE STARTED
THIS CONVERSATION TODAY WITH
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE FOR
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
TECHNICIAN LOW THANK YOU
MEMBERS. MISTER SPEAKER YOUR
RECOGNITION OR THE CHAMBER
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS FOR A VIGOROUS- DEBATE
TODAY- PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE
ALONG WITH PROPOSITION ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH THE TWO-
MOMENTS IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY
THAT REALLY LED TO MY
POLITICAL. AWAKENING TODAY I
THOUGHT BOTH WERE BAD IDEAS AND
I THINK- I STILL THINK BOTH ARE
BAD IDEAS. TODAY THANKS TO THE
AUTHOR WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT ONE OF
THOSE TWO VERY BAD IDEAS. AND
TODAY IS BEYOND TIME TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. REALITY IS
FINALLY CATCHING UP WITH THOSE
WHO HOLDING GRAIN
MISCONCEPTIONS OF RACE AND
GENDER RELATIONS. WE KNOW NOW
THAT SAYING WE ARE RACE COLOR
BLIND IS THE SAME AS SAYING WE
ARE BLIND TO HISTORY. THE SAME
WAY THAT SO MANY HAVE BEEN
BLIND TO POLICE BRUTALITY. TO
SAY THAT FEMINISM MEANS
TREATING WOMEN EXACTLY THE SAME
AS MEN. IS THE DENIAL OF THE
LONG TIME AFFECTS. A TURKEY. WE
CAN LEARN FROM THE PAST. AND WE
MUST KEEP LEARNING. EACH OF US
CAME INTO THIS WORLD WITH THE
SAME INTRINSIC VALUE. BUT
SOCIAL NORMS AN IMPLICIT BIAS
HAVE TIPPED THE SCALES AGAINST
US AND WE HAVE SEEN RESEARCH
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN
THAT BEARS THIS OUT. WE MUST
ALLOW FOR SOLUTIONS. THAT
PROVIDE A COUNTERBALANCE TO
UNFAIR ADVANTAGES. WE CAN BE
FAIR. WE CAN DIGEST WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD. BUT PROPOSITION TWO OH
NINE STANDS IN OUR WAY. I ASK
YOUR RIVALS RACY ACA FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
DOCTOR WEBER. YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
THANKS TO SO MANY OF YOU WHO
HAVE STOOD IN SPOKEN TODAY AND-
HAVE EXPRESSED YOUR CONCERN OF
YOUR INTERESTS THE IN THIS. WE
BEGIN BY FIRST OF ALL SAYING
THAT IT WAS NOT MY DESIRE TO BE
THE PRIMARY AUTHOR ON A CA FIVE.
OF IT WAS A GROUP THING AND I
HOPE THAT SOMEONE ELSE WOULD
BASICALLY LEAD THE CHARGE
BECAUSE I WOULD WAS EXHAUSTED
FROM LAST YEAR FROM THREE NINE
TWO AND SO I DIDN'T VOLUNTEER
TO CHEER THIS IT WAS A GROUP
THING THAT WE MET WITH
COMMUNITIES AND ORGANIZATIONS
AND SOMEHOW OR ANOTHER PEOPLE
JUST ASSUMED THAT I WAS THE
MAIN AUTHOR. AND AS A RESULT MY
NAME COMES FIRST EVEN ONE LAST
IN THE ALPHABET. WITH REGARD TO
THIS. SO FOR WHATEVER REASON A
IT WAS NOT MY INTENT TO DO THAT.
I WHEN I BEGAN MY PRESENTATION
TODAY I WAS GOING TO APOLOGIZE
TO MANY OF YOU. BECAUSE YOU
KNOW MY STRATEGY GENERALLY IS
TO TALK TO PEOPLE. TO TRY TO
GET TO YOU TO GET TO YOUR
OFFICE TO ACTUALLY HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU. AND A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF YOU I WAS
NOT ABLE TO DO THAT. MAINLY
BECAUSE WE WERE QUARANTINED AND
WE WERE HERE AND WE WERE THERE
AND TIME WAS RUNNING OUT AND SO
WE HAVE A VERY LIMITED AMOUNT
OF TIME. AND I HAD TO RELY UPON
OTHERS TO DO SOME OF THE
CONVERSATION FOR ME. THE API
COMMUNITY CHOSE THE CAUCUS
CHOSE TO DO ITS OWN
CONVERSATION WITH ITS MEMBERS.
AND SO THAT'S WHY YOU DIDN'T
NECESSARILY HEAR FROM ME. BUT
YOUR OWN MEMBERS CHOSE TO DO
THAT. AND THE SAME IS TRUE WITH
THE LATINO CAUCUS. BECAUSE
THERE WERE ALL THESE CAUCUSES
IN EACH ONE HAD A
RESPONSIBILITY TO GET ENGAGE
WITH THEIR PERSONS. AND COME
BACK TO ME AND TELL ME WHERE
THEY WORK. THE LAST I HEARD WAS
I WAS SUPPOSED TO HAVE A
MEETING ORGANIZED WITH YOU. THE
MISTER GIBSON I BELIEVE IT WAS.
AND SOME OTHERS AND SO IT WAS
NOT THAT I WAS IGNORING YOU IS
THAT WE HAD A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
TIME COMING BACK. AND SO VERY
FEW OF YOU I HAD REALLY A
CHANCE TO REACH OUT TO. AND I
GOT THE INFORMATION FROM OTHERS
AND EVENTUALLY. GOT FOUND OUT
WHERE PEOPLE WERE WITH REGARD
TO SOMEONE APOLOGIZE AS I WAS
GOING TO BECAUSE- MY STRATEGY
HAS ALWAYS BEEN TO MEET IF YOU
INDIVIDUALLY. AND SO THAT WAS
THEN BEING TOLD WHO POTENTIALLY
I NEEDED TO CALL. BECAUSE WE
WERE RUNNING TIME AND NOT
BECAUSE I WAS TRYING TO IGNORE
ANYONE BUT I WAS GETTING
INFORMATION FROM VARIOUS
SOURCES. I SEE FOR DOES SOME OF
YOU I DIDN'T REACH OUT TO. BUT
WHEN YOU'VE GOT GET FIFTY FOUR.
AND YOU A VERY LIMITED OF TIME
WE HAVE TO MAXIMIZE. WHAT
YOU'RE DOING I HAD MUCH MORE
TIME WITH THREE NINE TWO. NINE
THREE ONE COMBINED AND ALL
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. SO LET
ME THAT USE THAT SAY THAT THIS
WAS NOT MY INTENT TO DO THIS.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS OTHER
REASON IS BECAUSE- IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT. TO TALK ABOUT RACE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU ARE A
PERSON WHO SEES IT EVERYWHERE
IT'S VERY HARD NOT TO SAY THERE
IS THERE IS THERE IS THERE IT
IS BECAUSE THEN YOU BECOME THE
PERSON WHO'S ALWAYS SO BREAKS
CONSCIOUS. PEOPLE START
AVOIDING YOU DISLIKING YOU SO I
TRY TO SAVE MY RACE
CONVERSATIONS FOR THE REAL BIG
RACE ISSUES. NOT THE LITTLE
ONES BECAUSE IF YOU DO THE
OTHER YOU'RE OVER PEOPLE BEGIN
TO AVOID YOU. AND THEN YOU
BECOME INEFFECTIVE AND YOUR
ABILITY TO TEACH THEM ABOUT THE
BIG THINGS AND SO I TRY NOT TO
BECAUSE OF THAT AND I TRIED NOT
TO ALSO BECAUSE IT'S VERY
PAINFUL FOR ME. A PERSON WHO'S
LIVED AS LONG AS I'VE LIVED.
I'M SEVENTY ONE I'LL BE SEVENTY
TWO IN SEPTEMBER. HAS LIVED AS
LONG AS I LIVE. HAS SEEN SO
MUCH TRY SO HARD TRY TO HELP
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND HOW I FEEL
WHAT I SEE IN MY CHILDREN AND
MY COMMUNITY WHAT I SEE MY
RELATIVES HOW I SEE THE HURT
AND THE PAIN THAT THEY FEEL IN
THE DISCRIMINATION THAT THEY'RE
INVOLVED WITH. AND SOME PEOPLE
THINK WELL YOU'VE GOT IT ALL
SURELY YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT THE
CAREER YOU'VE GOT YOU KNOW A
SUCCESSFUL LIFE YOU'VE GOT THE
BIG HOUSE YOU'VE GOT ALL THESE
THINGS BUT I STILL HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT I STILL HAVE
NEIGHBORS I SEE SICK CHILDREN
AND I STILL WOULDN'T SCHOOLS
WHAT I SEE THAT THERE THE
FUTURE IS BLOCKED. AND I KNOW
THAT BUT FOR THE GRACE OF GOD
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN ME.
BECAUSE BECAUSE IT'S IT BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT IT IS IN TERMS OF
THE FAMILY THE RELATIVES THAT
YOU SEE. AND SO WHEN I HEAR
PEOPLE SAY YEAH I KNOW IT'S
THERE BUT I WANT TO DO THIS AND
I WANT TO DO THAT I WANT TO DO
IS I WANTED ALL THOSE THINGS TO.
AND YES WE MUST SARCHIE TO A
PROBLEM. WE MUST SO THAT'S WHY
IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO ME THAT WE
SAW THAT PROBLEM. BUT I'VE ALSO
LEARNED THAT IN THE PROCESS OF
THE STRUGGLE. BUT I CAN'T JUST
DO K. TWELVE. BECAUSE INTO THE
GENERATION UP YOU THIS I'M ALSO
LOSING. AS I'VE GOT TO HELP
THEM AS WELL. AND I'VE GOT TO
HELP PEOPLE GET INTO THAT AND
I'VE ALSO GOT TO HELP PEOPLE
GET CONTRACTS BECAUSE- I SEE
THE VISION. BEING KILLED IN THE
EYES OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHEN THEY
CAN'T GET THESE CONTRACTS OF
THESE JOBS. I SEE THE FACT THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH- KIDS OF
COLOR NOW IN A PRINT YOUR
PROGRAM. SO WHEN I GO ON WORK
SITES I SEE. ALMOST VERY FEW.
AFRICAN A- ITS OWN. LETTING TO
PRINT YOUR PROGRAM. WITH THERE
IS NO. OF REACH THEM TO. INTO
THE- IN SO WE HAVE CONSTRUCTION
A THIS THE PEOPLE CALL ME THE
CAP SAYS NO AFTER AMERICAN BILL
THAT BUILDING ACROSS THE STREET.
AND WE HAD TO GO TO THE
GOVERNOR AND WE HAVE NO PROGRAM
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT HAPPENS
OF THIS DIVERSITY ON A WORK
SITE. AND SO EVENTUALLY WILL
REALIZE AHA THERE'S NO AFRICAN
AMERICAN SO THAT WHEN FOUND
THREE OF THEM WHO ARE. WELL
QUALIFIED TO DO IRON WORK ON ON
THE BUILDING ACROSS THE STREET.
THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT I SEE
IN A DIFFICULT TO EXPLAIN. BUT
I DO KNOW THAT WHEN I WORKED
UNDER NEATH AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
AND I SPENT THOSE YEARS AT THE
UNIVERSITY I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HELP PEOPLE. I KNOW THAT MY
PROFESSOR HELPED ME THAT HAD HE
NOT BEEN ON THE CAMPUS OF UCLA
I WOULD NEVER BEEN A WHICH WILL
SOON FOLLOW. I WOULD HAVE NEVER
GONE TO GRADUATE SCHOOL. AS IT
WOULD TOO MANY OTHER PEOPLE
PULLING ME AWAY BUT HE WAS
THERE AS THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
ON CAMPUS TO HELP US. NAVIGATE
HE DIDN'T TAKE MY TEST HE COULD
WRITE MY DISSERTATION HE
COULDN'T DO THOSE THINGS BUT HE
COULD ENCOURAGE ME TO CONTINUE
TO MOVE FORWARD. HE COULD BE A
ROLE MODEL FOR ME IF YOU COULD
LIFT ME UP WHEN TIMES ARE
DIFFICULT AS THEY TRIED TO PUT
ME OUT OF SCHOOL. AND YET I
HAVE A HIGH GPA IN THE
DEPARTMENT GRADUATED EARLY THAN
ANYBODY ELSE. AND YET THE
RACISM OF THE WHITE MALE. PART
AND WANTED TO DESTROY ME AND
THEY MADE EVERY EFFORT TO TRY
TO DO IT. AND WHAT NOT FOR THIS
THIS GENTLEMAN WHO WAS A
SCHOLAR. AND A ROLE MODEL FOR
ME THEY WOULD HAVE DONE THAT.
AND SO I HAD A COMMITMENT WHEN
I BEGAN TO TEACH THAT I HAD TO
OPEN THESE DOORS EVERY YOUNG
PERSON I EVER SAW. TO MAKE SURE
OF THAT. NOT ONLY AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS BUT I BELIEVE
THE WHITE STUDENTS WHO CAME
INTO MY CLASS A BETTER PEOPLE
RIGHT NOW. BECAUSE OF THE
DIVERSITY THAT WAS IN THAT
CLASSROOM. THEY HAVE FRIENDS IT
DIDN'T LOOK LIKE THEM THAT WE
COULD CHALLENGE SIMILAR FOUGHT
TO MAKE AN CHALLENGE US. AND
THEY GREW FROM SIMPLY BEING IN
THE MIDST OF THEM AND IT MADE
CALIFORNIA IT MADE A UNIVERSAL
MAKE CALIFORNIA A BETTER PLACE
FOR PEOPLE TO BE. SO WHEN WE
START TALKING ABOUT THIS IS
EVERYTHING. IT IS NOT JUST
GETTING IN THE UNIVERSITY. IT'S
HAVING SUPPORT SYSTEMS WHY YOU
BETTER KEEP YOU THERE. IS
COMMITTING A STANDARD YOU
DIDN'T A RESPONSE. TO DO
LIKEWISE. THAT WHEN YOU WILL
HAVE A WORK SITE AND PEOPLE
COME TO THAT WORKS LIKE THAT IS
SO DIFFERENT. THAT'S WHAT YOU
WALK ABOUT WAS HE YOU WALK OFF
SINCE. YOU SEE STREET. TO THE
MY THIS. BUT YOU KNOW I ALSO
DID I TELL ALL MY- THAT THEY
HAD A HIGH BLACKS. AND THE- IS
TO. THERE IS A WHEN YOU INTO
OFFICES. CUT SANDY. EVERYBODY
HAS A THESE WERE BLACK. WORK AT
OFFICE THAT NAY DID THE BEFORE.
WHY BECAUSE THAT IS A- SO I HAD
YOU TODAY TO GIVE CAL. A CHANGE.
GIVE A THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE
ON THIS IS A NOT BUT JUST THAT
WE GOT TO HAVE A- BUT THAT. IN
A- NEEDS TO KNOW WHAT. AND THE
RE. INTO FOR THIS QUE. TO
BERKELEY WHEN I. MY CAN. TIME
IN. IT YOU WANT TO REPEAL PROP
BLOOM. THINK ABOUT WHAT WOULD
DO WE HAVE A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY. A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY. AND I WAS SO
GRATEFUL I DIDN'T HAVE TO
CONVINCE YOU THAT RACISM IS
REAL BECAUSE- GEORGE FOR DID
THAT. SO THAT WAS ONE
CONVERSATION THAT I DIDN'T HAVE
TO HAVE ABOUT THIS ISSUE. WE
HAVE TO ADMIT IT IS REAL. AND
IT IS THERE THAT IS PRESENT AND
IN THE PAST NOT JUST THE LIVES
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS WITH
EVERYONE IN THIS COUNTRY. AND
AS A LEGISLATURE WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO FIGURE OUT
EVERY WAY THAT WE POSSIBLY CAN
TO IMPACT THAT AND IT WOULD NOT
BE ONE THING. TWO NINE THE
REMOVING TOLD I WILL NOT SOLVE
ALL THE PROBLEMS. BUT IT'S ONE
OF THE MANY TOOLS THAT WE HAVE
TO HAVE A CALIFORNIA TO SAY
CALIFORNIA IS THE LAND OF GREAT
OPPORTUNITY. AND THOSE WHO CAME
HERE IS IDEA THREE YEARS OLD
THEY CAME HERE BECAUSE THEY
KNEW THEY COULD GET BETTER
THINGS YOU THAN THEY COULD IN
MISSISSIPPI AND ALABAMA IN
OTHER PLACES LIKE THAT. BUT THE
SUN WAS SHINING BRIGHTER IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THEIR FUTURE
WOULD BE BRIGHTER AS WELL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IDLE FOR A
CA FIVE. THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER
WITH AT THE CORPORATE LEVEL THE
ROLE MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WELL. CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS NINE THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO THE SENATE. CRAZY A FIVE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ITEMS ON CALL
WE ALSO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. IS ANY MEMBER WISH
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE THE CLERK WILL READ THE
SECOND A CONSENT CALENDAR SOME
AGO NINETEEN FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
FISHERIES. CLARK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE IN. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. WE DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CLARK
WELL. THE CLOSER ROLE I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED CLERK WILL
READ THE REMAINING ITEMS.
ASSEMBLY TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
WITH URGENCY I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY I SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE VAN
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE I SEVENTY TWO THOSE
ZERO. MEMBERS WE HAVE THREE
ITEMS ON CALL AND COMPARED TO
LIVE THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
SIXTY ONE PARTY FILE ITEM.
ACTION FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
FOUR THIS IS AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SIX. AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SIX QUIRK OPPOSE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
YEAH RIGHT. WORK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE VOTE EYES FORTY THREE
NOTES NINETEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES. CAN I PREPARE TO LET
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO
THIS IS AB TWENTY SIX NINETY BY
MR LOW FOR PROPOSED. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY THREE KNOWS
FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY EIGHT
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY NINE
AGAIN MY MISTER LOWE COVERS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO VOTE.
WORK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE THE
VOTE AYE AYES FORTY FIVE KNOWS
TEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS THURSDAY JUNE
ELEVENTH FLOOR SESSION AT NINE
AM FRIDAY JUNE TWELFTH NO FLOOR
SESSION NO CHECKING SESSION ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING
NO FOR THE BUSINESS I AM READY
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION. TO
ADJOURN MISTER GIBSON MOOSE AND%
MISTER FLORA SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY JUNE ELEVENTH AT TEN
AM IN THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.